COMING TO ORDER AND IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING. IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE
HAS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
TODAY WITH SOME ABLE IN DOCTOR
PAN AND CENTER MELENDEZ WILL BE
JOINING US TODAY HERE IN PERSON.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
ALL. PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FOR THE REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
FROM ME PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE
OR COMPUTERS WILL ELIMINATE ANY
CAUSTIC FEEDBACK. EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO RE RECOGNIZE PLEASE
USE THE RAISE OUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. AND THEN WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND
YOU. SELECT THAT AND BEGIN
MAKING YOUR COMMENTS. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WILL BE
USING A TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY REMOTELY.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE REMOTE
COMMENT TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR
ONE SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO TESTIMONY. WHICH
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING. SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS NEEDED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS BUT WE
DO ASK FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
EVERYBODY'S VOICE SHOULD COUNT
AND WE WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL.
OF EVERYBODY PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AT NOW WILL BEGIN THE
PRESENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. TEST FIRES. WELCOME AND
IF YOU COULD NOT. BEGIN TAKE
YOUR TESTIMONY. IN ORDER TO
HEAR FROM THE L. A. O. AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AFTER YOU
CONCLUDE- YOU'VE BEEN ASKED A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS. ABOUT
FIRST YOU GONNA DO AN OVERVIEW
OF THE DEPARTMENT. GOOD MORNING
SHARING SENATORS. I'M DOCTOR
THE MASBATE GONE THE NEW. STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE AT YOUR
SERVICE. I COME TO STATES
SERVICE FROM WORKING IN LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH MISSION IS TO
ADVANCE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE PEOPLE
AND COMMUNITIES. OUR VISION IS
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES WITH
THRIVING FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS. THE WORK CDPH IS
FACILITATED THROUGH OUR CENTERS
AND OFFICES. ROB THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IT IS SUPPORTED BY A
BUDGET OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND FOUR POINT TWO BILLION
PROPOSED FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. THIS IS A
SLIGHT- TWO POINT FOUR TWO
POINT 4% DECREASE FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR. FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ABOUT 38% OF OUR FUNDING COMES
FROM APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
SPECIAL FUNDS. ABOUT 37% COMES
FROM FEDERAL FUNDS AND
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF OUR BUDGET
COMES FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
THIS FUND SUPPORTS OUR TEAM OF
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED STAFF AND OVER TWO
HUNDRED PROGRAM AREAS. THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS AND ALL
OUT IN OUR ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
PROGRAM. FUNDING TO SUPPORT A
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
AND HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
FUNDING TO SUPPORT OUR RESPONSE
TO THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE ON
YOUR AGENDA TODAY FOR
DISCUSSION WITH MEMBERS OF OUR
LEADERSHIP TEAM. OVERALL FIFTY
PAGES A FUNDAMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY ARE
COMPREHENSIVE IN SCOPE INCLUDE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION. FOOD SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH LABORATORY
SERVICES PATIENT SAFETY CHRONIC
DISEASE PREVENTION AND HEALTH
PROMOTION CAN FAMILY MATERNAL
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT HEALTH.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO PROTECTS
PATIENT SAFETY IN HOSPITALS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
MAINTAIN BIRTH AND DEATH
CERTIFICATES AND PREPARES FOR A
RESPONSE TO A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY SUCH AS PANDEMIC.
WHICH HAS WHICH OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN AT RISK RESPONDING-
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY
TWENTY. ALL HAPPY TO GO INTO
SOME OF THOSE RESPONSE EFFORTS
AS OUTLINED IN ISSUE TOO SO
WE'RE WE'RE READY TO MOVE
FORWARD OR IF YOU WANT WE CAN
TAKE A FEW QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW.
A DOCTRINE. I THANK YOU-
BACKGROUND AND IT AND THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP OF- THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DEPARTMENT AND TO
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY THE
CALIFORNIA PART PUBLIC HEALTH I
DID JUST HAVE A FEW. QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT FUNDING
SUMMARY- UNDER REIMBURSEMENTS-
OH NINE NINE FIVE- BUT NICK
MAKE NOTE IS THAT THE- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. REVISED IS ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS BUT THE PROPOSED TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO GOES BACK DOWN.
I GUESS BACK TO THE BASE LINE
WHICH WE HAD BETWEEN NINETEEN.
TWENTY TO TWO BY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION. CAN YOU
JUST GIVE ME A BRIEF
EXPLANATION AS TO WHAT THE-
RICE I CAN SORT OF GUESS BUT- I
DON'T I GUESS I JUST WANNA KNOW
WHAT THE- SO WHEN UP TO SEVEN
FOURTEEN. MILLION A HUNDRED
MILLION. BACK DOWN TO BEING
PROPOSED FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION WHAT THIS
REIMBURSEMENT IS AN IS THAT. DO
WE REALLY EXPECTED TO DROP THAT
MUCH AGAIN SINCE I WELL AS I
SHOULD ASSUME WHAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT IS AYE. ITS
BIGGEST CODE RELATED BUT WE'RE
STILL INCOME IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- SO- I HAVE I HAVE RATED
NUDISM. HE CAN GIVE YOU A WANNA
MAKE SURE GIVING OUR- RISK.
BRANDON OKAY YOU. THOROUGHBRED
IS IN THERE IS IN OUR ROOM.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET HIM UP
RIGHT NOW THERE IS VERY HIGH.
THANK YOU. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES OKAY PERFECT SORRY ABOUT
THAT- YEAR CORRECT MY NAME IS
BRANDON IS ON THE CHIEF DEPUTY
FOR OPERATIONS OR THE
DEPARTMENT YOU'RE CORRECT THE
INCREASE IN REIMBURSEMENT-
REFLECTS SOME OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE
EUROPEAN LAB CAPACITY GRAHAM-
THAT FUNDING- WHAT INCREASE IN
OCCURRING HERE TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR THAT'S WHY YOU
DIDN'T COMPARISON TO THIS DROP
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
HOWEVER YOUR AWARE WE DID
RECEIVE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FROM THE L. G. GRANT CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION. I THINK MOST OF THAT
IS GOING TO BE COMING- FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANT BEGINNING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT- BUT
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE SEEN THAT
CAN ARISE IN REIMBURSEMENT THIS
PRIMARILY THROUGH THAT AT THE
IN LAP ABOUT THE GRANT THAT
OKAY SO I GUESS MY THEN THE
QUESTION IS THAT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE PURPOSE. BECAUSE
IT LOOKS YOU PUT IN ALL THESE
FOR MARKER CENTURY BACK DOWN TO
BASE- IS- AND THEN AGAIN WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WE
MIGHT GET- AND IN THAT TIME IS
A GUESS IS THERE GONNA BE A
REVISION IN MAY TWO BETTER
PROJECT WHAT WE MIGHT BE A
RECEIVING IN REGARDS TO- TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO STARTING JULY OR
ARE WE JUST GONNA CENTER AND
THIS IS JAX WEALTH IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE WILL
BE REVIEWING AVAIL SEVERAL
RESOURCES ARE PROVIDE. YEAH
WHEN WE PREVENT FOR HER SHE
PEOPLE WE THE BUT- THIS
PARTICULAR FEDERAL IT WASN'T
WAS A QUICK TRIP ACROSS BOB
WILL BE REFER THAT AND ANY
ADDITIONAL TO RE WE RECEIVE
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS SO. OBESE LEVELS
THAT OKAY THANK FOR YOU- YOU
KNOW I KNOW THE AND FOR WE DO
MAYBE THINGS TEND TO VERY BY
THE IT'S AND THAT- THIS COULD
OR SOMETHING HAS ENOUGH TIME TO
DO AND OF EXACTLY YOU KNOW HOW
MY FUNDING GETTING WE KNOW
RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY TO THE
PART PUBLIC HEALTH AND THEN ONE
OTHER QUICK. AND YOU ON THESE
FUNDS ARE LICENSE SORT OF. FOR
YOU KNOW IT'S GONE UP FOR ONE
HUNDRED NINE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWELVE BEGIN AND THEN NOW WE'RE
PER FOR ONE TWENTY TWO A TWO
HUNDRED SAID. HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SEEMS TO BE A BIT OF AN
IN- IS THERE WHAT WHAT
EXPECTING WITH MY SIR FUND A
WEEK SUCH A AND- OFFERED THIS
FOR THE NEXT YEAR. AND ABOUT.
ABSOLUTELY SO- YOU MAY RECALL-
PRAYER. REPLY THERE'S AN-
MILLION. IN IN OUR BUDGET FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FROM. AND
SORT OF A- UP PRIMARY WAS OR-
BECAUSE- A COUPLE LEGISLATURE.
AGO A LOT OF OUR LIFE AND BEING
WORKED ON LA. HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS DONE THROUGH A CONTRACT
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY RIGHT A
COUPLE BUDGET CYCLES AGO
PROPOSALS BUT BOARD FOR THE NEW
THREE YEAR CONTRACT WITH. L. A.
COUNTY. AND THAT BASIN SOME
RESOURCES OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO IS KIND OF THE
LAST YEAR OF THAT THREE YEAR
PERIOD. AND IT REFLECTS THAT IN
ROUGHLY NINETEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE TO REFLECT THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WERE
PROVIDED FOR L. A. COUNTY AND I
PROPOSAL A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
ALL RIGHT THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE EXPLANATION.
THANK THURMOND IS. THANK YOU
MAY CHAIR- I'D WOULD LIKE TO
COME OUT FOR ME- ACTIVITIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS HAD TO
PUSH ASIDE BECAUSE OF THE FOCUS
THAT HAS HAD BEEN PLACED ON
KOPET. I KNOW THAT CURRENTLY
OUR DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW HE IS
COMPILING THAT INFORMATION- I
DON'T HAVE A TEAM I DON'T HAVE
IT AT THE MOMENT BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WILL MAKE
AVAILABLE TO YOU AS SOON AS
IT'S READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE NOTE THERE ARE SEVEN
MAJOR DEPARTMENTS- THAT
COMPRISED. PUBLIC HEALTH MAJOR
AT THEM. AND I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION WHAT ARE WE
MISSING AS WERE AS WE'RE GOING
FULL FORCE ON THE PANDEMIC.
OKAY AFTER WE WELCOME YOU DR
GONE TO THE THANK YOU TO THIS
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND THIS
CONVERSATION. AND I THINK WE
CAN MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO AND
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING SENATORS-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR- THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED A MANY OF
DR ERIC UPON I AM THE STATE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES- SO THIS
MORNING I'LL START WITH- THE
REQUEST FOR AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
CURRENT CASE RATES
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND MORTALITY
STATISTICS FOR CALIFORNIA- WE
ARE AT JUST OVER THREE POINT
THREE MILLION CASES- ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND. NEW CASES TODAY ARE-
DALY CASE RIGHT OR SEVEN DAY
AVERAGES AROUND TWENTY SIX
POINT FIVE AND- ALL OF THESE
TRENDS ARE OF THINK THE
DECREASING- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS- WE HAVE A SEVEN
DAY TEST POSITIVITY OF FOUR
POINT 3% WHICH IS ALSO
IMPROVING OVER TIME- AS FAR AS
OUR HOSPITALIZATIONS- ARE
STATEWIDE HOSPITAL SEVENTY
HOURS OF NEW ADMISSIONS WHICH
IS SOMETHING WE'RE WATCHING
VERY CLOSELY HAS. DECREASED BY
ALMOST TWENTY FOUR PERCENT. AND
THEN THE CODE POSITIVE PATIENTS
AND HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN ARE
JUST ABOVE 50% OF WHAT THEY
WERE AT THE PEAK OF OUR SEARCH
JUST OVER THE HOLIDAY SEASON
SO- HUSTLER DEFINITELY
DECOMPRESSING AND I SEE YOU
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT SLOWER.
TO DECOMPRESS WE HAVE ABOUT 62%
OF THE PATIENTS AND I SEE YOU
COMPARED TO THE PEAK. OF THE
SURGE BUT DEFINITELY ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS- SO WE'RE
SEEING VERY ENCOURAGING TRENDS
AS FAR AS THAT- AS FAR AS
MENTALITY. THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
DEATHS IS- JUST OVER FORTY SIX
THOUSAND AND THAT IS DEFINITELY
A LAGGING INDICATOR SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO SEE- REPORTS
SOMETIMES THESE ARE- SIXTY
WEEKS EVEN OF- DATES OF. PAST
DATES OF DEATH I WANT TO POINT
OUT ACTUALLY THAT WE ARE- ARE
KEY STRAIGHT THOUGH I MEAN OUR
DEATH RATE PER CAPITA IS A
HUNDRED THIRTEEN PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LOWEST PER CAPITA DEATHS
AMONGST THE LARGE STATES.
SOMETHING I THINK WE SHOULD BE
PROUD OF IS A STATE. FOR HOW
WELL WE HAVE DONE THEIR- AND
THEN KIND OF MOVE FOR ON- SORT
OF AN OVER OF THE STRATEGIES
THAT WE HAVE- HOW DO WE THINK
ABOUT OUR STATE'S TO FROM RISK
FOR CO NINETEEN SO OUR OVERALL
NAY. RELATED TO THIS IS A THE
AND HEALTH INCOME WHILE BELL
THEM OF HOW SOCIETY ECONOMY. SO
THERE SEVEN STRESS ARE OF A
BUCKET WE THINK ABOUT IS OUR
STRATEGY SO WE WON OF COURSE AN
INCREDIBLY ONE THAT I JUST
HIGHLIGHTED WAS MONITORING THE
SCOPE AND THE PROGRESS ND
PANDEMIC TO INFORM THE SPONSOR
OF THE SURVEILLANCE IS THE DAY
THAT I JUST MENTIONED- ALSO
INCLUDING MODELING AND
PROJECTIONS ARE AS YOU WELL
KNOW WE'VE- BEEN LOOKING AT ICE
YOU CAPACITY IN PROJECTING THAT
FORWARD PROTECTING HOSPITAL
CAPACITY FOR REALLY HELPS AS
WITH PLANNING AND RESPONSE AND
RESOURCES- AS WELL AS THINKING
ABOUT ONE. ONE NON
PHARMACEUTICAL INTERVENTIONS TO
RECOMMEND- WE ALSO DO A LOT OF
ANALYSIS OF OUR DATA AND-
REALLY IS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTING THE DISPARATE
IMPACTS OF THIS PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED AS FAR AS THE
INEQUITIES- AND REALLY TRYING
TO PROVIDE METRICS AND
INDICATORS TO MONITOR AND
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS- AND THEN
REALLY- REALLY CRUCIAL TO ALL
THOSE WHICH OF COURSE ISN'T
HIGHLIGHTED THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC IS HOW. IMPORTANT FOR
DATA THE I. T. SYSTEMS ARE SO-
MAKING SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
RISE UP AND THAT IS GOING TO BE
A THEME CERTAINLY AROUND THIS
RESPONSE AND MY DISCUSSION OF
THAT OF OUR SECOND STRATEGY OF
COURSE IS DEVELOPING A POLICIES
THAT THEN YOU KNOW OUR INFORMED
ABOUT IT BY THAT DATA AND
SUPPORT THIS MISSION SO
PROVIDING A SCIENCE BASED
EVIDENCE BASED FRAMEWORK FOR US
A FREE OPENING OF THE ECONOMY
TO MINIMIZE THESE HEALTH
IMPACTS- SO EVERYTHING WE'VE
DONE TO DEVELOP THE BLUEPRINTS-
FURCIFER. WITH THE TEARS ALSO
DEVELOPING ALL THE SAFE- SORT
OF GUIDELINES AND PROTOCOLS AND
DIRECTIVES WE HAVE RELATED TO
DIFFERENT SETTINGS INCLUDING
SCHOOLS. REOPENING AND OF A
PRODDING AT GROUPON. AND ON- WE
WANT OF COURSE ALLOW. ALL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTHCARE
POLICIES ACTION WITH CHANGING.
IN OF PENN. WHICH BEEN RAPIDLY
CHANGING OVER THE ENTIRE AT NOW
SIR. MY I THINK WE'RE ARE IN
THIS AND THEN I. THE THIRD
STRATEGY IS- MITIGATE AND
SUPPRESSING COME NINETEEN SO
MID. BY AGAIN DIRECTING PREVENT
EFFORTS AND NONE OF OUR IS
STILL GOING- TO MINIMIZE THE-
HEALTH. OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW
THE MORE EXTREME IN THE OF
COURSE IS A STATE ORDER.
MASKING ALL OF THOSE IN. NOT
PHARMACEUTICAL. AND THEN
SUPPRESSING AND CONTAINMENT IS
REALLY ABOUT TO FOR PROVIDING
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES TO OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WHO
ARE THEN DOING THE CASE
DETECTION WHICH IS TESTING-
WE'LL TALK A LOT MORE ABOUT
LABORATORY PASSED IN TESTING
THE NEXT QUESTION- AND THEN
ONCE YOU DETECT THIS CASE IS
YOU HAVE TO INVESTIGATE THEM
AND THEN YOU DO CONTACT TRACING
AND THEN. ISOLATION AND
QUARANTINE SO ALL OF THOSE
EFFORTS ARE JUST PRESSING
CONTAINS SPECIALLY WHEN THEIR
CASE NUMBERS ON LOTTO. AND THAT
REALLY IS THROUGH THE ARMS OF
OUR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
PARTNERS THE SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH RESTRICTIONS. AGAIN A
LOT OF IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT AND THE NEXT
QUESTION. AND THEN OUR ROLE THE
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS
HEALTH PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR OUTBREAK
CONTROL- ESPECIALLY IN OUR
STATE HOSPITALS AND A LOT OF
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
HOMES WE HAVE A LARGE HEALTH
CARE SAYS INFECTION PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES THAT TA- SO GET
ALL THE HIGHER SETTING SUCH AS-
THE NURSING FACILITIES
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
WORKPLACES SCHOOLS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY SETTINGS AS WELL SO
WE PROVIDE THAT TA TO THE LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS AND ALSO HELP
COURTNEY WHEN THERE'S A MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL OUTBREAK- WE
ALSO. YOU KNOW WORK TO DEVELOP%
AND PROVIDE INNOVATIVE AND
EQUITABLE SOLUTION FOR CHANGING
THE. COURSE THE PENTAX. AND
THEN THE OTHER THE STREET- IS
COORDINATING ITS OPERATING. THE
STATE WHAT KERRY. AND PHARMACY
AND- SO. OF COURSE THE BIGGEST.
RIGHT NOW WHICH- AN- ANOTHER
QUESTION WHERE WILL- DIVE
DEEPER AND THIS IS. PROVIDING
AN EQUITABLE THE NINETEEN
VACCINE IS. PLAN AND THAT. CAL
BASED ON THE SUPPLY- AND THEN
ALSO ALLOCATING. GOVERNMENT'S
ANTI VIRAL AND ANTIBODY
TREATMENTS WHICH ARE STILL AN
ONGOING. ACTIVITY AND THEN
REALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS LAST SURGE- AND
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN MONITORING AND SUPPORTING
THE HEALTHCARE SEARCH SO WE
HAVE DEPLOYED. THOUSANDS OF
STAFF ACROSS THE STATE TO HELP
WITH SEARCH- THE SURGE CLINICAL
CARE- WE IMPLEMENTED A
HEALTHCARE SEARCH ORDER TO
ENSURE WE HELP LEVEL ACROSS
HOSPITALS MAJOR ELECTIVE
SURGERIES WERE CANCELED. MAKE
SURE THAT HOUSEHOLDS ACCEPT
TRANSFERS SO THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE INEQUITIES AND BETWEEN
HOSPITALS AND IN THE REGIONS.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO AVOID
CRISIS CENTERS OF CARE AND THE
STATE BY DOING THAT- THERE ALSO
STOPPING WAIVERS AND OTHER
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT- YOU KNOW
HELP AGAIN TO. TO MODERATE THE
IMPACT. AND AGAIN WE USING OUR
DATA. TO INFORM PLANNING WITH
PROJECTIONS- ALL PROVIDE YOU
KNOW LOT OF FOR PROTECT
EQUIPMENT OVER THIS MONTHS-
THAT- I. AND- NO ACTUALLY ALSO
TECHNO ASSISTANCE HELP WITH-
OLDER HOUSES THAT NEED MORE
ACTION TIME AND- A LOT OF LOCAL
STRIKE TEAM WHEN NEEDED FOR
HEALTH CARE. SERVICE SUPPORT
AND BACK TO THAT. AND THE- AND
ENHANCE INFECTION PRO. AND
THESE HEALTH FACILITY SETTINGS
AGAIN FROM TECH ASSISTANCE
SPARE. AND OF COURSE A REALLY
STRETCH IS COMING. OF TO THE
PUBLIC AND ENGAGING ALL
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS-
INCLUDING OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMUNICATING FREQUENTLY AND-
TO RIGHT UP TO DATE CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE SCIENCE BASED AND
EASY TO UNDERSTAND INFORMATION.
AND ACCESSIBLE FORMATS AND
LANGUAGES ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THE PANDEMIC TRANSMISSION AND
KEY RESPONSE INTERVENTION
ACTIVITIES. WE ALSO- REALLY
AGAIN AS ONE OF OUR CORE.
VALUES INCREASE AWARENESS ABOUT
THE DISPARITIES IN DISEASE
IMPACTING COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COME IN NINETEEN AND WE
DESIGNED TARGETED PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS FOR THESE
GROUPS. AND THEN THE LAST TWO
AND STRATEGIES GO HAND IN HAND
WHICH IS PARTICIPATING IN A
COORDINATED STATE GOVERNMENT
AND ALL OF GOVERNMENT ALL THE
STATE APPROACH REALLY TO
MOBILIZE YOU KNOW THIS IS A-
ONCE IN A LIFETIME PANDEMIC AT
LEAST WE HOPE- AND REALLY NEEDS
ALL HANDS ON DECK SO. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
ALL OF OUR STATE AGENCIES IN
APARTMENTS AND- A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PUBLIC AND PRIVATE-
PARTNERS AND OF COURSE AGAIN
PARTY WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO SIXTY ONE
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
AND BUILDING. AND IMPROVING ON
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS DEVELOP
THINGS SOME REGIONAL
COORDINATION- AND ENHANCING
THAT AND- AND ALSO AGAIN A
THEME OF DEVELOPING UNIFIED
DATA SYSTEMS AND ANALYTICAL
DASHBOARDS FOR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY CONTINUE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH A RESOURCES ACROSS THE
STATE- THE THIRD QUESTION WAS
TO. FOCUS ON TESTING CAPACITY-
INCLUDING THE PROBLEMS OF
DIFFERENT TESTING METHODOLOGIES
AND THEIR DISTRIBUTION AND
DEPLOYMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SO ARE- TESTING CAPACITY
WE HAVE ACTUALLY HAD A CAPACITY
THAT AND ONE POINT IS EXCEEDED
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PCR TEST
TODAY. AT THE PEAK OF OUR
SEARCH THERE ARE SEVERAL DAYS
WHERE VOLUME WAS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER DAY AND
OUR VOLUNTEER BRANCH I'VE STILL
HAS. MORE CAPACITY THAN
ACTUALLY HAS BEEN UTILIZED YET
SO- WE HAVE AGAIN OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PIECE OUR
CAPACITY TESTS TODAY- THAT'S
STILL THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING AND IT'S
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- THE PCR TESTING.
THERE'S- LOCAL CAPACITY THAT
OFTEN SERVE AND THEN WE HAVE-
LIKE TO BRANCH ON CONTRACTS FOR
FIXED SITES AND THERE'S MOBILE
BUSES FOR HIGH VOLUME AND MINI
VANS FOR LOWER VOLUME LEVEL
TESTING SITES WE HAVE TRAVELING
TEAMS. CAN DO COLLECTION OF
COMMUNITIES- THERE ARE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE UP TO SERVICE SITES-
AND JUST LIKE WE HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED COLOR. I'M IN
COMBINATION WITH OUR LAB AS
WELL THIS ALLOWING FOR TEST TO
BE DROP SHIPPED TO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE TRAINING.
AND THEN THEY CAN DO THEIR OWN
SPECIMEN COLLECTION AND THEN
SHIP IT TO THE LAB AND. THERE'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SITES
FOR THAT. AND THEN OF COURSE.
INTO IS- INCREASE IN YOU-
INDIFFERENCE. WE ABOUT TWELVE-
ANTIGEN TEST FROM ABBOTT BY
NEXT TONS. THE CAME FROM THE
FEDERAL. ALONG WITH THE DIRECT
ON A CASE OF SOME OF THESE
TESTS TO THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. WE'VE ALLOCATED
OVER SIX MILLION OF THESE TESTS
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS-
FIRST WE GAVE SERVE A MINIMUM
AMOUNT EACH COUNTY AND THEN USE
THEIR SHARE OF THE TOTAL
CALIFORNIA POPULATION PLUS
OTHER. ADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS
FOR COUNTIES WITH HIGHER CASE
RATES TO DISTRIBUTE THOSE
TESTING RESOURCES- WE ALSO
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS
TO RURAL AND CENTRAL VALLEY
COUNTIES AND- AND THEN ON TO.
AFTER THAT DISTRIBUTION CAN BE
REQUESTED VIA OUR MEDICAL
HEALTH OPERATIONAL. AREA
COORDINATION- PROCESS. OF THE
DOZEN WHICH IS A WORKED WITH
FIVE SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
AND ALL OF OUR STATE HOSPITALS
AND THEN WE ARE IN A PILOT MODE
OF TESTING- ENGINE TESTING IN
THE SCHOOL SETTING AND THAT'S
BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
THAT WE ARE WORKING HARD TO
MAKE SURE THEY MAINTAIN QUALITY
AND- ACTOR SINGER PROTOCOLS FOR
THAT- WE ALSO JUST READ THESE
TESTS TO CDCR FOR USAGE AND
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE UC
AND CAL STATE- UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS IS. TO DISTRIBUTE THESE
FURTHER. WE'RE ALSO EXPLORING
LEARNING MORE ABOUT HOME
COLLECTION IN HOME TEST KITS
WHICH ARE PREDOMINATELY ANTIGEN
BASED- THERE'S ALSO A HOME
ELECT EITHER WHAT'S CALLED A
LAMP TESTS. AND TESTS THAT ARE
STARTING TO BE ABLE TO BE
PURCHASED OVER THE COUNTER
WHICH WE ARE. ACTIVELY WORKING
ON SORT OF WHAT THE REPORTING
MECHANISMS FOR THOSE TEST
RESULTS WILL BE. CENEX I'M
GONNA MOVE ONTO OF THE FOURTH
QUESTION WHICH WAS PROVIDING AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM FOR VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
INCLUDING THE ROLE OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THE FEDERAL
CVS AND WALGREENS PARTNERSHIPS
IN THE NEW THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. US ALL START WAS
SORT OF- THE MAIN FOCUS ON OUR
ROLL UP UNTIL NOW FOR CITY
PAGES THEN- AS YOU HOPEFULLY NO
WE HAVE- THREE ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER OF. COMMITTEES THAT
HAVE BEEN REALLY CRUCIAL IN
INFORMING OUR RESPONSES THE
STATE. WE HAVE A WESTERN STATE
SCIENTIFIC AND SAFETY WORKER
COMMITTEE THAT HELPS US ASSESS
ONCE THE FDA. AND THE CDC-
AUTHORIZE A VACCINE FOR USE TO-
SORT OF CODIFY THAT MEASURE US
AS WELL THAT NO STEPS ARE
SKIPPED AND EVALUATING THE
SAFETY AND EFFICACY OF THESE
VACCINES. WE HAVE A DRAFTING
GUIDELINES WORK GROUP THAT IS A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY GROUP THAT
REALLY LOOKS AT THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES AROUND ALLOCATION OF
PRIVATIZATION. PRESIDENT LOOK
AT OUR- POPULATION DATA FOR
CALIFORNIA AND HAS REALLY
HELPED US SHAPE OUR
PARTICIPATION- FOR THE
DIFFERENT-YOU KNOW INITIAL
TEARS AND PHASES OF VACCINE
ALLOCATION. AND THEN ALL OF
THIS IS- VETTED WITH THEIR
COMMITTEE NEXT AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH HAS BEEN A
REALLY IMPORTANT. PARTNERSHIP
IN BOTH GETTING FEEDBACK ON ALL
OF THESE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS AS
WELL AS GETTING OUR MESSAGE OUT
TO DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMUNITIES- SO WE SETTLE THESE
POLICIES WITH THOSE- IN MIND.
WE ARE A LIAISON AND POINT OF
CONTACT IN THE- CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL PREVENTION- WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE- PRIOR. TO NOW ARE
AND- WE'VE BEEN IN ROLLING
PROVIDERS THAT ARE THE VACCINE
ADMINISTRATORS. AND ALLOCATING
AGAIN THIS IS A VACCINE BASED
ON A PRIORITY. POPULATIONS-
WE'VE PLAYED ORDERS THE FEDERAL.
AND A- WITH ANY **** MY OUR
TEMPERATURE EXCURSION ISSUES-
WE'VE- BEEN ACTIVELY- THAT YOU
KNOW CLEANING AND THEN-
INCREASING OUR STATE WOULD
MEDIA CAMPAIGN. AND EDUCATION.
AND THEN DATA SYSTEMS OF COURSE
AGAIN HAVE BEEN A REALLY
CRUCIAL SO WE HAVE- OUR
STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA MUSICIAN
REGISTRY AND THEN THERE ARE TWO
REGIONAL REGISTRIES AND-
WORKING TO INTEGRATE THOSE AND
IMPROVE THE CAPACITY OF THOSE.
AND THAT HAS EVOLVED INTO- CAL
ACTS WHICH IS OUR START AND END
SYSTEM. AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
HEARING MORE AND MORE ABOUT MY
TURN WHICH IS A PUBLIC
SCHEDULING AS ONE COMPONENT AND
CLINIC MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AS
WELL. AND THEN WE INTERACT WITH
THE FEDERAL DATA SYSTEMS SUCH
AS VACCINE FINDER AND THE BACK
END OF THAT IS CALLED TIBERIUS
AND THAT'S HOW WE GET A LOT OF
OUR- REPORTS THAT ARE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THAT'S-
ONE OF THE ELEMENTS IT PROVIDES
INPUT INTO TRACKING VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION. AND NOW WE'RE
ASSISTING IN TRANSITION TO THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR- AND
CONTINUE TO ASSIST WITH
CLINICAL AND SAFETY GUIDANCE.
AS FAR AS WORKING WITH A LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS- THEY-
WILL BE HIGHLIGHTED LATER AS
THEY- TESTIFY ON YOU KNOW ON
WHAT THEIR ACTIVITIES ARE BUT
THEY- YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING THESE ALLOCATION AND-
AND RE JUST READING TO OTHER
SMALLER PROVIDERS- INCLUDING
SOME FQHCS AND OTHER AT RISK
POPULATIONS- MANY OR MOST OF
THEM ALSO TO PROVIDE THEIR OWN
ASPECTS NATION CLINICS AND THEY
HAVE LOCAL NETWORKS OF
PROVIDERS- AND- AND THEN ONCE
THEY DO THOSE ALLOCATIONS THE
SHIPMENTS GO DIRECTLY TO THOSE
PROVIDERS. THE MULTI COUNTY
ENTITIES- TODAY HAVE BEEN
KAISER SUTTER ADVENTIST UC
HEALTH SYSTEMS PROVIDENCE- AND
MHC. AND THESE ARE DIRECT ON
OCCASIONS WHEN THE STATE THAT.
ARE GIVEN THE PATIENT
PERCENTAGE THEY REPRESENT AND
THE STATE. AND THEN THERE'S A
COUPLE STATE MULTI COUNTY
ENTITIES SO THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND CDCR. AND THEN JUST BRIEFLY
AS FAR AS THE PHARMACY PROGRAM
SO CVS AND WALGREENS- THE FIRST
PHASE OF THAT WAS FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. THAT WAS
PART A- AND THEN- PART B. WAS
TO AUGMENT AND ADD TO THAT TO
FOR ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO PART A
BEGAN AT THE END OF THE SUMMER
AND THE TWO ON THE EIGHTH. B.
B. ON GENERAL. AND PARDEE ISN'T
JUST. TO UP THE END OF THE- AND
B. TO RUN UP AND OF MARCH. AND
EACH FACILITY GETS THREE
CLINICS- FOR FACILITY CHIANG
MAI SURE THOSE TWO DOZEN
PURPOSE. GET IN WITHIN THOSE
CLINICS. AND THEN STARTING THIS
WEEK THE CDC IS STARTING A NEW
FEDERAL. PART WITH- SUB FEDERAL.
SO IT'LL BE ADDITION TO OUR
STATE ALLOCATION- THE
APPLICATION IS ONLY A MILLION
DOSES FOR THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
PER WEEK NATIONALLY SO IT'S NOT
A HUGE AMOUNT FOR CALIFORNIA-
BUT IT IS YOU KNOW AGAIN
ADDITIONAL JUST IS COMING TO
THE STATES AND AS ACTING SUPPLY
INCREASES. ADDITIONAL LOCATION
THEN PARTNERS WITH FEDERAL
PHARMACY PROGRAM CONTRACTS WILL
RECEIVE VACCINE- THE ULTIMATE
GOAL FOR THAT IS IF. NETWORK OF
THOUSAND LOCATE. AS THE CDC
RECOMMENDED THAT WE WORK
INITIALLY WITH TO- CALIFORNIA
PARTNERS THAT THEY HAD
IDENTIFIED CVS AND RITE AID TO
THEIR FOOT PRINT ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
OVERLAP OF LOCATIONS- WITH THE
OTHER. PHARMACIES SO THIS.
ROLLOUT IS- STARTING TO DAY.
AND ROLLING OUT TWO HUNDRED
IT'S- IN THE STATE AND PLANS
ARE GONNA BECOME AVAILABLE FOR
BOOKING AS EARLY AS- OR HAVE
BEEN BECOME AVAILABLE FOR
BOOKING AS EARLY AS THE NINTH-
CVS IS SAID THAT THE- THEY'D-
ACTUALLY SELECTED WHICH STORES
BUT THEY SAID THAT THEY DISLIKE
THEM ON. BASED ON POPULATION
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER THE
POPULATION DENSITY- AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND SOCIAL
MOBILITY INDEX WHICH IS
ANALOGOUS TO A HEALTHY PLACES
INDEX AND STORE FOOTPRINTS. OF
31% OF THOSE ARE IN OUR LOWEST
QUARTILE OF OUR HEALTHY PLACES
INDEX AND THEY'RE EXPECTED TO
RECEIVE OVER EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND FIRST US'S. PER WEEK
AND THAT'LL BE ABOUT A HUNDRED-
DOSES PER DAY PER STORE SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK SO THAT'S A NICE
AUGMENTATION- THAT JUST STARTED
AND THEN RITE AID IS ROLLING
OUT VACCINES TO THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR STORES
STARTING TODAY AS WELL. THEIR
INITIAL STORES WERE- LOW
SELECTED BASED ON THEIR
POPULATION WITHIN FIFTEEN MILES
OF THE STORE. SIMILARLY SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER
THEIR DENSITY. FOR SOME PERSONS
OF COLOR- THEY ALSO LOOKED AT
LIMITED ENGLISH- IN THE REGION
NO VEHICLE AND AVERAGE SOCIAL
MOBILITY INDEX A 28% OF THOSE
STORES THAT THEY IDENTIFIED ON
THE. BOTTOM EACH PACK QUARTILE.
THERE EXPECT TO RECEIVE OVER
THIRTY SO THOUSAND FIRST JUST
PER WEEK WHICH IS ABOUT. TAXES
A DAY STORE FIVE DAYS A WEEK-
AND THEY WILL ALSO MAXIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF LOCATION THOSE
VACCINES LIKE INCREASES. AND
THEN JUST RECENTLY ANNOUNCED AS
A FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP FOR WITH
FQHCS OVERSIGHT AND THE CDC ARE
LAUNCHING A PROGRAM. TO
DIRECTLY ALLOCATE A LIMITED
SUPPLY OF COVER NINETEEN
VACCINE TO. PERSONAL HEALTH
CENTER STARTING NEXT WEEK. SO
THE INITIAL PHASE WILL INCREASE
ACCESS TO VACCINES OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY CENTERS
NATIONALLY. IT WILL BE ANOTHER
INCREMENTAL EFFORT AS MORE
VACCINE BECOMES AVAILABLE SO
THE FIVE FQHCS ARE SELECTED TO
INITIATE THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
WHERE THE UNITED HEALTH CENTERS
IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. ULTIMATE
HEALTH SERVICES CORPS IN
COMMERCE CALIFORNIA. CLINIC A
DISSOLUTE- IN SALINAS. OF THE
STAFF COMMUNITY CLINIC IN THESE
TO CALIFORNIA. AND J. WCHS INTO
AND LA. IS A NATIONAL HEALTH
CENTER IS CHOSEN FOR THIS
PROGRAM INCLUDE THOSE THAT
SERVE A LARGE VOLUME OF ONE OF
THE FOLLOWING
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
POPULATION SO- INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
PUBLIC HOUSING RESIDENTS
MIGRANT. OR SEASONAL
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. OR
PATIENTS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY. THE ALLEGATION AS
A SET FROM A- WEEKLY ON. SO
AGAIN THIS IS AN HONOR. OF OUR
CALVET LIKE- AND THEN- JUST PRE
AS FAR HE TRANSIT TO THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR- THIS IS
OVERSEEN BY GOT OFFICE- THE
THIRD PARTY AND WILL PROVIDE
PRIORITIZE SAFETY EQUITY AND
THE FASTEST POSSIBLE
ADMINISTRATION OF VACCINES-
DEVELOPING AND MANAGING THE
STATE VACCINE NETWORK CONTRACTS
INCLUDING START UP COSTS AND
MONTHLY INCENTIVE PAYMENTS AND
DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING AND
COMMUNICATION PLAN WITH ALL
THAT STATEWIDE NETWORK
PROVIDERS AND OVERSEEING AND
MANAGING THE STATE ACSI
NETWORK. OF THE NEW T. PAY WILL
SUPPORT VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
STEP BY THE STATE- SO WE'RE
WORKING CLOSELY TO DEVELOP THIS
ALLOCATION FORMULAS AND THEN
INCLUDING CONSIDERATION SUCH AS
HOT SPOTS IN OUR EQUITY
MEASURES- AND THEN THE TVA THE
THIRD TRIMESTER WE FEEDING
CREDITED AS REQUIRED TO MY
TURN- AND ALSO THE STATEWIDE
DASHBOARDS AND SO THAT'S BEING
ROLLED OUT IN WAVES- THERE'S
THREE WAYS THAT HAVE JUST BEEN
IDENTIFIED WE'RE NOTIFYING
THAT- COUNTY IS THIS. THE WEEK
ON- OF HOW THOSE AWAYARE. ARE
DESIGNATED. MOVING ON TO- THE
QUESTION WAS TO HAVE DATA ON
AFFECT OF IDENTIFICATION AND
CONTACT TRACING- ARE CHEN OF
NINETY AND WELL HAVE WE LEARNED
CUT RAISING TO PANAMA THAT MAN
MORE BECAUSE IN EFFORTS AND
FUTURE- I THINK ALSO JUST WAS
YOU KNOW- WE AND LOOK HEALTH OF
OUR DO QUE AND HUNTER IN THE
STATE FOR MANY OTHER DOES.
AGAIN THE MAGNITUDE AND SCOPE
OF THIS PANDEMIC HAS HAS MADE
IT EXTREMELY CHALLENGING YOU
KNOW IN THE MIDST OF SEARCHES-
AS FAR AS OUR DATA YOU KNOW
AGAIN THIS IS A CRUCIAL PUBLIC
HEALTH TOOL FOR CONTAINING THE
SPREAD OF. THE NINETEEN AND
OTHER DISEASES- AND IT'S MOST
EFFECTIVE WHEN CASE COUNTS ARE
LOW ALLOWING FOR CASES AND
EXPOSE CONTACTS BE REACH MORE
RAPIDLY THE TESTING TURNAROUND
TIME IS ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT
AS FAR AS A LESSON LEARNED WITH
THAT- SO IT IS DIFFICULT AGAIN
WHEN THERE ARE HUGE SURGES- TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND REALLY SHIFT
SORT OF FROM THE SUPPRESSION
WHICH CASE AND CONTACT
INVESTIGATION THOSE TO THE
MEDICATION WHICH IS WHY. FOR
EXAMPLE WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT
REGIONAL STATE HOME ORDERS OR
OTHER MUCH LARGER
INTERVENTIONS- SO WE DO HAVE
CDC PERFORMANCE METRICS TO THAT
MEASURE CONTACT RACING
PERFORMANCE STATEWIDE AND THEN
IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT TO SAY WHAT THE
SPECIFIC IMPACT OF STATEWIDE
CONTACT TRACING EFFORTS BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF VERY ABILITY
OF LOCAL PROTOCOLS AND DATA
SYSTEMS- ARE CAL CONNECTS TO SO
MUCH- HAS EVOLVED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE LAST NINE MONTHS HAS
CIGNA VARIATIONS AND EVEN HOW
EACH LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
UTILIZING THE DATA FIELDS. BUT
WHAT'S NICE ABOUT IT IS WE HAVE
A FIFTY FOUR HELP JURISDICTIONS
ARE NOW USING IT AND- FORGET
THE PROPORTION OF CASES THAT
ARE IN IT NOW BUT IT REALLY IS-
A GREAT I'VE BEEN TATIAN THAT'S
HAPPENED TO THIS PENDING THAT
REALLY HELPS US HAVE INCREASING
STATE DATA ON ON THAT PIECE. OF
IT- I THINK THE MOST THING MY
BE TO. PROVIDE IN A- OF THE
IMPACT OF CONTACT. SO SANTA
CLARA- WAS ONE OF THE- KNOWS
YOU KNOW WHETHER EARLY DOCTORS
OF THE SITE. COUNTY THAT
ADOPTED CONNECT. AND THEY
LOOKED A DIFFERENCE OF. K. WHO
ARE NOW. TO THE LOCAL HEALTH-
AS CONTACT IN CASE WHO ARE NOT.
AND WHEN NEW CASE HAD ARE BEEN
RECENTLY. REACH A CONTACT
RESOURCE TO NOTIFY THEM THAT
THEY WERE A CONTACT. THOSE
CASES WHERE ARE YOU STAYING
HOME BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN
QUARANTINE INSTRUCTIONS. AND
THEN NOT EXPOSE ANY NEW
CONTACTS SO THEY DID BECOME
DEAD ENDS FOR TRANSMISSION. AND
THE PROPORTION OF THAT WAS
NEARLY DOUBLE- COMPARED TO
CASES WOULD NOT BEEN IN CONTACT
AND HAD NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED.
THANK CONTACT TRACING. OF FEWER
CASES WERE PREVIOUSLY KNOWN AS
CONTACTS WERE NOT IN ISOLATION.
AND THAT- SO THAT DECREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD DISTANCE BRAD'S WAS
5% COMPARED TO FIFTEEN PERCENT-
CONDUCT RACING'S ALSO FOUND AN
OVERALL SLIGHTLY HIGHER SUCCESS
RATE REACHING THE CASE. THEY
HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN KNOWN AND
REACHED AS A CONTACT. OF AND
THAT OF COURSE NOW IS WHEN I.
BY CALIFORNIA NOTIFIED WE HAVE
OVER NINE MILLION USERS TO THAT
THAT HAVE THE- ANONYMOUS
IDENTITY. IF THEY'VE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH FOREIGN ROLLED.
THE IS JUST AN EXAMPLE FROM
COUNTY TO SKI YOU A OF- A MORE-
GRANULAR. AT OF THE IN. I AS
FAR AS THE KEY LESS LEARNED- I
ALREADY MET THE FASTER ONTO
RESULTS CRUCIAL WE NEED TO.
LOOK UP AND ABOUT A CASE
QUICKLY AND TO REACH AND
CONTACT. TO FINE BOTH CASES
INCOME. ARE THEIR PAIN THAT THE
TIME INFECTION PERIOD IN
KEEPING PERIOD- I. NEEDS TO BE
SCALED RAPIDLY- SO AGAIN WE
WERE ALREADY- I THINK AS PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM YOU KNOW.
PROBABLY WERE UNDER RESOURCE TO
DO THE CASE AND CUTTING
MEDICATIONS WE NEED TO DO FOR
THE OTHER. OVER AT REPORTABLE
DISEASES AND- AND THEN HAVE
THIS PANDEMIC ON TOP OF THIS I
THINK WE- TRYING TO MOBILIZE
YOU KNOW THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE AND- DID AN
AMAZING JOB TRAINING AS WELL
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UC'S OF RITUAL TRAINING
ACADEMY. BUT I THINK AS FAR AS
A LESSON LEARNED WE NEED TO
REALLY MAINTAIN A REALLY ROBUST
PUBLIC HEALTH STAFFING
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT- IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE SET UP. IN
SUCH A AN URGENT WAY- WE HAD A
VERY VERY SMALL EXISTING
WORKFORCE EXPERIENCE
INVESTIGATORS THE NEED TO-
QUICKLY TRAIN AND LEAD OTHERS
TO DO THAT. I THINK THE OTHER
LESSON LEARNED IS THAT YOU
KNOW- IN CALIFORNIA THE
WILLINGNESS OF INFECTED
INDIVIDUALS TO SPEAK TO CASE
AND CONTACT INVESTIGATORS AND
SHARE INFORMATION- IS REALLY
TERRIBLE THE WILLINGNESS OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC TO ANSWER CALLS
AND TEXTS FROM THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND ENGAGE WITH
CONTACT RACING IS- IS VERY ABLE
SO- THIS REQUIRES INVESTMENT
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION A
MESSAGING IN MANY LANGUAGES TO
ENCOURAGE ENGAGEMENT LOCALIZE
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS FOR TRUSTED
STAKEHOLDERS- AND AGAIN A WORK
FORCE THE NEEDS LANGUAGE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WORK FORCE- WITH
CLIENT CENTERED PRACTICES OF
THOSE ARE. SOME HUGE LESSONS
LEARNED THAT WE NEED TO
MAINTAIN TO KEEP US PREPARED
FOR ALL INFECTIOUS DISEASES. OF
THE ABILITY TO OFFER RESOURCES
FOR INFECTED INDIVIDUALS TO
ISOLATE QUARANTINE. SO THINGS
LIKE WAGE REPLACEMENT SO THEY
CAN PROPERLY ISOLATE OR
QUARANTINE HOUSING FOOD
DELIVERY DURING SITUATIONS TO
REALLY MAKE SURE WE CAN
INTERRUPT TRANSMISSION- OTHER
POLICIES THAT COULD SUPPORT
THAT OUR ENFORCEMENT OR
INCENTIVES TO ENSURE BUSINESSES
SUPPORT QUARANTINE AND
ISOLATION REQUIREMENTS OF THEIR
STAFF. OF AND THEN OF COURSE
AGAIN THE ABILITY TO ANALYZE
AND OBTAIN A CASE DATA AND
CONTACT DATA- TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A REALLY- INFORMED.
ANALYSIS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
STATEWIDE- AND THAT REALLY-
ROBUST DATA SYSTEMS AND IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN ALSO-
HELP US WITH STRONG
INTERJECTION COMMUNICATION IN
COORDINATION TO IMPROVE SPEED
AND EFFICACY OF TRANSFERRING
CASES AND CONTACTS BETWEEN.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
pSHARING DATA AND TACKLING
OUTBREAKS TOGETHER. SO THE LAST
QUESTION I AM GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING IS- HOW IS THE
CURRENT CODE NINETEEN RESPONSE
HIGHLIGHTED GAPS IN READINESS
THAT MIGHT HELP THE STATE AND
DPH TO PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
PANDEMIC. WHAT WOULD CAUSE CHEN
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS SO AGAIN
JUST TO KIND OF YOU KNOW THAT
IS SUMMER IS A LOT OF WHAT I
HAD ALREADY SAID THAT I THINK
YOU KNOW CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IS REALLY. A ONE
OF THE HUGE GAPS AND I THINK
THE TWO MAIN AREAS ARE STAFFING
SO HAVING YOU KNOW ROBUST
EPIDEMIOLOGY- EXPERIENCE CASE
AND CONTACTED THE SKATERS
OUTBREAK INVESTIGATORS- HAVING
THE CAPACITY TO DO- MORE
SOPHISTICATED DATA ANALYSIS AND
MODELING HAVE BEEN REALLY.
HELPFUL WE GOT DEVELOP SOME
GREAT PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
ACADEMIC PARTNERS WHICH WILL BE
HEARING ABOUT LATER IN ANOTHER
BUDGET REQUEST- AND ALSO-
HAVING THE ABILITY TO HAVE OUR
WORK FIRST EVALUATE THESE
INTERVENTIONS SO. DOING THAT
BOTH WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND
THEN AGAIN REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THE- PARTNERSHIPS WE'RE
DEVELOPING WITH OUR ACADEMIC
PARTNERS TO FORMALIZE ALL THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS- AND THEN REALLY
OF COURSE THE INVOLVING- TOPIC
IS GENOMICS WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING AND- INCREASING
THEIR LEAD ANOTHER LABORATORY
TESTING BUT OUR ABILITY TO DO
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. ONE OF THE MOST
ROBUST SYSTEMS IN THE NATION-
BUT AGAIN IT'S- IT'S NOWHERE
NEAR OTHER COUNTRIES FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE THE UNITED KINGDOM
SO WE'RE RAPIDLY SCALING THAT
UP AS WELL. AGAIN WITH PARTNERS
SO- I THINK THE OTHER GAP AGAIN
IS INVESTMENT IN OUR DATA AND
IT INFRASTRUCTURE- BOTH THE
ACTUAL SYSTEM THEMSELVES AND I.
T. STAFFING TO SUPPORT THAT WE
CAN'T. COLLECT GOOD DATA THAT
WE DON'T HAVE GOOD IT SYSTEMS
AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND GOOD-
ROBUST STAFFING TO SUPPORT THAT
AS WELL. WHEN WE HAVE REVIEWED
OUR- AFTER ACTION APART FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND NINE PANDEMIC
H. ONE ON ONE IT ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR US TO
MAINTAIN INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE
DEVELOPED FOR COVERED GOING
FORWARD. BUT UNFORTUNATE THAT
AND PANDEMIC ALSO HAPPENED IN-
A DIFFICULT BUDGET TIME AND A
LOT OF THOSE RESOURCES
INFRASTRUCTURE- DID DISAPPEAR
AND I THINK THE THEME. THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN PUBLIC HEALTH IS-
HOW THESE VARIOUS SMALL.
INFECTION EMERGED LIKE A- SEEK
THE PRIOR PAN AND GETTING SOME
SHORT TERM FUNDING BUT THEN THE
SHORT TERM FUNDING GOES AWAY
AND WHAT WE REALLY NEED AS LONG
TERM SUSTAINMENT OF THE ROBUST
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO THAT IS A
GOOD SEGUE I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
JACK'S WELL TO TALK MORE ABOUT
OUR BUDGET AND- FUNDING. S.
GOOD MORNING CENTERS JESSELTON
FINANCE ARE. IN THE ATTIC
QUESTION SEVEN I REQUESTED A AB
REVIEW COUNTING OF ALLOCATIONS
OR STATE FEDERAL FUNDING PRETTY
BIJUR BRITANNIC RELATED THAT
EXPENDITURES YESTERDAY EVENING
WE SENT A FULL CHART. OF ALL
THOSE CATEGORIES OVER TO US AND
STAFF BY I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S- MATED TO THE SENATE AT
THIS POINT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIRTY THREE ROWS OF DATA EACH
WITH ITS OWN SUBSET- DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS THE BEST VALUE TO
RUN TO THAT CHART- BUT IT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED AND- MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
ABOUT THAT NOW OR OR AROUND. IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS YOU REVIEW
THAT JORDAN YOU CAN SEND THEM
TO US THROUGH YOUR STAFF AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM
BUT- WE WERE ABLE TO SECURE
THAT DATA. FOR YOU- AHEAD OF
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU- AT THAT
APPRECIATE THAT YOU SENT TO
DATE OVERESTIMATE I'M NOT A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT MYSELF- I
KNOW OUR STAFF WORKS VERY HARD
ON THESE THINGS. MAYBE YOU CAN.
THIS IS AN OVERVIEW TO THAT-
BECAUSE MY WHEN MY COURT
QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL
ESSENTIALLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. SOME MILLION STATE
GENERAL FUNDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PART PUBLIC HEALTH.
HOW HOW MUCH OF THAT IS- I
GUESS- DIRECTLY PANDEMIC
RELATED AND THEREFORE IT'S OKAY
THIS WAS LIKE YOU YEAH I KNOW
THAT- EVEN THOUGH TECHNICALLY
ONLY PASS A BUDGET FOR A YEAR
WE DO MULTI YEAR PROJECTIONS.
AND SO HOW MUCH OF THAT
INCREASE IS GOING TO THE KIND
OF INFRASTRUCTURE- THANK ITEMS
THAT- DOCTOR POND JUST- TALKED
ABOUT. SO THEREFORE IS GONNA BE
MULTI YAR. VERSES I GUESS A
YEAR BY YEAR WHERE IT'S A THIS
IS DIRECTLY. COVERED RESPONSE
SO OBVIOUSLY COVERED RESPONSE
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S WHEN FRONT OF US BUT-
MOST OF THINKING IN TERMS OF
THE MORE LONG TERM INVESTMENTS
WE NEED TO MAKE IN THE
DEPARTMENT. FOR EXAMPLE AROUND
IT AND SO FORTH AND I DO I DO
RECALL THAT- SO A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- WE ARE STARTING TO BARK IN
THAT DISCUSSION ABOUT IT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR. A CD P. H.
AND THEN- COVERT HITS- SO- SO
WE WERE ALREADY THINKING ABOUT
THAT AHEAD OF TIME BUT I JUST
WANNA KNOW THAT. SO OF THAT
INCREASE CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THAT AND AS BROAD TERMS.
ABSOLUTELY SIR AND- THINKING
ABOUT IT AND THAT TERM YOU KNOW
OF COURSE ARE A LARGE MARGIN
FUSIONS OF CASH ON THE ON A ONE
TIME BASIS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC RESPONSE A
LOT OF THAT WILL BUILD SOME OF
THAT I IT INFRASTRUCTURE YOU'VE
DISCUSSED- I MEAN WHILE A LOT
OF WHAT OUR EFFORTS ARE FOCUSED
ON NOW- OKAY NINETEEN OF
NINETEEN RELIEF TRACKING- THE
SORT OF. SYSTEMS AND SYSTEM
UPGRADES THAT WERE MAKING ON
THE I. T. SIDE TO VARIOUS
FAXING DATABASES STORE CONTACT
GRAYSON SYSTEM- YOU KNOW THOSE
ARE GONNA GO WAY WHEN THIS IS
OVER AND OF COURSE OF DEALING
WITH THIS THIS PRYING CRISIS
IS- IS OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
BUT A LARGER YOU KNOW A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
MONEY THAT'S BEING- CHANNELED
INTO THE APARTMENT. AND
DEMOCRATS SPONSORS WAY TO BUILD
LONG TERM CAPACITY YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY IN ADDITION TO
THOSE I. T. INVESTMENTS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND YOU KNOW
EXPANSION OF LABORATORY
CAPACITY- ADDITIONAL STAFF IS
BEING BROUGHT ON I AM MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN A LONG TERM
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO HOW
TO INVEST IN PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- MOVING FOR
WITH THE LEGISLATURE- BUT AS IT
STANDS NOW- IT'S DIFFICULT TO
SPECIFICALLY DELINEATE WHICH
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO BE.
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE AND WENT
AND WENT OVER RESPONSES
CONCLUDED THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
LONG RANGE IMPACT ON THE
OVERALL PUBLIC HEALTH READINESS
IN THE IMPACTING DEVELOPERS
SYSTEM BUT THERE IS THERE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS- IN.
REAL REAL LAB. YOUR QUICK
MENTOR OKAY BLACK BASS. I
STRUCTURE THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO THE LAW RUN- AND WE'RE ALSO
SORT OF STACKING UP. A BROADER
HEALTH. THAT ONCE WE SORT OF
ADDRESS THIS IS. OKAY NINETEEN
WILL PASS WE CAN WE CAN REALIGN
ANCESTRY OUT PRIORITIES. OKAY
WELL I APPRECIATE ANY
APPRECIATE INTO EXAMPLE LIKE I.
T. OBVIOUSLY OUT. AS WELL AS
WHERE YOU CAN PUT THEM U FRONT
CAPITAL AND THEN. BUT YOU LSO
HAVE MAINTENANCE STAFFING IS AN
ONGOING EXPENSE SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE OTHER PART
INFRASTRUCTURE SO ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. SOME PERMANENT
INCREASES IN STAFF- KNOWING
THAT WE WERE EVEN PRE COVETED.
SHORTHANDED AND- ALLOW THE
STAFF IN C. P. H. R. FOR
SPECIFIC GRANT PROJECTS OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS WE GET FROM
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS YOU MAY
KNOW IN THE INTRODUCTION ONLY
25% OF. THE FUNDS FOR C. P. TO
ACTUALLY COME FROM THE STATE
ADDRESSES. FROM FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS VERY.
PHYSICALLY YOU KNOW. TO VERY
THING IT'S NOT THAT IT'S JUST
LIKE THE CA.GOV GAVE US A PART
OF MY INSTEAD USE IT AS- THAT
THINK IS A- APPROPRIATE SO. WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A CERTAIN
RIGIDITY TO THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND AND THINGS LIKE. WHAT IS
CONTACT TRACING CAPACITY I YOU
KNOW IT RESPONSE AND FAXES
THESE THOSE ARE REALLY CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS.
OFTENTIMES ARE FUND DO NOT END
UP BEING FUNDED BY THE STATE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND- SO- I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. AS
WE'RE- AND I KNOW IT'S SO HARD
TO TEASE SOME OF THAT OUT BUT
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT SORT OF. A
MULTI YEAR PROJECTIONS THAT
FINANCES DOING AND SO FOR THAT
WE'RE HAVING THAT DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THE
BUDGET. I WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN KNOWING AND BILL WE CAN.
CERTAINLY DO THIS AFTER THE
HEARING WILL TO GO ALL THE
DETAILS HERE AND HEARING RIGHT
NOW BUT- IS THAT WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF. MORE
LONGER TERM INVESTMENTS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH CAPACITY- OVER
YEARS VERSUS YOU KNOW OKAY WELL
WE HAD A YOU KNOW WE HAVE
FEDERAL MONEY WE HAVE IT
CENTER- AND IN TERMS OF THE-
CODE RESPONSE AND YES SOME
INVESTMENTS WE'RE GOING FOR
GOLD RESPONSE WILL HAVE- HELP
US. YOUNG TECH. WILL HELP US
THE MOST BUT- AND THEN ALSO
ANYTHING ABOUT LABORATORIES AND
I JUST POINT OUT THAT I THINK
WE'VE LOST A TWELVE LET COUNTY
LABORATORIES SO. YOU KNOW WE-
WILL BE LOOKING SYSTEMATICALLY
AT A LABORATORY CAPACITY SO I
KNOW THAT CERTAINLY WE HAVE OUR
STATE LAB AND APPRECIATE WE'RE
INVESTING IN THAT. SO WHAT KIND
OF THE NEW CAPACITIES
REBUILDING IN THERE BUT ALSO
HOW WE MAKING UP FOR THE LOSS
OF LOCAL LABS. AS WELL AND ARE
WE TAKING A MORSE- SIR
STATEWIDE EARLY STRATEGIC
APPROACH AND PARTNERING WITH
OUR LOCAL COUNTIES TO BE SURE
WE HAVE SUFFICIENT TOTAL LAB
CAPACITY AND ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SIDE IN OUR STATE
BECAUSE WE KNOW A LOT OF
CAPACITY IS NOT ACTUALLY.
DIRECTLY FUNDED BY THE STATE
BUT HAS BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ARE COUNTY GOVERNMENT I SHOULD
SAY. YES YOU KNOW WHY IN THE
LAST BUDGET ACT WE PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THE
STATE LABORATORY STAFF
EQUIPMENT. THAT'S ONGOING. YES-
WE HAVE A LOT OF. AT LEAST IN
THE IN THE NEAR TERM WE HAVE A
HUGE NEED THAT'S LARGELY BEING
FUNDED BY ONE TIME EXPANDING
ONE TIME FUNDING SOURCES. AND
YOU KNOW AS WE ADVANCE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND FOR THE-
BUDGET I THINK WE'LL BE HAVING
A- MORE FOR CONVERSATION ABOUT.
THE- LONGER TERM INVESTMENTS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH- AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE WERE
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING THE
FULLEST ACCOUNTING OF BUDGET
YEAR EXPENDITURES IN THIS.
INDUSTRY BROWN IS A REALISTIC
OF THE RESPONSE. THE DISCUSSION
AS TO WHETHER THE LONG TERM
FUTURE OF STATE INVESTMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IT WOULD BE. IS
GOING TO BE A COMMON
CONVERSATION AND SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT LOCAL LABORATORIES WE'VE
BEEN VERY FORTUNATE. TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL- EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
LABORATORY CAPACITY GRANTS FROM
THE CDC- MUCH OF WHICH IS GONE
TOO- LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORIES TO EXPAND OUR
CAPACITY ABILITY- AND NOT ONLY
THAT- WITH WITH THE- INCREASED.
DEMAND FOR TESTING WE'VE BEEN TO STAND UP AND LENDS A
BRANCH LABORATORY. BROWN TO
INCREASE OUR TESTING THAT IS SO
I THINK WE'VE WE'VE BEEN MAKING
SOME PRETTY. SIGNIFICANT UP
FRONT INVESTMENTS AND- WE'RE
GONNA GO WITH THOSE AND BUT
WHAT WHAT WE'VE WHAT WE'VE
CREATED AND WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE
MOVING FORWARD. I THINK WILL BE
AN ONGOING DISCUSSION FOR TO
HAPPEN THAT WITH LEGISLATION
OKAY WELL I DID IT LOOK FOR TOO
WELL WHAT HAPPENS MAY REVISE I
DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT-
UNDER GOVERNOR NEWSOM. AT
LEAST- LAST YEAR WE HAD FOR THE
FIRST TIME ACTUALLY PROVIDE
SOME HELP FOR. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THANKS TO THE
GOVERNOR- THIS WAS RIGHT BEFORE
KOBE AND- I'M HOPING WE CAN
BUILD ON THAT KIND OF
INVESTMENT- ESPECIALLY WITH THE
LESSONS WE'RE LEARING FROM
COVERED ABOUT NEED. TO BUILD
THAT CAPACITY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU GRANT-
THIRD DOWN BOND. WE HAVE BEEN
THIS. TO FOR. A NOW- WE'VE
REFLECT. LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME
WE HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN CASES I THINK REPORT SAYS
AND NOW WE ARE. AT OVER. THREE
MILLION THREE AND A HALF
MILLION THAT THAT HAS UCKED
HAS TRANSFORMED EVERYBODY'S
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA- AND DOCTOR
PAN HAS A LOT OF A- KNOWLEDGE
AND WEEDS IN THIS AREA BUT I'M
JUST GONNA TALK LIKE A- LIKE A
REGULAR. PERSON WHO I HAVE TO
INTERACT WITH EVERY SINGLE DAY
IN MY DISTRICT. RIGHT IT IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ON THIS JOURNEY
AND I GUESS IN IN VERY-
CONCRETE TERMS I'M WONDERING.
AND I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS OUT
THERE ARE WONDERING- WHAT KIND
OF WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED. WITH
THE FIRST PROCESS AND IN PLACE
LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT I
REPRESENT- TESTING WAS VERY
LATE TO GET ON. IT WOULD TAKE
TWO WEEKS SOMETIMES AFTER
SOMEBODY GOT TESTED. IN AND
HEAVILY AGRICULTURAL. COMMUNITY
WAITING TWO WEEKS TO FIND OUT
THE RESULTS OF THE TEST WAS
UNACCEPTABLE. AND THAT IS PART
OF THE REASON WE SPREAD AND IN
A WAY THAT WE DID BECAUSE
PEOPLE COULD NOT STAY HOME AND
CONTINUE TO WORK AND CONTINUE
TO CARPOOL. AND WE'VE SEEN AT
THE RESPONSE OF THOSE OUTBREAKS.
OUR TESTING IS BETTER NOW BUT
NOW I THINK WE'RE FACING THE
SAME THING WITH THE
VACCINATIONS AND WHILE I KNOW
WE'RE DOING A LOT TO GET THEM
OUT. I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
AVERAGE PERSON OUT THERE KEEP
SAYING WHERE DO I GET MY WHEN
DO I GET MINE. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY. AND I THINK
EVERY TIME WE ROLL OUT A NEW
PROGRAM OR NEW TEAR. IT
CONFUSES EVERYBODY AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DATA IS
MOVING QUICKLY AND I UNDERSTAND
WE'VE HAD A CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATION. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME I THINK ONE OF TH
MESSAGES THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH IS.
CLEAR CONCISE. INFORMATION AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE PUBLIC
FEELS LIKE THEY HAVE RECEIVED
THAT- AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT. THAT THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BUT LIKE THEY HAVE
RECEIVED THAT AS WELL. EIGHT
AM. TODAY AND OFTENTIMES OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS YOU
KNOW HAVE BEEN UNDER. UNDER
FIRE UNDER ATTACK- FROM. MOVE
CONSTITUENTS WHO WHO DISAGREE
WITH THE SCIENCE AND THEN. HAVE
ROOM TO QUESTION THE SCIENCE-
SO. WHAT DO YOU MEAN WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THE AVERAGE PERSON
WHO SAYS. YOU KNOW WE COULDN'T
GET THE TESTING RIGHT AND I AND
I'M IN THE COUNTY. I DON'T
BELIEVE AS A LAB AS WE KEEP
SENDING THEM OFF AND THEN. THE
DATA WOULDN'T BE INTEGRATED AND
SO. YOU KNOW AND EVERYONE'S
VERY. WAS FOCUSED ON THE TEARS.
AND THEN THE TEARS CHANGED. AND
IT. HOW SO HOW WHAT IS OUR- AS-
WHAT IS OUR ASSURANCE I GUESS
THAT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH
TESTING. WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
WITH OUR CONTRACT TRACERS AND
HOW WE CONTINUE TO USE THOSE-
AND NOW AGAIN WE'VE GOT. ACT
BECAUSE I UNDERSTOOD WALGREENS
CVS AND RITE AID WE'RE JUST
GOING TO BE FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES BUT NOW I'M HEARING.
IT'S GOING TO BE FOR EVERYBODY.
AND THEN THEN WE HAVE OUR TO
WEAR BLUE SHIELD AND KAISER
COMING IN. SO I JUST I THINK
THEY'RE STILL REMAINS A LOT OF
CONFUSION ABOUT WHO'S DOING
WHAT WHO'S ON FIRST- THE
COUNTIES I THINK WONDER ARE
THEY STILL GOING TO IT ARE THEY
STILL GOING TO BE INVOLVED. ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GIVING IT
OUT NOW THEY'VE YOU KNOW
EVERYONE'S REALLY BUILT OUT OF
SYSTEM. TO BE ABLE TO. TOUCH
ALL THE FOLKS WHO WHO
OFTENTIMES ARCHITECTURE OR NEED
TO BE- ADDRESSED. IN WILL BE
ABLE TO USE THAT SYSTEM WITH
THE NEW. THIRD PARTY AS WELL AS
WITH THE NEW ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ARE THAT ARE DOING ALL
THAT. SO YOUR QUESTION IS JUST.
SORT OF HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
RESPOND TO. A RESPONSE YET.
YEAH I MEAN I HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR I THINK- I THINK A FEW
THINGS I THINK WE HAVE LEARNED
LOTS OF LESSONS AND I THINK
WHAT WE'RE DOING MUCH EARLIER
ON NOW IS. REALLY MAKING SURE
WE INTEGRATE AN ACTUAL- EQUITY
BASED FORMULA- MOVING FORWARD
INTO- DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES
AND I THINK THAT'S DEFINITELY
INCREASED INVOLVED OVER TIME AS
FAR AS PROVIDING RESOURCES
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THAT- AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS RATED. BOTH
THE COUNTING ON ALSO STATEWIDE
LEVEL AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE- ALLOCATING RESOURCES
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW AGAIN AS YOU
MENTIONED CENTRAL VALLEY- YOU
KNOW HUSBAND IS PARTIALLY
IMPACTED AND NEEDS-
DIFFERENTIAL RESOURCES JUST
BASED ON WHAT'S THERE SO I
THINK WE'RE NOT JUST FRESNO.
RIGHT RIGHT AND I THINK
COMMUNICATION ALWAYS NEEDS TO
BE YOU KNOW WE ARE CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE AND I MEANT THAT AND
ACTUALLY IMPROVED THE- LEVEL OF
RESOURCES- I THINK. WELL AS I
THINK I JUST I AND I THINK AS A-
COMMUNITY I THINK WE HEARD IS
JUST AGAIN THAT THIS ISN'T IT
CONTINUES TO RAPIDLY EVOLVE SO
AS YOU POINTED OUT
COMMUNICATION IS CRUCIAL BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO. COMMUNICATE THE
THINGS CONTINUE TO CHANGE- BUT
NEED TO COMMUNICATE THEM
CLEARLY SO I THINK WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IMPROVING THAT
MESSAGE AND- THAT TRANSITION IS
HARD AND WE HAD SO MANY
CHANGES- OVER THIS- NOW OVER A
YEAR OF THIS. THE PANDEMIC AND
LEARNING ABOUT THIS DISEASE- SO
I THINK YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO
PROVE I THINK WE HAVE LEARNED A
LOT I THINK WE HAVE IMPROVED A
LOT I THINKWE ALWAYS HAVE MORE
ROOM TO IMPROVE AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON THAT AS FAR
AS- GETTING MORE MORE CLRITY
ON. I KNOW WE ARE IN TRANSITION
RIGHT NOW AS WE OF ALL THOSE
THOSE- CLARITY OF ROLES AND
COMMUNICATING THOSE WELL- WE
ARE ALSO WORKING ON- HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE THINKING ABOUT.
HOPEFULLY AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN ALSO GIVE US
MORE- MORE ABILITY TO PROJECT
YOU KNOW BEYOND JUST TO TWO OR
THREE TWO WEEKS RIGHT NOW IS
ABOUT WILL TELL US TWO OR THREE
WEEKS WHICH IS MORE THAN BEFORE
WHICH IS ONLY ONE WEEK AT A
TIME- I THINK AS WE CAN SEE
MORE SUPPLY WILL BE ABLE TO MAP
ON A PROJECT FOR THE PUBLIC AS
WELL LIKE WHEN WE THINK WE'LL
HAVE ENOUGH SUPPLY FOR. YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT- DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING ON THAT AND I YOU KNOW
IT HAS BEEN A LONG HARD YEAR
FOR EVERYBODY AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE FRUSTRATION AND WE CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE AND GET BETTER. IT
INTO CAN YOU. JUST VERY CLEAR
TERMS DELINEATE BETWEEN THE-
WALGREENS CVS. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES. THE FQHCS. THE
AND THE THIRD PARTY HOW. AND
INTERACTING WITH THEIR COUNTIES.
THREE ONE MORE TIME ABOUT HOW
MANY VACCINES OR THE POT TO THE
VACCINES ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED
TO EACH OF THOSE AND THEN WHAT
IS THEIR ROLE OF RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE DELIVERY OF THAT. SO
SAID TO SHIP BACK TO THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR WILL BE
REALLY DOING ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE NOT SO.
THE FEDERAL PHARMACY
PARTNERSHIPS OR THESE AND
ACTUALLY NOT THESE FEDERAL
ACTUALLY DIDN'T EVEN MENTION
THESE FEDERAL SITES THAT- ALL
THE STUFF IN OAKLAND IN L. A.
COUNTY- BUT EVERYTHING THAT IS
NOT THAT WILL BE COORDINATED BY
THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
ONCE THE TRANSITION IS COMPLETE
SO ALL THE PROVIDERS. AND THAT
OUR ROLE NOW WILL BE SWITCHING
OVER TO THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR SO THAT IS A
COMBINATION- COUNTIES VIA LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- THEY'RE
ALSO RELATIONSHIPS WITH AFTER
EACH USE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
WITH THE STATE THAT COULD BE
TRANSITION AND- THERE ARE LOCAL
PHARMACIES AS WELL THAT COULD
BE IN THOSE NETWORKS- SO THAT
THEIR PRIME MINISTER IS GOING
TO BE- YOU KNOW STARTING WITH
THESE WAVES AND DOING IN THREE
WAYS FROM THAT- LOOK UP. AND
ALSO WORKING WITH HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND THEN THERE ARE AS
AS YOU MENTIONED ARE MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PROVIDERS
AND AS WE GET MORE SUPPLY WE
WANT TO HAVE MORE ABILITY TO
GET ACCION'S MORE MORE
LOCATION. RIGHT OTHER
PHARMACIES- SO THAT THE CAR
BALLOTS- TO COVER ANY OTHER
PRIVATE. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
PROVIDED. SEPARATELY ARE- THE
THESE NEWER PARTNERSHIPS IN THE
FQHC PARTNERSHIP ON THEN THE
MOST RECENT PHASE OF A PHARMACY
PARTNERSHIP FOR CDS AND
WRITING- AND THEN THESE. THESE
LARGE SORT OF MEGA SITES ARMOR
IS BRINGING BACK SEEMS TO HAVE
THOSE ARE SEPARATES- AND THEN-
AS INTER IT BECAUSE- WILL BE. A
SEPARATE I'LL- AND WELL AS THE
PARTY. P. WITH. THE REST OF
THOSE I DON'T KNOW SOMEONE WE
GOT BOXES ON THE MY LAI WEEK
MORE THAT. BUT OKAY OFF OF THE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IN AND I
DID AND I. YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK I COULD ACKNOWLEDGE
ENOUGH THAT I KNOW IT'S A
MOVING TARGET AND I KNOW IT'S
YOU KNOW IT IS IT IS
UNPRECEDENTED. BUT EVERYTHING
LET ME IS ASK IS EVERYTHING YOU
JUST EXPLAINED- DOES IF I CAN
CALL ANY PUBLIC HEALTH PERSON.
DIRECTOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEY WOULD KNOW
THAT THAT INFORMATION THAT YOU
JUST REPORTED TO ME. BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S PART OF WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT PLANNING AND THINGS
CHANGE. HOW DOES IT IMPACT ON
THE ON THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THEN HOW DO
THEY- COMMUNICATE THAT OUT
LOCALLY. YEAH AND AGAIN I CAN
KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE THINGS HAVE
BEEN SO FAST MOVING- AS HAS THE
INFORMATION- WE- YOU KNOW WE DO
OUR BEST TO- YOU KNOW WE ARE
OFTEN ON THE PHONE WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO THE
LEADERSHIP LEVEL. TWO THREE
FOUR TIMES A WEEK AND THEN WE
HAVE. YOU KNOW DIFFERENT DAILY
OR WEEKLY CALLS THAT ARE KIND
OF TOWN HALLS AROUND MAXINE
IMPLEMENTATION FOR DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF THE MUSICIAN
CORNING'S AND THERE'S- SO WE
TRY TO PUSH THAT INFORMATION AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN AND AS WE GET
IT- AND AS IT'S EITHER.
CONFIRMED OR APPROVED- AND SO
AND BUT IT IS BECAUSE IT'S
PROBABLY MOVING I CAN SPEAK AS
A PRIOR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
PERSON TO. IT'S HARD TO STAY ON
TOP OF ALL THE INCOMING
INFORMATION AS WELL- WE DEVELOP
THINGS LIKE A SHAREPOINT SITE
WHERE WE CAN SHARE INFORMATION-
WITH LOCAL DEPARTMENTS- IN A
MORE TIMELY WAY THAT'S REALLY
PUBLIC HEALTH SPECIFIC AS WELL
AND- AND REALLY IMPROVE WE'VE
DEVELOPED REGIONAL- YOU KNOW.
WORKING ANSWER SOME OF OUR
STUFF SAID SIT IN ON THEIR
REGIONAL MEETINGS TO REALLY
HELP IMPROVE OUR COORDINATION
THESE LOCAL COORDINATION TEAMS.
AS WELL AS THE STRIKE TEAM SO-
IT IS A CHALLENGE THE
INFORMATION FLOW- AND THE
MAGNITUDE. RELATION FLOWS WELL
HAS BEEN CHALLENGING- SO I
THINK- OFTEN WHEN THINGS ARE
MOVING FAST I THINK YOU KNOW IN
A GIVEN. YEAR VERY QUITE A
QUESTION ANY GIVEN. OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT LEADER OF MAY
NOT HAVE HEARD THE LATEST IF-
THEY HAVEN'T KEPT UP WITH THEIR
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF EMAILS OR
YOU KNOW WE TRY TO COMMUNICATE
A LOT OF DIFFERENT. WAYS AND
AGAIN WE CAN TO TRY TO IMPROVE
THAT. AND I AND I HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE KALKA AND- SOME.
DATA YOUR DASHBOARD. THE LAN
AGREE DID OUT THERE BUT I JUST
WONDER. IF PEOPLE ARE ARE YOU
ABLE TO TRACK THE PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY UTILIZING IT. AND THEN
ON OUR PURE DATA SYSTEMS ARE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY IS THE INPUT
GOING INTO BEING INTEGRATED I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN. SOME LAG IF.
A PROVIDER. HAS BEEN ACCEPTED.
BUT THEY'RE NOT INTEGRATED INTO
OUR OUR DATA. SYSTEM HAS NOT
BEEN ADDRESSED YET. OTHER HAVE
BEEN HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS
AS FAR AS YOUR YOUR LETTER
QUESTION OF- IT'S TRUE YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE'S DEFINITELY A DATA
LAG AND GETTING- AS THE DATA
AROUND DOSES ADMINISTERED INTO
THE SYSTEMS AND I THINK THE
OTHER CHALLENGES BEEN A FEW
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS OTHERS THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM WHICH IS THE
VACCINE FINDER SYSTEM. WE HAVE
OUR IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY BUT
AGAIN THERE'S THREE DIFFERENT
REGISTRIES- WHEN ONE STATEWIDE
THE TO REGIONALS THAT ARE-
SEPARATE AND THAT STARTED
SEPARATELY AND WE HAVE- MATHIS
AND AGAIN SO THERE'S BEEN A
HUGE TEAM OF PEOPLE LIKE
REALLY. LITERALLY WORKING
CALLING- PROVIDERS AND TRYING
TO GET ON THE GROUND DATA AND
CONTINUE IMPROVE THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF IT INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES THAT WE DISCOVERED THAT-
HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES TO GET
THAT DATA IN A MORE TIMELY WAY-
THERE ARE REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
ABOUT- INPUTTING THE DATA IN A
TIMELY WAY TO THE- THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM AND NOW OURS AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY THE LATEST
COMMUNICATIONS THIS WEEK ABOUT
YOU KNOW YOU MUST MUST MUST.
AND BE PUTTING THAT DATA AND
PUTTING IT IN A TIMELY WAY- AND
IT WILL IMPACT ACTUALLY
DOWNSTREAM PROVIDERS ABILITY TO
GET MORE VACCINE IF THEY'RE NOT
IN PUTTING IT SO. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING HARD TO PROVE THAT I WE
DO THINK YOU KNOW AND IT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR EQUITY BECAUSE I
THINK THERE ARE SOME. FRONTLINE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE SERVING
EXACTLY THE PEOPLE WE NEED THEM
TO SERVE THE MOST BUT DON'T
HAVE A ROBUST I. T. STRUCTURE
SO THEY MIGHT BE PUTTING ON
PAPER FIRST AND THEN THE NEW
DATA ENTRY SO WE'RE ALSO
WORKING TO. RESOURCE THAT AS
WELL AND TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES SO THAT WE CAN STILL-
AGAIN REGIONAL POPULATIONS THAT
WE NEED TO THE MOST. AT THE
DISTURBANCE WITH THE QUESTION
DOCTOR PANEL ASKING ABOUT I. T.
I MEAN IT'S I THINK THAT IS ONE
OF. THE HUGE THINGS AND AS A AS
A SOCIAL WORKER I WORK CLOSELY
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AND I KNOW
WE HAVE BEEN UNDER RESOURCE AND
I'VE HEARD WE'VE BEEN UNDER
RESOURCE FOR A LONG TIME. AND
NOW WE GO INTO A PANDEMIC ON
AGAIN WE SEE THE RESULT OF NOT
HAVING A ROBUST PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. BUT AS WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WITH DATA AND AS BIG AND
DIVERSE IS OUR STATE IS THE
DATA PART OF IT AND THE DATA
SHARING PART OF IT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND YOU'RE
RIGHT THOSE WITH THE GREATEST
AGREES OF DISPARITIES ARE THOSE
OFTENTIMES YOU DON'T HAVE. AT
THE FACILITY OR THE STAFF OR
JUST A TIME TO BE ABLE TO DO
ALL THIS SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
BUILDING UP PUBLIC HEALTH WITH
A COMPLETE STRUCTURE MEMBER.
OUR OUR LOCALS ON THE GROUND AT
AND- I KNOW AS I. WE DO AS YOU
SAID. THINGS ARE ARE MOVING
VERY SICK. AND THEN JUST FINE.
IT BECAUSE IT WHEN INFORMATION
GOES OUT A SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION. WE'RE GOOD WHEN DO
YOU THINK WE'LL GET TO THE
POINT THAT WE'RE THE PEOPLE CAN
EXPECT A VACCINATION. I KNOW WE
HAD SAID STE YOU KNOW.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS SIXTY FIVE
AND THEN AND I KNOW THE-
SOMETIMES WE'LL GET A THOUSAND
DOSES A WEEK AND SOMETIMES YOU
WON'T AND THEN I GOT A EMAIL
THAT WENT OUT TO MY ENTIRE ONE
OF MY BIGGEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT SAID. OF ALL EDUCATORS ARE
GOING TO GET VACCINATED IN THE
NEXT THREE WEEKS AND SOMEBODY
ASK ME AM I GOT. I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT- AND THEN THEY'RE LIKE IS
IT TRUE WELL. IN AN EMAIL SAYS
YOU KNOW DEPENDING ON SUPPLY
BUT ARE WE GETTING INFORMATION
THAT A MASSIVE AMOUNT IS COMING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO.
REALLY GO OUT AND- VACCINATE
ALL OF OUR EDUCATORS IN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS AND HOW HOW
CLOSE ARE WE TO GETTING ALL OF
OUR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS
VACCINATED BEFORE WE MOVED TO
NEXT YEAR THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NOT TO GET PEOPLE'S
HOPES UP. JUST TO THEN HAVE TO
EXPLAIN- SORRY WE MADE A
MISTAKE. WHICH IS NOT YOUR TURN-
GREAT QUESTION I THANK YOU FOR
THE PROMPT I ACTUALLY MEANT TO
MENTION SORT OF- WE HAVE. I AM
VERY HAPPY TO SAY WE HAVE
VACCINES. OVER FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOSES OF THE
ADMINISTERED. AND WE JUST HAVE
THE ONE MILLION MARK FOR A ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED- YOUR OTHER POINT
THAT AND THEN WE HAD ABOUT
EIGHT MILLION DOSES DELIVERED
AND I THINK THE OTHER. AND WE
USED ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THOSE
JUST AS FAR AS WHAT WE HAVE IN
OUR SYSTEM SO- WHAT'S THE
ELIGIBLE POPULATION ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT SO WE HAVE
ABOUT THREE MILLION ELIGIBLE
HELP. PEOPLE IN PHASE ONE EIGHT
WHICH IS THE HEALTHCARE WORKERS
IN NURSING HOMES AND ABOUT A
HALF MILLION IN THAT. YEAR WHEN
INCLUDING TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS- IN AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS. AS WELL AS- THEY WERE
TO THE SERVICES RESPOND AS AND
PEOPLE SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE
AND OLDER SO WE- WE DEFINITELY
HAVE- MORE PEOPLE ELIGIBLE THEN
SUPPLY THAT WE ARE GETTING
AROUND ONE MILLION AND THEN
INCREASE THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOSES A WEEK. IN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS SO YOU KNOW-
SO AND THEN YOUR OTHER QUESTION
IS WHEN DO WE THINK IT'LL
REALLY BE MORE WHEN THE NUMBER
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING YOU KNOW
SPRING AS- THAT- THAT ALSO
DEPENDS ON YOU KNOW THE NEXT.
TO VACCINES THAT ARE MUCH
CLOSER THAT JANSSEN. VACCINES
AS- HAS SUBMITTED AN
APPLICATION AND SHE'S NOT ATION
THEY HAVE AN THAT- AND- REVIEW
THAT AND THE BRAIN ARE SEEN TO.
FIFTH BE. RIGHT NOW THAT
HOPEFUL. AND THAT IS ACTUALLY
WONDERS. THAT REALLY. HELP A
LOT WHICH IS ARE. WE WANT TO
SEE THAT. SO WE ARE HOPE. THAT
THIS- YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE MUCH
MORE VACCINE ARE AT LEAST AN
INCREASE SUPPLY- AND- CAN
REALLY BE. HOPEFULLY SOON AFTER
THAT BE ABLE TO OPEN UP TO A
MUCH BROADER MALAYSIANS BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW. AGAIN WORST
RESTING TO AND WEBER WITH THE
FEDERAL. SURPRISE WELL- WE DO
HOPE TO BETTER OF. MATHIS HOW
PEOPLE WE KNOW IN HERE YOU AS
IS THAT. I MUST COMMON QUESTION
AND ONE. FROM AND IT THE AND
THEN ALL THE SUBJECT OF. OR SO
WE HAD THIS GRAY SYSTEM ARE WE
GONNA CONTINUE. TO USE THAT-
AND I KNOW IT CANMAKE IT AND I
CAN TALK MY COUNTY BUT IT'S BY
EXAMPLE. THE IT'S A WE'RE GONNA
START- VACCINATING PEOPLE DOWN
ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF STOCKTON
BUT I HAVE. HERE IS UP LIKE IN
THORTON ON THE NORTH SIDE OF
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. THERE'S IT
IS IT IS VERY ISOLATED ARE WE
ABLE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
USE THOSE CONTRACT RESEARCH
GOING FORWARD. PERHAPS TO HELP
WITH DISTRIBUTION. OR TO HELP
WITH- IT IS VERY I ALSO BOUGHT
A AG AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. I'M
THAT REALLY NEED TO BE IN THERE
AND MAY NOT HAVE THE SAME KIND
ACCESS SO WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ACTUALLY REACH. A REAL
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WHO WHO
YOU KNOW MAY NOT KNOW HAVE A
SMARTPHONE. MAY NOT KNOW THEY
HAVE TO DRIVE YOU KNOW TWENTY
MILES TELLS TO GO GET
VACCINATED WHAT DO WE DO IT TO
GET USES CONTRACTORS IN THIS
SYSTEM WILL DEVELOP. TO GET OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITIES AND ON THE
GROUND. YES I THINK- BOTH A THE
STATE LEVEL USE THAT- WE CAN BE
REJECT. SOME OF THOSE RESOURCES
AREN'T THAT HAVE BEEN THE-
ALONG LEVEL. SO WE- OUT TO
PARENTS AND THAT'S ABOUT MANY
THE- MANY- GROUND HAVE RE
DIRECT. SOME OF THOSE RESOURCES
TO HAVE A TECHNICIAN AND I
THINK THAT IS THE OTHER PART
WORKING CLOSELY WITH. OUR
MINISTRY THERE ARE AROUND. I TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN ENGAGE ONE-
SIMILARLY COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND WHO ARE TRUSTED BECAUSE
YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT WE NEED TO
HAVE INTERESTS AND- MSSENGERS
ON. OUTREACH AND AGAIN
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF- THAT'S A
LOT OF WORK IN PROCESS WITH.
OUR PRIME MINISTER TO HELP MAKE
SURE WE ARE- FUNDING AND
ENGAGING THOSE RESOURCES THAT
ARE NEEDED TO REALLY RECHARGE.
OKAY THEN JUST BEFORE I GO TO
MAKE MY COLLEGES FROM I. GET IN
MY HEAD. SO THE THIRD PARTY IS
GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTING
VACCINES. TO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OUR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH.
THEY'LL BE ALLOCATING. AND ALL
THEN ONE THEY'RE OUT. THEN THE
DISTRICT COMES TO THEM FROM THE-
FROM IT- THE VACCINE. THE
BOTTOM OKAY YES WILL BE
ALLOCATED OKAY THANK. THANK THE
GENERAL. BUT THANK YOU CHAIR I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- THE
FIRST ONE IS GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE HAD- PRIVATE
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
OPEN FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AND DOING SO FOLLOWING
GUIDELINES IN KEEPING EVERYONE
SAFE I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHY OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE NOT ALSO
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT THAT'S MY
FIRST QUESTION YOU CAN. ANSWER
THAT PLEASE AND THEN THEY'LL
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND ONE. SO I
THINK- AS YOU ALSO KNOW I THINK
WE'VE BEEN REALLY WORKING
REALLY DILIGENTLY AND CHEST-
AS- SERVING OF A SAFE SCHOOLS
HOUSE AND- HOLES SAY SCHOOLS
TEMA TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND-
ACTUALLY HAVEN'T HEARD THE
LATEST STATUS ON ON THAT- THE
POTENTIAL FUNDING THAT. THAT
WE'RE HOPING CAN REPORTED THAT
I THINK I THINK ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS ARE ALL
THERE I THINK WE HAVE REALLY-
AS FAR AS THAT GOES- IT IS AN
EFFORT THAT WE HAVE BEEN. ALSO
REALLY- EXPLAINS CROSS- CROSS
AGENCY- COLLABORATION WITH. AD
IN THE STATE BOARD- WITH OSPINA
AND HELLO SHAD TO COME UP WITH
TACKLE SYSTEMS TEAMS TO HELP.
THE SCHOOLS DIRECTLY AND LOCAL
HEALTH. SYSTEMS WE'VE BEEN
USING A LOT OF THESE ACTUALLY
ARE CAL CONNECTS RESOURCE FOR
CONTACT TRACING IS ALSO NOW-
CREATING THESE PORTALS FOR
SCHOOLS TO USE- SO THAT THEY
CAN- WORK CLOSELY WITH LOVED
NOT. HAVING TO NEW CASES
INVESTIGATIONS AND THEN WE
JUST- AND THAT DASHBOARD ABOUT
WHICH SCHOOLS ARE ARE OPEN SO.
WE'VE. BEEN ACTUALLY WORKING ON
THAT I THINK- OKAY THIS IS
ANOTHER OF. ALL COMMUTER ALL-
ALL- IN APPROACH THE WE NEED TO
WORK UNDER. TO THAT WE HAVE TO
HEAR NOT PART BUSES BEGINNERS.
ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS NOT THE-
EMPIRE CHARTERS AND- WHAT
DOCTOR PINE A PRE YOUR RESPONSE
HOWEVER IT'S- IT'S BEEN A YEAR.
AND A PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE ABLE
TO OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION SAFELY. I STILL
DON'T HAVE ANY ANSWERS TO WIRE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS CANNOT CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT THE HOLD UP IS
BECAUSE THE DASHBOARD IS GREAT.
AND TALKING ABOUT IT IS GREAT
AND THAT'S WONDERFUL THAT
EVERYBODY'S COMMUNICATING
WHAT'S NOT HAPPENING IS THE
EDUCATION IN THE CLASSROOM
WHERE THE KIDS NEED TO BE SO
CAN YOU. PROVIDE ME SOME
CLARITY ON WHAT THE HOLD UP IS.
I MEAN THE- WE HAVE PROVIDED
GUIDELINES THAT- YOU KNOW WE
ARE NOT RESTRICTED. SCHOOLS
FROM THE OPENING WE ARE
ENCOURAGING- YOU KNOW AGAIN
WITH. THE PLANS AND SAFETY- TO
PROVIDE YOU KNOW. THE GUIDANCE
TECH ASSISTANCE FOR SCHOOL
THREE OF. BUT YOU ARE HELPING
TO PROMULGATE THE REGULATIONS
AND GUIDELINES BEHIND THESE
TEARS RIGHT THE SYSTEM IS PUT
IN PLACE A DETERMINES. WHAT CAN
OPEN AND WHEN THEY CAN OPEN ARE
YOU NOT INVOLVED WITH THAT. YES
WE'RE DOING THAT FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW SO AND WHAT
THAT WAS MY POINT IS THAT.
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE NOT
PROHIBITING THEM FROM OPENING
BUT REALLY YOU ARE BECAUSE YOU
ARE. HELPING TO PUT TOGETHER
THESE REGULATIONS AND STANDARDS
THAT THEY HAVE TO MEET. WHICH
THEY CANNOT MEET WHICH MEANS
THEY CAN'T OPEN SO- I JUST I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE CAN
HAVE PRIVATE SCHOOLS OPEN. AND
THAT'S SEEMS TO BE FINDING
GOING SMOOTHLY. BUT THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
ARE LEFT TO LANGUISH AT HOME IN
FRONT OF A LAPTOP COMPUTER AND
IT IS BEEN A YEAR. TWENTY YEAR
AND I DON'T SEE ANY END IN
SIGHT AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE
TEARS ON HERE. AND I SEE THE
YELLOW TEAR WHICH IS ONE CASE
OR LESS PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN EVEN IN THAT TIER.
THERE ARE STILL SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT RESTRICTIONS SO
WHAT WILL IT TAKE. TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO OPERATE IN THE MANNER
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO OPERATE
WHAT WILL IT TAKE WILL IT TAKE
COMPLETE ERADICATION OF. ANY
AND ALL CORONAVIRUSES BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING. SO I
WILL SAY THAT I DO THINK WHAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY
CAREFULLY ON IS MAKING SURE WE
HAVE AGAIN GUIDANCE FOR C.
RAMBLINGS AND SUCCESSFULLY
OPENINGS. AND OUR SCHOOL STAFF
NEED TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
RETURNING TO SCHOOL AND THAT
IS- EXACTLY WHAT IS HEALTH AND
FORM- THEY CAN AND WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF EDUCATION AND
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY IN THE
LAST. FEW MONTHS OF- REALLY
SHOWING- THAT YOU CAN DO THAT
SAFELY IF YOU MASS YOU HAVE
DISTANCING OF CONFEDERATION
COHORTS- AND ALL THAT IS- THIS
THING ORIGINAL BUT WE ALSO NEED
OUR- SCHOOLS TO BILLS THEY
FRIEDMAN RETURNING AND THAT IS.
NOT AS YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE WE
HAVE WORKED ON IN ORDER TO.
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SCHOOL.
STAFF AND COMMUNITIES ALLSTATE.
OKAY WELL I. THAT RESPONSE BUT
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH. THIS IS
ALREADY HAPPENING THAT IT IS
HAPPENING SAFELY IN THE
TEACHERS DO FEEL SAFE GOING
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY DOING
IT IN THE PRIVATE SCHOOL
SETTING. WE'RE JUST KEEPING THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL KIDS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. FROM BEING ABLE TO
DO SO AND I AM AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE AND- I'M SURE CLEARLY
SEE I'M VERY FRUSTRATED BY THAT
AS ARE. A LOT OF PEOPLE- THAT
THE SECOND QUESTION I HAVE
RELATES TO STUDENT SPORTS. WE
HAVE SEEN- YOU KNOW
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS MAJOR
SPORTS BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR SEASONS WITHOUT- ANY
MAJOR PROBLEMS. AND I AM
WONDERING WHY WE ARE NOT-
ALLOWING THAT. TO BE REPLICATED
IN YOUTH SPORTS SO THAT THEY
CAN GET BACK TO PLAYING SPORTS
AS WELL CAN YOU ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FOR ME. YOUR RELIGION
RELEASE ARE USED SPORTS
GUIDANCE AND AGAIN IT'S IT IS
BASED ON DISEASE TRANSMISSION-
LOOKING AT AGAIN BALANCING
SAFETY WITH NOW WE HAVE SEEN A
SUPPORT. AFTER RECREATION AND-
KIDS UPSWING EXERCISE AND
ACTIVITY I THINK WORK AND-
GENERALLY TRYING TO BALANCE
THAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN A LOT OF
SPORTS OFFERINGS WE'VE SEEN
SOME OLD INTERSTITIALS WITHOUT
BREAKS AND ASK YOUR FRIEND
ABOUT. SPECIALS AND I KNOW SOME
OF THE COLLEGE TEAMS NOT CANCEL
HAPPENED GAMES BECAUSE I'VE HAD
SO MANY CASES SO. AGAIN WE YOU
KNOW THIS AS I MENTIONED IN THE
VERY BEGINNING I THINK WE HAVE
A REALLY. TRY TO EMPHASIZE
BALANCING AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS TO MOVE- MINIMIZE
DISEASE TRANSMISSION AND
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT ON THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WITH ALSO
KIND OF SAFELY. RE OPENING YOU
KNOW THE VARIOUS PARTS OF OUR
ACTIVITIES AS A SOCIETY AND
ECONOMY AND IT IS A DIFFICULT
BALANCE IN THIS VIRUS HEY- CAN
TURN VERY QUICKLY SO I THINK
THE- I DIDN'T EVEN TOUCH ON
VARIANTS WHICH AGAIN WE ARE.
ACTUALLY WORKING ON SOMETHING
CREEK SURVEILLANCE FOR ARAFAT
IN GAZA BORDER WILD CARDS THAT
IS THE NEWEST FONG. AND THEN I
CAN HOW THAT COULD. TURN US
INTO ANOTHER SURGERY HOPING
THAT THIS LAST WAS. THE LAST
ONE BUT- OUR WHERE WE LET'S SEE
WHAT. AND THESE OTHER VARIANTS
THAT HAVE BEEN HOW. TEND TO BE
MORE INFECTIOUS. OKAY FOR MY
FOR QUESTION- AND GOING TO THE
YELLOW T. IS THE MAY TO. NEW K.
PER ONE THOUSAND IS LESS THAN
ONE- AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
RESTRICTIONS- YEAH I MEAN EVEN
IN TIER ONE WHERE IT'S LESS
THAN ONE CASE PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND YOU HAVE CHURCHES CAN
BE OPEN INDOORS BUT ONLY AT 50%
CAPACITY. SO. IS IT THAT-
UNTIL. WE GET RID OF THIS TIER
SYSTEM AND IT'S ENTIRELY
INTEGRITY. THAT THINGS WILL
REVERT TO THE WAY THEY WERE PRE
CAVITIES IS DRY UNDERSTAND THAT
CORRECTLY THAT ONCE WE SAY WE
NO LONGER NEED TO STEER SYSTEM
AND EVERYTHING REVERTS TO PRE
COVERED. RIGHT AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT THE BLUEPRINT AS YOU
ARE SPEAKING AND YEAH VACCINES
ARE REALLY OUR ANSWER TO GET
THAT RIGHT AND SO WE NEED TO
GET TO COMMUNITIES SO THIS IS
WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
OUR FOCUS RIGHT NOW IS ON
ACTIVATIONS. SO ONCE WE CAN GET
TO COMMUNITY THEN WE CAN
FINALLY GET TO A PLACE BEYOND
THIS FRAMEWORK INTO THE GREENS
ON BECAUSE IT ADDS VERY
PURPOSEFUL THERE'S NOT A GREENS
OUT HERE YET WE ARE. ONCE WE
CAN GET TO COMMUNITY THAT IS
WHEN WE GET TO A POST. POST
PANDEMIC POST- PRINT WITH THOSE
TEARS. OKAY WE ARE YES THE-
RIGHT NOW- WELL THANK YOU FOR
THE INFORMATION I WILL TELL YOU
THAT ON A PERSONAL NOTE I FIND
THAT THE FACT. THAT THERE ISN'T
A GREEN TO EUROPE. A BIT OF A
PESSIMISTIC VIEW- AND ONE THAT
IS NOT LOST ON CALIFORNIANS BUT
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR YOUR
ANSWERS. AND ARKHIPOV I COULD
JUST ASK A- THE FOLLOW UP TO
THAT SO MY UNDERSTANDING WAS
THAT THE SCHOOLS THAT WERE HAVE
ALREADY OPENED WERE L. ABLE TO
CONTINUE BUT THAT NO NEW
SCHOOLS WHO WHO MET THE
CRITERIA WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
OPEN SINCE SINCE WE WERE ON
LOCKDOWN HAS THAT NOW BEEN
LIFTED AND OF SCHOOLS. ARE ABLE
TO OPEN SAFELY THEY THEY ARE
ABLE TO AT THIS POINT. SO ACT
THE END OUR GUIDANCE ONE OF
THAT BENCHMARKS IS BEING UNDER
THE TWENTY FIVE VIEW STREET-
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER DAY- BUT
IF THE SCHOOL IS UNDER THAT AND
MEETS ALL THE SORT OF
GUIDELINES- TO SAFELY OPEN AND
ITS ITS PHASE SO COULD BE
EITHER SOME SCHOOLS ARE
STARTING WITH TAKING THREE TWO
ZERO OUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS-
AND SUBMITTING THEIR PUBLIC
SAFETY PLANS KIND OF A
COMBINATION OF- THE OSHA
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN THE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE THEN THEY CAN
REOPEN YES. EVEN IN A PUT IN
EVEN IN A PERFECT HERE. YEAH IN
THE POP CULTURE. A RATED FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER DAY. OKAY
IT BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW AND I
THINK WHAT IS HAPPENING PLACES
SCHOOLS OPEN AND THEN AND WE
ALL WE ALL WANT AND WE KNOW
ESPECIALLY. ON WOMEN OF COLOR
HAVE BEEN THE LARGEST GROUP TO
FALL OUT OF THE WORK FORCE AND
WE KNOW A LOT OF THAT IS
BECAUSE OUR SERVICE INDUSTRIES
AND THEY HAVE TO STAY HOME
PEOPLE TO. STAY HOME WITH KIDS-
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IF WE
OPEN THEM TOO SOON AND THERE'S
AN OUTBREAK AND IT'S EVEN
HARDER ON FAMILIES TO HAVE TO.
FIND CHILDCARE AND THEN NOT AND
THEN AND GO BACK AND FORTH AND
I THINK NOBODY WANTS THAT. AND
I THINK YOU KNOW I THINK WE
CONTINUE TO SEE EXAMPLES OF
THIS TENSION WHICH IS WHAT
MAKES IT SO DIFFICULT PEOPLE
WANTING TO OPEN. AND SOMETIMES
NOT BE COMPLIANT WITH
GUIDELINES. AND THEN TRYING TO
REALLY MAINTAINED THE SAFETY OF
EVERYBODY GOING FORWARD SO- SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT A DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- BACK
ON IT'S NOT A DO I THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR HARD WORK I KNOW THAT
YOU NOT ONLY OF COURSE OUR
STATE EPIDEMIOLOGIST YET STEP
IN FOR A WHILE TO. ACTUALLY
HELP. A RUNNER. FOR A PUBLIC
HEALTH. AS WELL AS WELL AND-
DURING DISCOUNT CODE PANDEMIC
SO. CERTAINLY WANT TO RECOGNIZE
YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP DURING THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TIME- I DO WANNA.
BASE ON- CONTACT TRACING AND-
YOU DRESS SOME OF THAT IN YOUR
REMARKS- IN A- SILVER ARE I
GUESS OUR HOPE IS VACCINES AND-
YEAH WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH A
SHORTAGE OF VACCINES. I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THAT- THE
VACCINES THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
WORD JUST APPROVED FOR- UNDER
DELAYS FOR USE I GUESS AT THIS
POINT IS IT OR EVEN AT TWO
MONTHS NOW. SO YOU KNOW I.
THINK IT'S EAGER AS WE ARE WE
ALSO BE CONSCIOUS OF SOME THE
TIME LINES BEHIND BEHIND THAT
TOO- AS WELL AND WELL WE'RE
TRYING TO GET OUR VACCINATION
RATES UP AND I AND I WOULD
POINT OUT. THAT- EVEN IF WE
ABLE TO GET VACCINES TO
EVERYONE WE STILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO MAY
NOT WHO IN THE SAME WAY THEY
REFUSE TO WEAR MASKS- AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE SPREAD ALSO
MAY REFUSE TO GET VACCINATED. A
WIN FOR SURE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO VACCINATE THEIR CHILDREN.
UNTIL THAT'S APPROVED AND WHILE
CERTAINLY- THEIR- LIVES AT LESS
RISK NOT ZERO RISK AT LESS RISK
OF CODED- THAT- THEY MAY. ALSO
PARTICIPATE AND THE SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE AND FORTY UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO VACCINATE ONLY
SOME OF THEM. THAT'S STILL 20%
OF POPULATION DEBTS- CAN REMAIN
UNVACCINATED TOLD THOSE UNTIL
THEY'RE PROVED SO THAT'LL TAKE
A LITTLE TIME WE'RE TALKING
SKILL MONTHS THAT'S STILL
PRETTY FAST- BUT- SO IN THE
MEANTIME I DID WANT TO TOUCH ON
CONTACT TRACING I KNOW WE SPENT
THE FUNDS FOR A CONTACT RECENT
PLATFORM IN VIRTUAL CONTACT
TRACING. CALAMY IT CETERA- WHAT
CAN YOU JUST SPEAKTO OUR
CONTACT TRACING CAPACITY I KNOW
I KNOW THAT AND- THE NUMBER OF
CASES WE HAD AND- JANUARY- IN
DECEMBER. AND WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF CASES NOW I MEAN WE ARE
DETAINED RIGHT DIRECTION BUT
LET'S LET'S BE CLEAR I THINK
WE'RE STILL ABOVE OUR SUMMER
PEAK CELLS. BEFORE IN TERMS OF
CASES AND YOU CAN CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG- BUT WHAT IS THE
CAPACITY TO ACTUALLY CONTACT
FACE PAZ KEYS SO WE ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND WHERE. THE CAL CASES
ARE SPREADING ARE YOU ABLE TO
DO IN DEPTH CONTACT TRACING
WHAT DEGREE ARE PEOPLE
COOPERATING ARE NOT COOPERATING
WITH CONTACT RACING IN THE SAME
WAY THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
COOPERATING WITH MASKS AND-
CLIPPING OF VACCINES WHICH IS
ALSO LIMITING OUR ABILITY TO.
BE ABLE TO OPEN SCHOOLS SAFELY
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS SO
CAN YOU SPEAK TO. WHAT IS THE
CURRENT STATE OF OUR
CONTRACTORS IN CAPACITY AND THE
LEVEL COOPERATION WE'RE GETTING
FROM PEOPLE. AND OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY HOW THIS
DISEASE IS CONTINUING TO
SPREAD. ESPECIALLY AS WORLD
CONCERNED ABOUT NEW VARIANTS AS
AS WELL. AND AND THEIR
INSTRUCTIONS THERE SO THAT
AGAIN. IS COMES FROM DATA FROM
CONTACT RACING. YES SIR- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER HANFORD.
OF THE- RECOGNITION AS WELL
AND- THEN- AS FAR AS OUR
CONTACT USING I THINK A COUPLE
THINGS ONE I JUST WANNA AGAIN
ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHT THAT. THE
SYSTEM AND YOU KNOW I WAS
EMPHASIZING THE NEED FOR DAM
SECTIONS AND THAT'S CAL
CONNECTS THEM IS ABSOLUTELY-
YOU KNOW. THEN A RAPID KIND OF
UP SKILLING AND SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE USED YOU KNOW BEYOND A
CODED AND BAR MULTIPLE DISEASES
I THINK. YOU KNOW INNER IS
REALLY COMFORTING EMPIRE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM AND HAVING
A CONTACT DATABASE- WHICH WE
DIDN'T HAVE STATEWIDE SO
THAT'LL BE VERY THIS WOMAN
PARTY THINK. YOU'RE A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION ABOUT DURING
THE MIDDLE THE SURGE YOU KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE REALLY
CONTACT AND WE DO HAVE SOME
DATA. YOU KNOW THAT- A
COMBINATION OF. JUST THE
ABSOLUTE NUMBERS MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO REACH- CASES AND
CONTACTS AND SO I THINK AT THE
PEAK OF. THINGS YOU KNOW IT
SOMETIMES WAS LESS THAN HALF OF
CASES ARE CONTACT MIGHT BE-
RESPONDING TO- TO REACH S THEY
THINK THE OTHER TECHNOLOGY
THINGS THAT LEVERAGE BUT AGAIN.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY RICH
ARTISTRY OPERATION BUT WE DO
HAVE THIS CALIFORNIA NOW TO
FIND OUT. I ALSO HAVE- A
VIRTUAL AGENT. AND WE'RE DOING
MORE MORE INTERNET TO LINK THAT
TO YOUR- LABORATORY TESTING-
DATA RESULTS SO THAT WHEN
SOMEONE GETS NOTIFIED OF THEIR
TEST RESULTS THEY CAN ALSO GET.
CODE TO RESPOND TO THAT SORT OF
A MARKET SURVEY IF THEY ARE
TECH SAVVY AND- AGAIN. WE HAVE
THIS IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH NOW- BUT THAT IS A WAY
TO KIND OF LEVERAGE THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND HELP LOCAL. ARTS
PRIORITIZE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF I'M PATTERSON THAT- I THINK
THAT IF YOU WANT SPECIFICS
ABOUT. SOME OUR METRICS I'M
HAPPY TO. I'M NOT FINDING WEEK
FIND TO YOU. YOU GET A MONTH
DATA THAT WE SYSTEM THAT IN THE
CITY'S. ON THE PERCENT OF CASE
THAT ARE IN. WITH YOU KNOW ONE
IN JUNE. AND THEN I OF CONS OR-
IN WITHIN A DAY AND- AND HOW WE
GET HAS. SO WE FOLLOWING WE
CREATE. I THINK IT IS
DEFINITELY CHEN IN THE A START
BUT I THINK. IS DUE TO- REACT
WHERE I. REAL AT THAT AS WELL
WITH THE- AND KIND OF. IS THE
CAPACITY NEEDED BIRTH I'M THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE WORK FORCE
AND- KIND OF RE LOOKING AT THAT
WE HAD PROJECT AND I THINK THE-
ENTIRE TEAM RIGHT AWAY. ARRIVAL
HAD LOOKED AT- THE CAPACITY AND
NEEDING TO HAVE YOU KNOW X.
NUMBER OF- CONTACT TRACERS FOR
EXTRA PIECES- SO WE'RE KIND OF
RE LOOKING AT THAT AS WELL.
WITH HONORS AND UPDATES. AND
LESSONS LEARNED OVER THE LAST.
OKAY THANKS YEAH I APPRECIATE
THAT. YOU COULD- SHARES. OF
THAT AND- I'D KNOW IF THE- SOME
OF THOSE METRICS ARE PUBLICLY.
OR NOT BUT CERTAINLY BE
INTERESTED IN. THE MARKET AND I
KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD- I'M GOING
TO- CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT. I
WOULD ALSO JUST MAKE NOTE THAT-
WELL- YOU KNOW I THINK MY- GOOD
FRIEND- WHO TALKED ABOUT DO WE
HAVE TO WAIT TO GET TO ZERO- WE
MAY NOT AND- AND- YOU KNOW
THAT'S THAT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
ACTUALLY THERE ARE COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE GOTTEN. PRETTY CLOSE
TO ZERO. AND WHAT THEY'VE DONE
IS THAT- SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
AUSTRALIA. WHEN THEY HAVE AN
OUTBREAK THEY ACTUALLY CLOSE
EVERYTHING DOWN UNTIL THEY GET
DOWN TO ZERO THEY DON'T. OPEN
THE THINGS UP WHEN THINGS ARE
LOWER DAY ACTUALLY WAIT TILL
THEY GET IT DOWN TO ZERO
SOMEONE MILBORNE HAD OUTBREAK
THEY- COLLECT EVERYTHING DOWN
UNTIL ZERO. I WAS ELECTED THE
THING DOWN. THEY DON'T ALLOW
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T ALLOW
PEOPLE RUN AROUND WITHOUT MASKS
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THEIR
PEOPLE SO- I HOPE. YOUR HELP WE
CAN. MAYBE THAT'S A POLICY
THAT- THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
OR SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE- IF
WE REALLY ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS. IS THAT- YEAH WE KNOW
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE- WE'VE
SEEN OTHER COUNTRIES DO IT THE
QUESTION IS THAT. DO WE HAVE
THE WILL TO DO THAT. HERE NOW
IT'S A LITTLE CHALLENGING FOR A
STATE TO DO IT ALONE- BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T. STOP PEOPLE
FROM COMING ACROSS OUR BORDERS.
FROM OTHER STATES- BUT- I THINK
THAT IF PEOPLE ARE SERIOUSLY-
WANTED HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT TRYING TO REOPEN SCHOOLS
AND BUSINESSES. HOPEFULLY THEY
ALSO WILL BE SERIOUS ABOUT
SUPPORTING THINGS LIKE
REQUIRING PEOPLE TO WEAR MASKS
AND- ENFORCING DISTANCE- PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS. ARE SOMEONE WE-
GIVE PEOPLE PASSES TO VIOLATE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS- WE ARE
ESSENTIALLY UNDERMINING ABILITY
TO STOP THIS. A PANDEMIC. AND
PEOPLE OF DUNDAS OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE DONE THIS
WITHOUT THE VACCINES EVEN. SELF
CERTAINLY WE'RE GOING TO WORK
ON VACCINATIONS AND- BUT- IN
THE MEANTIME UNTIL WE TRY TO
GET TO THE PLAY. WHERE
COMMUNITY WHICH WILL TAKE US A
WHILE I MEAN EVEN. ONCE THE
EVEN ONCE WE GET ENOUGH VACCINE
FOR ANYONE WHO WANTS IT WE
STILL HAVE WORK TO DO EVEN
BEYOND THAT TO GET TO THAT
PLACE- WE ARE. GOING TO- NEED
TO. INVEST IN THAT. MAYBE JUST
ONE OTHER. QUESTION AND I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER IT'S HERE AND-
WELL MAYBE DOES THAT ALLEN'S
ASK IT NOW- WHAT KIND OF
INVESTMENTS ARE WE MAKING AND
I'M TRYING TO LOOK AT THE-
AGAIN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL ENTER
AND- MAYBE. NOT IN THIS SECTION
BUT- IN TERMS OF THAT EDUCATION
PIECE RIGHT WE- WE YOU KNOW. WE
NEED TO PERSUADE THE L. WE NEED
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
VACCINES AND ANSWER DIRT
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS THEY HAVE
ABOUT THE VACCINES. AND SO
FORTH- AND- I CAN SO CAN WE
SPEAK TO WHAT. WHAT'S HER. AND
I KNOW SOME OF THAT'S KIND OF.
YOU KNOW HAPPENED SHOULD BE
HAPPENING NO NOT WAITING TILL
JULY FIRST BUT- CAN SPEAK TO
WHAT KIND OF FUNDING AND
RESOURCES ARE PUTTING INTO
THAT- EDUCATION EFFORT- TO.
ADDRESS VACCINE HESITANCY. SO
SHOULD THE SCHOOLS FUNDING
ACTUALLY WONDERING IF THERE'S-
SOME NOT GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DIDN'T RESPOND I KNOW I BELIEVE
THERE'S AN ACT OF SORT OF-
BUDGET REQUESTS. AS WE SPEAK
VETERANS IS BEING REVIEWED- AND
I WANT TO SAY IT'S OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE DON'T
HAVE THE DETAILS. AT THE END OF
OUT FINANCES THERE CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT WHAT WHAT KIND
OF. BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
THEREFORE- DRESSING VACCINE
HESITANCY. HELLO I'M SORRY YES
MA'AM ACTION HAS AND SEE. SOME
OF THE SCHOOLS NOW TALK ABOUT
VACCINE HESITANCY SO WE WE'RE
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS RIGHT NOW
WE DO HAVE THE VACCINES FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE WANT THEM AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO. EVERYONE'S
ASKING ABOUT HOW CAN I GET MY
VACCINE AT SOME POINT WE'RE
GOING TO HIT A POINT WHERE
ACTUALLY EVERYONE WHO WANTS.
ONE IT'S GOING TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO GET ONE TO HAVE. I BELIEVE
IN NOT THAT WILL EVENTUALLY
HAPPENED THEN ARE ISSUES GOING
TO BE. WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE-
DECLINED THE VACCINES SO NOW
MANY OF THEM ACTUALLY MAYBE
JUST. WANTING TO WAIT A LITTLE
WHILE BUT FOR EXAMPLE I THINK
THERE'S SOME DATA THAT SHOWS
THAT- IN OUR NURSING HOMES- IS.
THE CVS WALGREENS PROGRAM
THERE'S BEEN SOME REPORTS- THAT
THE VACCINE TAKE UP RATE. IS
ONLY ABOUT. A LITTLE OVER A
THIRD. THAT THAT ACTUALLY OVER
HALF OF PEOPLE HAVE DECLINED
THE VACCINE TO WORK YOU WORK IN
THE NURSING HOMES- I THINK LA
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT- I
THINK JUST A LITTLE OVER HALF
OF THEIR FIREFIGHTERS HAVE.
ACTUALLY BEEN OFFERED THE
VACCINE OF ACTUALLY TAKING IT.
SO WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO AND
I. AND I. YEAH I THINK SOME OF
THE NAY THIS PEOPLE ARE LIKE
OKAY YOU'LL NEED TO GIVE ME
ANOTHER MONTH AND LET'S SEE
WHAT HAPPENS ALL THE PEOPLE I
KNOW WHO GOT INTO A FINE I'LL
GET MINE. BUT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT DOES SPEAK TO THE NEED TO.
EDUCATE THE ALSO WE DO KNOW
THAT THERE WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES EVEN WE CAN OFFER
PEOPLE VACCINES THAT. SOME OF
THESE GROUPS THAT HAVE ENABLED
OFFERED THAT THERE ARE RATES OF
VACCINE HESITANCY OUT THERE.
AND AS WE TRY TO KEEP.
COMMUNITY WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
THAT. BURGER UPON THIS IS A
DOCTOR TO. NOT ONE. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU FOR THE PERSON I WAS.
BRIEFED YESTERDAY- THERE IS A
LARGE CAMPAIGN THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THE UNDER WAY. AT THE
MOMENT. AND THEY'VE DONE
EXTENSIVE BOTH. A RESEARCH OF
THE LITERATURE. AND THEY'VE
GATHERED CONDUCTING FOCUS
GROUPS WITH OVER A THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO DEAL TO DEAL WITH
THE- WHOLE ISSUE IS HOW DO WE-
GET PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED
AND THERE'S IN THERE
SPECIFICALLY DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE OF VACCINE HESITANCY. IN
DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT-
PRIORITY POPULATIONS- AND I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING.
ADDITIONAL BRIEFINGS AND
DATACOM. AND SO WE CAN SEND
THAT INFORMATION WE CAN COMPILE
THAT INFORMATION AND SEND IT
OVER TO YOU. OKAY I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. I DID I DID THIS
IS BUDGETS OF KATIE WAS ASKING
ABOUT WHAT'S THE BUDGETARY
ALLOCATION IT'S GOING TO BE.
GOING AT THAT WERE- COMMITTEE
TO DIS EFFORTS AS WELL. SO IF.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT READILY
AVAILABLE AT THAT THE
APPRECIATE IF YOU COULD. SHARE
THAT WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
YEAH OKAY YOU FOR I THIS IS
IT'S NOT OUT OF THE UNIQUE
BUDGET BUT THE REST LARGER
UNDERWAY. OKAY THANK YOU I WAS
SURE WHERE IT WAS IN THE BUDGET
THAT SIDE THAT RECOGNIZE THAT
ASSETS HERE IN THE HOPES THAT-
MAYBE SOME CONTRACT IN RIGHT
DIRECTION OAY THANK YOU. YEAH
WE'LL GET THAT- IT AND A FINAL
QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
OUR PANEL AS WELL- BIG
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT. THAT AGAIN
WE HAVE THAT. WE HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE STATE WITH A LOT OF FAT
DIVERSE IDEAS THAT HAVE
OFTENTIMES LED US TO NOT BEING
ABLE TO. OPEN MORE EFFECTIVELY-
THE ISSUE OF PEOPLE NOT BEING
NON COMPLIANT WITH MASKS OR NON
YOU KNOW THAT THERE AND WE HAVE
OUR LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
PARTICIPATING IN- PRESS
CONFERENCES- THING OPENS UP SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF EVEN OUR
LEADERS WHO WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
COMPLAINT WAS SAFETY
GUIDELINES. HAVE WE- I WE
CONSIDERED- WHEN WE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WORKING WITH TRUSTED
ADVISORS AT THAT. AT RISK
COMMUNITIES HAVE WE CONSIDERED.
THEM AND THE VACCINE HESITANCY
DO WE HAVE A STRATEGY FOR
ACTUALLY. ADDRESSING ADDRESSING
THE VERY NON COMPLIANT LARGE
LARGE GROUPS. SMALL GROUPS TO
BE ABLE TO GET OUT WITH THAT
THAT HAS ACTIVELY SPREAD
DISINFORMATION- TO ACTUALLY
TARGET SOME OF THOSE THOSE
GROUPS AND I KNOW YOU KNOW
FARMWORKERS IMPORTANT PEOPLE OF
COLOR LOW SOCIAL ECONOMIC BUT
WE ALSO KNOW. THROUGH THROUGH
THIS YEAR THAT THE- THE
MISINFORMATION THE ALTERNATIVE
FACTS IF YOU WELL I HAVE HAVE
HAVE LED. HAVE WENT TO THE
CONTINUED SPREAD AND THE LACK
OF IS BEING ABLE TO GET CONTROL
OF THIS. DO WE HAVE A PLAN AND
IS THEIR PLACE IN THE BUDGET
THAT ACTUALLY TARGETS- THE
POPULATION WHO COULD ALSO SAY
IS AT RISK AND PUTS THE REST OF
US AT RISK- I CAN. GET A HIGH
LEVEL. HOLSTERED COMMUNICATIONS
TEAM NOW WITH THE VACCINE LPGA
FRAMEWORK- JUST AREN'T ON THE
NORMALIZATION KAGHAN SHANNON TO
REALLY WORK ON VACCINE
HESITANCY. HEARING AS DOCTOR
RUNS AND- IN FOCUS GROUPS THAT
REALLY LOOKING AT- THERE IS A
VACCINE HESITANCY AND SORT OF
REALLY CREATING MESSAGES AND
WORKING WITH JUST MESSAGES AND
THEN THERE'S A WHOLE. PACKAGE
THAT JUST CAME OUT I JUST DON'T
HAVE THE DOLLAR AMOUNT TO WORK
WITH STUDIOS SPECIFICALLY
PROBLEM REASONS UNDER YOUR ARM
IS BEING TO REALLY WORK.
MESSENGERS AND- WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS AND TO COUNTER
MISINFORMATION I THINK WEALSO
HAVE STARTED THAT
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM IS ACTUALLY
MONITORING DOING SOME OF THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA MINING. LOOK AT
THIS INFORMATION AND I'M TRYING
TO COUNTER IT WITH- WITH YOU
KNOW ACTUAL AS FACTS AND THEN
AS AS WE ALL KNOW AND I KNOW.
SENATOR HANDLES WELL TO AND
WORKING MOST BECAUSE OF THE
STRESS MASTERS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THE FACTS ARE NOT
WILL COMPEL PEOPLE THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIND SINCE AND
CHAMPIONS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY-
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY HUGE
EFFORT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT.
WE WERE THAT GOV OFFICE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HE ALREADY
TALKED. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND IF I PAN IS EVERYTHING
I THINK- I THINK WE HEARD FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCE BUT. THE L.
A- BEFORE WE GO TO OUR PANEL.
HEY HI MADAM CHU IN MEMBERS AND
SO NEED. FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S. I HAVEN'T- COMMON-
RELATED TO DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH BUDGET WHEN IT COMES TO
THE CO IN NINETEEN- WE KNOW
THAT FROM A BUDGETARY
PERSPECTIVE MOST OF THE PUBLIC
NINETEEN RESPONSE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. PUBLIC
HEALTH BUDGET IS NOT REFLECTED
IN THE ENACTED TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. OR IN THE
PROPOSED TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. AND THIS IS
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ADJUSTMENTS. AND IT'S CLEAR
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
RELEASED IN JANUARY THAT IT
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IT CITES
THE NEED TO MAINTAIN
FLEXIBILITY S A RESPONSE TO A
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING PANDEMIC.
AND THE ENGINE AND PROVIDED
TODAY HAS A VERY THOROUGH
DESCRIPTION OF THE WAYS THE
ADMINISTRATION AUGMENTED
FUNDING- SINCE ENACTMENT OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO DESCRIBE HOW
PROPOSES TO MAKE ME YEAR
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
THE COUPLE IMPORTANT THINGS TO
NOTE THERE WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES A NEW
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN POINT
NINE FIVE. WHICH WOULD ALLOW
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ARGUMENT
FUNDING DECREASE FUNDING OR
TRANSFER FUNDING BETWEEN A
SELECT NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS.
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW- FOR
EXPENDITURE OF FEDERAL FUNDS IN
THESE- DEPARTMENTS IMPORTANTLY-
TO KNOW THOUGH IS THAT THIS
CONTROL SECTION DOES NOT
INCLUDE A NOTIFICATION. OF THE
LEGISLATURE PROVISION- THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES TO
EXTEND- THE AUTHORITY ALLOWED
THROUGH THE- DISASTER RESPONSE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT.
IT PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE TRIO-
THROUGH THE- THROUGH THE ENTIRE
BUDGET YEAR OTHERWISE THE
AUTHORITY TO SPEND FUNDS
THROUGH THIS ACCOUNT WHICH
WOULD EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR. I'M IN ADDITION WE
ALSO MENTION THAT BECAUSE THE
STATE IS UNDER A DECLARED STATE
OF EMERGENCY IT'S ALLOWED TO
FOREGO THE FORMAL COMPETITIVE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. AND SO JUST TO GIVE
AN EXAMPLE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS USED AS SOME SINCE THE START
OF THE STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR
EXAMPLE- ENTERING INTO A
CONTRACT OF PERKINELMER TO OPEN
THE VALENCIA BRANCH LAB-
THROUGH A NO BID CONTRACTING
PROCESS- WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE TO
RELY ON THIS PROCESS THROUGH-
THROUGH THE END OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. NOW- WE JUST KNOW
THAT BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE HAPPENING
OUTSIDE OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO EXPRESS ITS GOALS AND
PRIORITIES. A PARTICULARLY-
YEAH POTENTIALLY AHEAD OF THE
MAY REVISION SO SOME OPTIONS
FOR HOW THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO
THAT- GIVEN THAT SO MANY OF
THESE THINGS ARE HAPPENING
OUTSIDE OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
IT CAN SEND LETTERS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IT CAN REQUEST
INFORMATION BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AS IT STANDS
TODAY- IT CAN ADD PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO THE BUDGET. IT CAN
REQUIRE ROBUST REPORTING FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT
RESPONDS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NOTIFICATIONS
OF ACTION- IT COULD ALSO
REQUEST MODIFICATIONS TO THE
PROPOSED CONTROL SECTION
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRED
NOTIFICATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
ENSURE CHOIR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO PROVIDE SPECIFIC INFORMATION
WHEN IT IS MAKING A MAJOR
ADJUSTMENT. SO AS HAS BEEN
NOTED ALREADY IN THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
ASKED TO RESPOND QUICKLY- AND
IT YOU KNOW TO BOTH THE MAY
REVISION AS WELL AS POTENTIAL-
MID YEAR. ACTIONS AND- WE
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS SOME CRITERIA AS IT
ASSESSES THESE PROPOSALS- FOR
EXAMPLE IT SHOULD CONSIDER THE
IMPORTANCE AND RELEVANCE OF ANY
PROPOSED ACTION AND HOW IT FITS
INTO THE STATE'S OVERALL
COVERAGE NINETEEN RESPONSE. IT
COULD BE A CONSIDER THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTIVENESS OF ANY
GIVEN PROPOSAL AND WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
ENOUGH INFORMATION- TO SHOW WHY
AND HOW THE PROPOSED ACTION
MIGHT BE EFFECTIVE. IT COULD
CONSIDER THE FEASIBILITY OF ANY
PROPOSED ACTIONS SO JUST TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE HERE. IF THE
PROPOSED ACTIONREQUIRES THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE LOCAL PUBLIC%
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAS THAT
BEEN PROPERLY ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE PROPOSAL. EQUITY IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT CRITERION- AND JUST
TO CONSIDER WHETHER ANY
PROPOSED ACTION WOULD HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACTS ON VARIOUS
GROUPS IN THE STATE. AND THEN
FUNDING AND CONTRACTING WOULD
BE ANOTHER AT KEY CRITERION TO
USE IN ASSESSING PROPOSALS FOR
EXAMPLE WHETHER THAT FUNDING.
IS ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND- AND IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN A WAY THAT WOULD
MAKE IT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT. WE ALSO- IN
CLOSING I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
IF YOU ISSUES TO CONSIDER ONCE
THE STATE BEGINS TO ENTER THE
RECOVERY PHASE FROM THE
pALREADY BEEN MENTIONED TODAY
AND WE DO SO WE WOULD JUST
UNDERSCORE. OF THESE ISSUES ONE
IS TO CONSIDER- WHAT WILL BE
NEEDED IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IN THAT
CONTINUED AN ONGOING RESPONSE
TO COVERT NINETEEN. AND WHETHER
THE ADMINS- THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO CONSIDER- HOW TO
LEVERAGE RESOURCES THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. EITHER IN THE NEAR
TERM OR ON AN ONGOING BASIS SO
THIS COULD INCLUDE. THE VILLAGE
HE WENT BRANCH LAB IT COULD
INCLUDE- AS SUSTAINING SOME OF
THE WORK FORCE THAT'S BEEN
ADDED. AT THE LOCAL AND STATE
LEVEL. ANOTHER KEY ISSUE TO
CONSIDER IS WHAT- ACTIVITIES
PUBLIC HEALTH RELATED
ACTIVITIES HAVE BEEN DEFERRED-
AS THE STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC AND WHAT WOULD BE
TAKE. WHAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO
RECOVER IN THOSE AREAS. AND
FINALLY WEWOULD RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE FUND AND A
COMPREHENSIVE AFTER ACTION
REVIEW- OF THE PANDEMIC I MEAN
THE PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED A
NUMBER OF. DIFFERENT PROBLEMS
IN THE STATE INCLUDING UNDER
RESOURCE STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. A RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES-
COORDINATION PROBLEMS- IN
PUBLIC HEALTH GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES- AS WELL AS AN
OUTDATED IT SYSTEMS SO. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER USING SOME OF THE ONE
TIME- WINDFALL AVAILABLE THIS
YEAR TO FUND. COMPREHENSIVE ACT
AFTER. ACTION REVIEW AND
ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT HOW
DO WE TAKE THIS HUNG UP ONCE IN
A CENTURY- OCCURRENCE- RECOVER
FROM IT AND COME OUT STRONGER
WITH WHAT WE'VE LEARNED. DR AS
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION BY
L. L. I HOPE TO AND IT'S LARGER
AND JUST A SUBCOMMITTEE BUT-
AND I THINK I'VE MENTIONED IT
IN OUR- BUDGET OVERVIEW BUT- I
WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
ELYASAND PUT IT ON HOW WE
MANAGE- SUGGESTIONS ON
CONTROLLING WHICH I THINK THERE
WERE SOME CONCERNS LAST YEAR
ABOUT THE TRAIL OF PROCESS- NOW
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH IT ON A
LONG TERM BASIS AND IT WASN'T
REALLY DESIGNED FOR A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND ONGOING PANDEMIC
GOES MORE FOR SHORT TERM- WELL
THERE'S ONLY A LONG TAIL SAID
THESE YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE
WILDFIRES OR EARTHQUAKES AND
OTHER TYPES OF- EVENTS- WHAT WE
HAVE TO BE SURE THAT WE TAILOR
OUR- OVERSIGHT- FOR THE NATURE
OF. THIS PARTICULAR EMERGENCY
WHICH IS AN ON GOING- SAID
WERE- GET PAST YEAR NOW AND SO
WOULD APPRECIATE LA IS-
SUGGESTIONS AND INPUT INTO HOW
WE CAN. GO ABOUT THIS DOING
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT I THINK WE'LL NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR PANEL THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH. AND FROM OUR PANEL WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE. REPRESENTING
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS HOSPITALS
CLINICS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. C. P. AGN AND SEIU
FROM A LABOR PERSPECTIVE AS
WELL SO WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
EVERYBODY. WITH THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND PERSPECTIVE
WELCOME PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF BEFORE YOU PRESENT THE
START WITH HOSPITAL'S FIRST ON
OUR LIST. THE MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK THIS IS DJ YES. YES
YES YES GREAT GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIGHT
BE JEOPARDIZED IN THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR NURSING CLINICAL
SERVICES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALIZATION THE STATION.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY TALKING
ABOUT THE HOSPITAL EXPERIENCE
OVER THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS.
WHEN COVER NINETEEN CAME TO
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN A YEAR AGO
HOSPITALS WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF OUR STATE'S RESPONSE
REALLOCATING STAFF AND SPACE TO
CARE FOR THE EMERGING COVERED
CASES. AND DEVELOPING
INNOVATIVE METHODS TO SAFELY
PROVIDE CARE TO ALL PATIENTS
THEIR TELEHEALTH AND HOSTILE
HOMES PROGRAMS AMONGST MANY
HOSPITALS RECONFIGURED IN
ADVANCE AND SERVICES SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL ICE YU INVEST IN
NONTRADITIONAL AREAS LIKE
PACKED USING CLOSE UNITS. MANY
HOSPITALS USE LOBBYIST GIFT
SHOP SPACE AT COPE WITH THAT
CAPACITY IN EDIE'S. PUT UP
TENTS TO RECONFIGURE COVENTRY I
JUST MANAGED MASSIVE PATIENT
INFLUX AND INFECTION CONTROL
NEEDS. HOSPITALS QUICKLY
PURCHASES MUCH PROTECTED AND
CLINICAL EQUIPMENT IS AVAILABLE
AND THEY COMPETED WITH THE
WORLD FOR THIS PRODUCT WHICH
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
OBTAIN. WHEN PROPER PP AND
RESOURCES SUCH AS THAKSIN
BECAME SCARCE HOSPITALS FOUND
WAYS TO ENSURE STAFF AND
PATIENTS STAFF AND PATIENTS
WERE SAFE AS POSSIBLE GIVEN THE
RESOURCES ON HAND. AZUL'S HIRED
AND TRAINED MORE STAFF WHENEVER
POSSIBLE TO ANY AND ALL
AVAILABLE TRAVELING INTEMPERATE
TEMPORARY AGENCIES ACROSS. THE
U. S. WHAT FRONT LINE CARE NAY
HAAS WILL PROVIDED HOUSING
CHILD. NIELSEN TRAINING. ALL OF
THIS DONE IN A TIMELY HOSPITAL
HAD JUST THERE'S IN MY AND
POINTY NURSING EXAMPLE IS A AS
ADDING SUPPORT. TO K. FOR THE-
INCREASING OF PATIENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BROUGHT
THE PANDEMIC HOSPITALS HAVE
BEEN AIDED IN THEIR WORK TO
SAVE LIVES REGULAR
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
WITH STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS. THIS MAN IS ON THAT
ON A WHOLE CALIFORNIA'S
PANDEMIC RESPONSE IS AND HAS
BEEN STRONG. THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADERS NURSES DOCTORS
HOSPITALS AND OTHER SHOULD BE
PRAISED FOR THEIR PERSEVERANCE
AND- RESILIENCE. WELL THE
ABSENCE OF HOSPITALS AND OTHERS
HAVE UNDOUBTEDLY SAVED LIVES
THERE ARE MANY LESSONS TO BE
LEARNED IN ACCESS TO BE TAKEN
TO MAKE SURE STATE IS READY FOR
WHATEVER DISASTER COMES NEXT.
WE IN CALIFORNIA NAY TIRE WORLD
WERE OVERWHELMED BY THE SCOPE
AND IMPACT OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
WE MUST RETHINK OUR
CORPORATIONS. WE NEED TO INVEST
MORE IN CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EXPERTISE INCLUDING
MODERNIZE MARGIN SCALABLE DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS.
CALIFORNIA'S DISASTER RESPONSE
NEEDS TO BE RETHOUGHT AND
REDESIGNED IN SEVERAL WAYS. WE
MUST RECONSIDER HOW WE RESPOND
TO REGIONAL VERSUS STATEWIDE
DISASTERS- WE MUST RECONFIGURE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITY IN
DECISION MAKING BETWEEN
COUNTIES TO THE STATE WE NEED
ALIGNMENT AND DECISION MAKING
ACROSS FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
THREE CITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
REDUCED AND CONSISTENCY
CONFUSION DELAYS BARRIERS AND
INEQUITY. WE NEED TO DEVELOP AN
ALTERNATIVE TO CURRENT MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM WHICH IS NOT WORKING
A PANDEMIC WHEN EVERYONE IS IN
NEED OF ASSISTANCE AND THERE'S
NO EXTRA RESOURCE TO OFFER TO
OTHERS. CONSIDER WHAT IS WE
NEED TO CONSIDER WHAT IS
CRITICAL IN ANY DISASTER FOR
EXAMPLE FOCUSING ON EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN AN EARTHQUAKE.
STOCKPORT STOCKPILING PP FOR
INSECTS DISEASE PREPARATIONS OR
TRIAGE PROTOCOLS FOR MASS
CASUALTIES. AND FINALLY WE NEED
TWO INVEST MORE IN. PUBLIC AND
FOR. AN EXPERT. AND MODERN
LARGE AND- DATA ACROSS NOW.
BASED ON THE LATEST TECH. A
WITH FEDERAL EFFORTS. CHF
PROCESS THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO PRESENT HOW WE'VE BEEN
ATTACKED AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ONGOING COLLABORATION TO
STRENGTHEN OUR DISASTER
RESPONSE. THANK YOU. I KNOW THE
HOSPITAL'S EVER HAVE THAT HAVE
HAVE BEEN HORRIBLY IMPACTED
ANNA AND WE THANK ALL OF YOUR
STAFF AND ALL OF THE WORK
THAT'S THAT'S GOING ON AT THE
SAME TIME YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO DO
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
SUPPORT A HOSPITAL TO BE ABLE
TO KEEP ITS DOORS OPEN. SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE REALLY
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINE IN THIS-
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS. YES
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS KEVIN
THANK YOU MANAGER MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CASSIDY BURKE I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE HOPE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
PHYSICIAN HEALTH OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA SIXTY ONE COUNTY AND
CITY JURISDICTIONS. I TESTIFIED
BEFORE YOU AT THIS HEARING LAST
YEAR RECITING A LIST OF NEEDS
OF LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC THANK YOU FOR HEARING
THAT I REVIEWED MY TESTIMONY
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND WAS
PLEASED TO NOTE THAT MOST OF
THE ITEMS YOU PRESENTED WERE
INDEED ADDRESSED THAT SHOWS THE
STRONG RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. THANK YOU FOR
BEING RESPONSIVE TO OUR NEEDS
BUT AS YOU KNOW NEEDS CHANGE AS
TIMES CHANGE AND OUR GREATEST
NEED AS WE WILL DISCUSS LATER
IS ONGOING INVESTMENT. THE
FIRST QUESTION WERE ASKED TO
ADDRESS HERE AT THIS HEARING IS
HOW DO WE COORDINATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OTHER STATE
ENTITIES. THE ANSWER IS WE HAVE
A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PH BETWEEN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY AND JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO THE FRST. TWELVE
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS AS
A GROUP SPENT TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY HOURS ON THE PHONE C.
P. H. WE HAVE REGULAR WEEKLY
CHECK INS WITH THEIR
LEADERSHIP. AND MULTIPLE TIMES
A WEEK CDPH HOST OFFICE HOURS
FOCUSED ON SPECIFIC TOPICS SUCH
AS VACCINE ADMINISTRATION
TESTING SITES OR MODELING.
TWENTY MERGING THESE ARISE WE
HAVE LATE NIGHT AND WEEKEND
PHONE CALLS AS WELL. WE ALSO
WHEN NECESSARY CAN SPEAK WITH
THE HHS SECRETARY GOVE OPS AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THINGS
DO MOVE QUICKLY AS THE CHAIR
POINTED OUT WE KNOW THE STATE
NEVER WANTS TO SURPRISE US AND
DOES THEIR BEST TO NOTIFY LOCAL
HEALTH LEADERS IN ADVANCE OF
MAJOR NOW. NOT ALWAYS PERFECT
BUT THE RELATIONSHIP IS GOOD.
MY COLLEAGUE MICHELLE GIVENS
WILL DELVE MORE DEEPLY INTO OUR
RESOURCE NEEDS I WILL SIMPLY
GIVE A BRIEF INTRODUCTION. WE
NEED BETTER INSIGHT INTO DATA
AND BETTER DATA SYSTEMS AT THE
STATE LEVEL WE ALSO NEED THE
STATE TO WORK WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY DATA ON
DEMOGRAPHICS AND BAXEEN
INVENTORY IS CORRECT BEFORE IT
IS PUBLISHED. WE NEED MORE
VACCINE. THE STATE IS NOT IN
CONTROL OF THAT IT'S A FEDERAL
ISSUE BUT I MENTION IT BECAUSE%
IT IS FRANKLY ARE MOST
IMPORTANT AND MOST IMMEDIATE
NEED. IN THE LONG RUN FOR
BETTER PREPAREDNESS WE NEED
FLEXIBLE LOCAL STAFF WHO CAN
WORK ON DAY TO DAY NEEDS LIKE
STDS AND TUBERCULOSIS AND THEN
SWITCH TO OUTBREAKS. LIKE
MEASLES OR GOD FORBID ANOTHER
PANDEMIC IF NECESSARY. I WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE MICHELLE GIVEN. THANK
YOU. AND GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHELLE
GIBBONS AND I'M WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS YOU
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE CATHY
BURKE SHE SPOKE ON A
RELATIONSHIP SO I'M GONNA FOCUS
ON THE RESOURCE NEEDS OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. BUILDING ON
WHAT DR ERICA PUNCH SHARED I
WANT TO FIRST START BY
HIGHLIGHTING THE UNDERFUNDING
OF PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
IN OUR STATE WHICH MEANT THAT
LOCALLY WE HAD LIMITED CONTACT
TRACING AND DISEASE
INVESTIGATION WORKFORCE.
LIMITED EPIDEMIOLOGIST OUTDATED
DATA SYSTEMS REDUCE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY CAPACITY AND
A LACK OF UPDATED EQUIPMENT
AMONG OTHER DEFICIT. BECAUSE OF
THIS THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BEEN AND CONTINUE TO STATE OF
RAMPING UP WRAPPING UP CONTACT
TRACING RAMPING UP TESTING.
RAMPING UP OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EDUCATION TO
DIFFERENT SECTORS AND NOW
RAMPING UP VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION. THE RAMP UP
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED THIS
OPENED AT NUMBER OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT STAFF THAT WE
HAD BUT IT ONLY HAPPENED WITH
THE INFUSION OF FEDERAL FUNDS
AND THE SUPPLEMENT OF STATE
RESOURCES. IN ADDITION MANY OF
THE DATA SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SET UP BY THE STATE OR THE
DIRECT REFLECTION OF A LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA SYSTEMS. THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS INVESTED INTO
THESE SYSTEMS DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR CONTACT TRACING
TESTING RESEARCH REQUEST IN
AGAIN NOW BAXEEN
ADMINISTRATION. INSTEAD SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INVESTED EARLIER TO
MAINTAIN AND MODERNIZE THOSE
SYSTEMS. IS INVESTMENTS NEED TO
BE SUSTAINED BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC BOTH TO ADDRESS THE
RESIDUAL CODE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND TO ALSO BOLSTER PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. BEFORE
THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT.
LEE ADDITIONAL TO PASS IS TEN.
AND THERE'S NO FUND STREAM TO
SUSTAIN BEYOND THE PANDEMIC.
OUR CALIFORNIA CANTLEY
COALITION MADE UP OF COUNTY
ASSOCIATIONS ORGANIZED LABOR
AND PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES IS
ASKING FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. THESE
FUNDS COULD SUPPORT THE
RETENTION OF STAFF TO WORK
ACROSS VARIOUS CRITICAL ISSUES
SUCH AS EQUITY. HOME VISITING
STDS AND OTHER COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS. AND AGAIN THE DATA
SYSTEMS THAT WERE STOOD UP
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BRING VALUE
TO OUR STATE. AND OR SIMILAR
INVESTMENTS INTO MODERNIZING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH DATA SYSTEM
SHOULD BE MADE. LASTLY I WANT
TO TURN TO YOU ADD THE VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ROSE TO THE
CHALLENGE OF ADMINISTERING
VACCINES QUICKLY AND THEY'RE
DOING SO WITH EQUITY IN MINE.
WE STILL HAVE LOCAL BACKS AND
VACCINATION SITES PARTNER WITH
PROVIDERS TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S
EQUITY GOAL. AND ALSO CONTINUE
TO EXPLORE MUCH NEW STRATEGIES
TO REACH VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.WITH THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE THIRD PARTY
AGREEMENT AND NOW THE
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO USE MY TURN.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
NEED THE FOLLOWING. INCREASE
VACCINE SUPPLY THE LOCAL
VACCINATION SITES CAN RAMP UP
TO FULL CAPACITY. ACCURATE AND
TRANSPARENT DATA WE CAN'T
GUARANTEE EQUITY WITHOUT
KNOWING HOW MUCH VACCINE IS
BEING ALLOCATED AND
ADMINISTERED BY ALL PARTNERS
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND SEE EASE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
PROVIDERS. AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE STATE IS WORKING TO
CLEAN UP THE DATA IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND PROVIDERS. BUT
WE THINK THAT THERE'S MORE THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE BEFORE
IT ACCURATELY REFLECTS WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND. WE
ALSO NEED TRANSPARENT EQUITABLE
ALLOCATIONS TO BE DONE IN
COORDINATION WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- THE
NATIONALLY AND ONGOING. AND
THEN LASTLY WE NEED- THE
FUNCTIONALITY EXCUSE ME WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO TRANSITION OUR
CURRENT PROVIDER NETWORKS THAT
WERE BUILT- IT LOCALLY INTO THE
THIRD PARTY NETWORK AS WELL.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE FUNCTIONALITY IN MY TURN TO
FOCUS ON VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AND ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT MAY ARISE OUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS PROVIDED TO US IN A TIMELY
MANNER GIVEN THE NEW SYSTEM.
IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGING YEAR
BUT. LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
CONTINUE TO DO ALL THAT THEY
CAN AND TO PROTECT THEIR CA. WE
APPRECIATE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE LOOK FORWARD TO ADDRESSING
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CLINICS.
HEY GOOD MORNING SENATORS I AM
ANTI MARTINEZ PATTERSON THE
VICE PRSIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND ITS
IMPACT ON COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS. CBSA REPRESENTS
FOURTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. PROVIDE PRIMARY
BEHAVIORAL AND ORAL HEALTH CARE
TO SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT'S
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN FIVE I'M
TO GIVE YOU A BETTER SENSE OF
OUR PATIENT POPULATION OF ONE
IN THREE OF THE ALL MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES RECEIVE CARE AT
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER. THREE
FORCE OF OUR PATIENT POPULATION
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THE
MAJORITY ARE UNDER 2100% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY- SO NEEDLESS TO
SAY COVER NINETEEN HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED OUR
PATIENT POPULATION. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC LIKE
MOST PROVIDERS COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS EXPERIENCED MASSIVE
DROPS IN VISITS. BECAUSE WE ARE
DENTAL PROVIDERS WE HAD TO SEE
THE CLOSED TEMPORARY CLOSURE OF
OUR DENTAL SITES. WHICH ARE NOW
RAMPING BACK UP WE HAD TO
FURLOUGH STAFF TEMPORARILY
CLOSED SITES AND WE'VE HAD AN
OVERALL CONSTRUCTION OF STAFF
BECAUSE THEY AYE AYE THERE ARE
BEING INFECTED BY CO THAT THEY
HAD TO QUARANTINE FROM.
EXPOSURE TO COVET AND WE ALSO
HAD TO DEAL WITH CHILDREN AT
HOME FROM THE SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS. IN REGARDS TO CASTING
TREATMENT AS WELL AS VACCINES.
THE WITH TESTING CENTERS. ARE
TESTING BUT NOT NEARLY IN THE
LARGE TESTING EFFORTS THAT WE
HAD ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED- SOME
DID AT THE BEGINNING BUT
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
RESOURCES AND STAFF AND WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THAT STATEWIDE. THE HEALTH
CENTERS THAT ARE DOING NOT
LARGE TOPPING EFFORTS TEND TO
BE THOSE PARTNERING WITH HEIR
COUNTIES AND ARE RECEIVING
SUPPORT FROM THE COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS. ONE OF FLAG THAT
FIVE HEALTH CENTERS ARE
PROVIDING MONOCLONAL ANTIBODY
AND FUSION THERAPY AND MANY
MORE ARE PREPARING TO DO SO.
THIS THERE APPEARS FOR ACUTELY
COVERT POSITIVE PATIENTS. I
MEAN IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE ON TO
BE VACCINATING THEM AT THIS
POINT BUT IT HELPS PREVENT
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL. UP AS TO
VACCINES WE ARE HOPING THE
VACCINES ARE VERY DIFFERENT
STORY THAN TESTING. OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT HEALTH
CENTER SHOULD BE VACCINATING
ALL OF THEIR PATIENTS AT SEVEN
POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE OF
COLOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF
COLOR ACROSS CALIFORNIA. TO
DATE HOWEVER WE HAVE. DONE
THOUSANDS- BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD
ENOUGH VACCINE IN ORDER TO DO
AS MUH AS WE NEED TO. I'M AS
DR PINE NOTED THE BITE IN HERE
SAID MINISTRATION HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THE PIVOTAL IN
CRITICAL ROLE OF FQHCS. AND
IT'S STARTING TO DISTRIBUTE
VACCINES AS NOTED TO FIVE NEXT
WEEK AND WE'RE HOPING TO SEE
ALL OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS
WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH OR TO.
HAVE ACCESS TO DIRECTION MEANT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE PLAN IS TO GET A MILLION
VACCINES AFTER WHICH IS A WEEK
WITH THE GOAL OF ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS DOSES NATIONWIDE BUT
ONE WITH KNOWLEDGE. OUR PATIENT
POPULATION AND SEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION SO WE'RE GONNA NEED
UPWARDS OF AROUND FOURTEEN
MILLION DOSES JUST IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. AND WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN AS IT NOTES A 100%
F. MAP FOR MEDICAID VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH WE REALLY
HOPE DHS TAKES FULL ADVANTAGE
UP. TO ACCURATE SEES CAN
RECEIVE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO DO. LARGER VACCINE EFFORTS
AND QUICKER VACCINE EFFORTS. WE
ARE IN OUR- IN RELATION TO
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION WE ARE IN
CONVERSATION WITH BLUE SHIELD
THE T. PA- BUT WE HAVE YET TO
DETERMINE THE EXACT ROLE FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN REGARDS TO HOW
THE PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED
PRIMARY CARE I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AN UNDERSCORE
TELEHEALTH- I CAN'T SAY THIS
WITHOUT FIRST COMMENDING AND
THANKING DH CS ONCE AGAIN
SPECIFICALLY J. C. COOPER. WHO
HELPED US IMMEDIATELY RECEIVE
THE FLEXIBILITY AND THE
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE BOTH
TELEHEALTH. TELEPHONIC AND
VIRTUAL CARE- WHICH WAS
INSTRUMENTAL TO KEEPING THE
HEALTH CENTERS STRONG AND
FEELING DURING THE- BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC. AT THE
BEGINNING HEALTH CENTER FOR
PROVIDING ABOUT 80% OF VISITS
TELEPHONICALLY- AND NOW IT'S
ABOUT 50% QUITE SIMPLY PATIENTS
LOVE IT PROVIDERS LOVE IT- AND
WE NEED TO ENSURE. THAT E ARE
PAYING FOR PARITY THE
TELEPHONIC AND TELE TELE-
VIRTUAL CARE ALL ARE BOTH BEING
PAID THE SAME- SO THAT WE DON'T
CREATE A TWO TIERED SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
HELLO I'M HOPING YOU CAN ALL
HEAR ME WE CAN. WONDERFUL HELLO
MY NAME IS IAN WALTERS AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF CLINICAL
AFFAIRS AND QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES AND WE'RE
A TRADE ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTED THEIR TEAM HUNDRED
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
INTERMEDIATE CARE- DEVELOPING
ABOUT DEVELOPMENT THE FABLED
CENTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. SO
HOW WE HEARD MANY OF THE SAME-
CONCERNS AND ISSUES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
WAS DESCRIBED WITH FROM BEING
ON CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ARE MANY CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE FACING THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES I WE DIDN'T
SEE ANY- A DELAY AND-
PREPARATION TO IF THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY TO THE
RESPONSE OF SO MUCH ATTENTION
WAS PUT TOWARD THE HOSPITAL IN
ORDER TO PREPARE THEM FOR- YOU
KNOW THE SURGE THAT WAS
EXPECTED TO OCCUR- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE IN A REGULAR QUESTION
WAS YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AFFECTED
AND- AND HONESTLY THE- THE X.
FACTOR BAND. THE COMPLETE
CHANGES ALL OF OPERATIONS
WITHIN THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY OF FROM THE- BAN ON
VISITORS TO THE REQUIREMENT FOR
EXTENSIVE PP THAT HAS NEVER
BEEN REQUIRED BEFORE INFILL
NURSING. AND ALSO IN JUST THREE
WEEKS STAFF AND THE WAY WE
PREPARE AND PROVIDE CARE FOR
ALL OF OUR OUR FACILITY RATHER
THAN. SO IT IS REALLY JUST-
CHANGE EVERYTHING THAT WE
USUALLY DO AND TRYING TO
PROVIDE A HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENT
FOR OUR RESIDENTS I'M SO IT'S
BEEN TRULY A COMPLETE
TURNAROUND FOR I'M OUR
RESIDENTS AND OUR STAFF. AND
YOU KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WAS HOW HAVE WE
PROTECT IT RESIDENTS STAFF AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW EVERYBODY
KNOWS THE BEGINNING A PANDEMIC
WITH SUCH A LACK OF PVD AND
ALSO YOU KNOW NOT MUCH
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE VIRUS
IS. AIRBORNE AND AFFECTS PEOPLE
AND SO IF THE BEGINNING THINGS
ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
TO ALL STAFF NEEDED IT. THANK
GOODNESS THAT THOSE- LINES OUR
RESOURCES WERE. INCREASED AND
ADDS AND WE YOU REACH THE SURGE
OVER THE SUMMER WE GOT HAD MORE
AT. TO PP BAG EVEN WE SEE HAVE
A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS. THAT ARE
USING. USE OF THEIR PP BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T AND- TO RETURN A
FEW ORMAL. OF THE STILL
STRUGGLE IN. A HIGH ENOUGH OF.
AN OBVIOUS THE FINANCING IS
GOING A LONG WAY TRYING USE THE
THOSE AMOUNTS PLAN. I'M NOT
ONLY KEEPING YOU SAID THINK
SOME BY THE ACTUAL OF THE PD
ISN'T THE HIGH FOLD. AND SO
THAT HAS CREATED QUITE THE CHIU.
I'M VERY THOUGH THE PART OF
PROTECTING AND READ IS THAT ON
MOST OUR- PARK. AND HE ARE
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP TO BRING A
VACCINE YOU NURSING HOMES AND
I'M SO GREAT NUMBERS OUT THERE-
ALL OF THE FACILITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAS THEN HAD THEIR
FIRST VISIT- FIRE. A FEW YEARS
OR WALGREENS I'M L. A. COUNTY
IS SEPARATE AND I WENT A
DIFFERENT ROUTE- BUT- 95% OF
THE SLAVES OF ALREADY RECEIVED
THEIR- SECOND VISIT BY HE ASKED
AND WE'RE ABOUT 61% AND SECOND
THERE'S IT'S BY WALGREENS SO.
AT THIS POINT TIME A HUGE
NUMBER OF OUR RESIDENTS HAVE
BOTH OF THE VACCINATIONS ARE
COMPLETE AND SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. IT'S REALLY
REFLECTING ON THE NUMBER OF I'M
CURRENT CASES- YOU KNOW I JUST.
HORRENDOUSLY YOU KNOW ARE AT
THE HIGH STREET OVER THE
HOLIDAYS YOU KNOW WE WERE
SEEING SOME SEVEN HUNDRED
PIECES AND THEY- ARE NOW WHERE
AN AVERAGE OF SEVEN DAYS ABOUT
I THINK ITSELF SEVENTY ONE. AND
SO WE'VE REALLY SEEN SOME
REMARKABLE CHANGES ON THANK
GOODNESS THE COMMUNITY SEARCHES
DECREASED THAT ALONG WITH THE
VACCINATION PROGRAM HAS REALLY
MADE A HUGE IMPACT. OUR FOR OUR
RESIDENTS. AS WELL AS FAR STAFF.
AND THE AND THAT WAS PART OF
THE OTHER QUESTIONS BACKING.
PROGRESS WE'RE WE'RE CONTINUING
WITH FOR YOU KNOW. I'M A GOOD
DOWN AS WELL- OVER THAT. 5% OF
THE BILL IN L. A. COUNTY- SO
THEY'RE NOT IN THE- HAS ALSO.
COMPLETED THEIR FIRST ROUND
BACK. AND OUR SO WE CAN TO MOVE
FOR WITH- AS WE PREPARE FOR
THAT. DAYS THAT. I CAN TO BE.
THAT ARE STAFF FAX NATION'S
WELL. SO AT THIS POINT TIME I
BELIEVE THAT YOU WE'RE SEEING
OVER A PERCENT. OF OUR
RESIDENTS THAT ARE ACCEPTING
THE VACCINE SO THAT HAS BEEN
EIGHTY WONDERFUL ON RESPONSE ON
THE FACILITIES I WORK
DILIGENTLY TO GET. FROM CONSENT
FROM FAMILY AND OTHER PERSONS
FOR THOSE RESIDENTS SAID I
CANNOT SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES SO.
THEY HAVE HOW THOSE IN PLACE IN
OUR SEEN ON THAT HUGE NUMBER.
AND SO- THINGS CONTINUE MOVE
FORWARD AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO. SEE THAT
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE DROP AND
THEREFORE BEING ABLE TO AGAIN
BRING BACK OUR FAMILIES SO THAT
THEY CAN VISIT OUR RESIDENTS
AND A MUCH MORE PERSONAL WAY IS
AND WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
RIGHT NOW. HELLO AS FOR THINGS
FOR OUR SKILLED NURSING- SECTOR
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AND TO.
PUT FORWARD OUT FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER ENDING A FULLY FUNDING
OF YOU KNOW OUR COSTS OF LABOR
OUTSIDE THAT THE MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM IN ORDER
FOR US TO REALLY BRING THOSE WE
JUST DO OUR WORK BIRTH. I'M AT
THE FOREFRONT INSTEAD OF YOU
KNOW TWO YEARS IN ARREARS SO
THAT'S THE ONE I THINK THAT
WE'RE HOPING TO WORK WITH
EVERYONE ON AND ON OBVIOUSLY
THE BIG THING IS WAITING FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY- FROM ALL
LEVELS YOU TO BRING YOUR
FAMILY. BACK TO THE VISITING ON.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND THE- YES GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBER I AM SURE AND
SEVEN SOMEONE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK RECEIVED PAN WHERE IS
STATE WIDE MULTI CULTURAL
HEALTH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO THE BELIEF THAT BY
UNITING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND BRINGING CONSUMER VOICE TO
THE TABLE WE CAN ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY. OKAY NINETEEN IS A
CRISIS WITHIN A CRISIS. NO
CORNER OF THE STATE HAS BEEN
LEFT UNTOUCHED BUT THE IMPACT
HAS BEEN FAR FROM EQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED. GENERATIONS OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM CREATE
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN COMPOUNDED BY THE
PANDEMIC. RESULTING IN
DEVASTATION IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SIMPLY
PUT COBIT NINETEEN IS A
PANDEMIC WITHIN THE ON GOING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT IS
RACISM. PEOPLE OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK LATINO
NATIVE AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER PEOPLE ARE LEAST
LIKELY TO HAVE A USUAL SOURCE
OF HEALTHCARE MOST LIKELY TO
LIVE WITH CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS SUCH AS HEART
DISEASE DIABETES AND ASTHMA.
AND FREQUENTLY REPORT
DISCRIMINATORY TREATMENT WITHIN
HEALTH CARE SETTINGS. ARE THERE
MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE MOST
LIKELY TO LIVE IN HISTORICALLY
REDLINED NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH
TODAY ARE PLAGUED BY ADVERSE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS INCLUDING
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXINS. FOOD
DESERT'S AND GUN VIOLENCE. IT
IS AGAINST THIS BACKDROP THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND NOW
INJURING THE MOST DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF COBIT NINETEEN THE
HIGHEST RATES OF COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION THE LARGEST NUMBER
OF DEATHS AND THE GREATEST
LOSSES OF JOBS AND- ENTIRE
FAMILY. BEEN LOST TO THE VIRUS.
YET WE CONTINUE TO WITNESS
GRAVE INEQUITIES IN ACCESS TO
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
FINANCIAL RELIEF AND THE
CORPORATE NINETEEN VACCINE. WE
APPLAUD THE ACTIONS THAT THE
STATE HAS TAKEN TO FOCUS
RESOURCES ON NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY
ADVERSE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS.
THE BLUEPRINT FOR SAFER ECONOMY
INCLUDE TO HEALTH EQUITY
METRICS THAT INSTITUTIONALIZE
IS THE PRINCIPLE THAT WE ARE
ALL STRONGER OR WE ARE ALL
HEALTHIER WHEN WE LEAVE NO ONE
BEHIND. THE STATE HAS REQUIRED
COUNTIES TO INVEST A
MEASUREABLE PORTION OF THEIR
COPING NINETEEN REALLY FUNDS IN
THE COMMUNITIES HARDEST HIT BY
THE PANDEMIC. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE HOWEVER THAT THE HEALTH
EQUITY METRIC IS IN PERFECT
OVERLOOKING SMALL POPULATIONS
THAT ARE AMONG THE MOST BURDENS
SUCH AS THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY CONSIDER RACE OR
LANGUAGE. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
EVEN DEDICATING A PORTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RESOURCES FOR
EQUITY IS INADEQUATE WHEN
PUBLIC HEALTH IS AS MASSIVELY
UNDERFUNDED AS IT IS TODAY. WE
DO QUESTION THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF THE RELIANCE ON LARGE
TECHNOLOGY AND HEALTH INDUSTRY
COMPANIES IN THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE WHO WILL BE HERE TODAY
AND GONE TOMORROW MISSING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECTOR STATE
RESOURCES TO BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
DISRUPT THE ROOT CAUSES OF
INEQUITY. WE HEARD TODAY ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES RELATED TO LACK
OF IT INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT EFFECTIVELY
REACH OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THIS IS WHERE WE
SHOULD BE MAKING OUR
INVESTMENTS. WE RECOMMEND FOR
ACTION STEPS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO STEM THE DAMAGE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND BEGAN TO
BUILD A MORE EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA. FIRST DECLARE THAT
RACISM IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND COMMIT RESOURCES TO
IMPACT LONG. STANDING
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES. I CAN'T
EXPAND WORKER PER. INCLUDING
HATE SICKLY. THIRD ENSURE THAT
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION REACHES
THE MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
FIRST. AND FOURTH. REIMAGINE
OUR HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE AS TOOLS
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH AND EQUITY
BY INVESTING IN COMMUNITY. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OR
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE QUESTION
AND ANSWER PORTION. AND I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE BY EXPRESSING OUR
DEEP GRATITUDE AND SUPPORT FOR
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS. FOR THEIR HEROIC
WORK OVER THE PAST YEAR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
FRIENDS IN LABOR. THE MORNING
MORNING. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILLIAM
RAMIREZ AND I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH
MICROBIOLOGY SUPERVISOR UNDER
THE BUREAU OF MEDICAL DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION AT THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND- APPROX
ME TWO YEARS AGO DURING A
SENATE CONFIRMATION HEARING ON
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES I
TESTIFIED IN THE SIMILAR
APPEALS TO BARKER PASSING AND
OTHER SENATE THIS IS SUPPORT
OUR CORE CENTRAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN OUR
WORKFORCE. AND THAT WAS ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO. PASSPORTING TWO
YEARS SINCE THEN AND AFTER THIS
BEEN DONE BEFORE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SPEND THAT MUCH WE'RE
SEEING THAT BARBARA COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE BEEN.
SEVERELY RAVAGED BY THE SPEND
THAT MUCH. THROUGH A MORE
DEVASTATING LEVELS THAT.
OTHERWISE. HAVE WE HAD A MORE
ROBUST. LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH-
DEPARTMENT INITIATIVE AND ALSO
A REMORSE OFFICIALLY STOPPED IN
RESPONSE. SO- EARLIER A DOCTOR
AT THE STATE ILLUSTRATED VERY
ELOQUENTLY POLICIES AND FINDING
OUT THAT HAVE TO DO WITH. OUR
RESPONSIVE IS THE SPEND THAT
MAKE AND OTHER THINGS RELATED.
BUT A LOT OF THE A LOT OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THIS PANEL WAS WAS. AS FOR ME.
THIRTY THOUSAND- AFFORDHIGH
VIEW AND WHAT I'M HERE TO DO
TODAY IS TO GIVE YOU GUYS SOME
OF SOME EXAMPLES SOME OF AND TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE THAT THAT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AT THE
GROUND LEVEL TO ILLUSTRATE THE
NEED FOR INCREASED CAPACITY AND
INCREASED. SOLUTIONS ARE BETTER
SERVE OUR COMMUNITY DURING THE
SPEND AN EXAM OTHER- OTHER LIKE
THREATS. SO ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I WAS ASKED TO
ANSWER WAS. TO DESCRIBE THE
IMPACT THAT THE- COMMON
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS. SO I AM
A SUPERVISOR MY JOB IS TO
ENSURE THAT I UTILIZED THE
RESPECT FORCES PROPERLY SO THAT
I CAN CONDUCT WORK THAT IS
RELEVANT TO KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. I HAPPEN TO BE
PART OF THE UNITA SMALL UNIT
WITHIN L. A. COUNTY THAT IS
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW CASTLE.
AND WE ALSO WORK WITH- THE CDC
TO TEND TO- POTENTIAL OUTBREAKS
ONE SPECIFICALLY IS. THAT OF
CARBAPENEM RESISTANCE. OUR SO
THE RESISTANCE TO THESE OUR
ANTIBIOTICS HAS TO DO WITH LAST
MINUTE TYPE ANTIBIOTICS WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASE OF THAT IN
OUR CLIENTELE AND ACTUALLY MORE
US REALLY DEVASTATED.
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES AND NURSING
SKILLS BUILT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. WE'VE ALSO SEEN A
HUGE INCREASE IN THE EMERGENCE
OF CANADA OR AS WHICH IS A- AND
CHECK BOND GOLD RESISTANT EAST.
THIS ORGANISM HASN'T BEEN
SMOKING IN THE UNITED STATES UP
UNTIL. ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO WHAT WE'RE KEEPING TRACK OF
IT. AND AS A RESULT OF THE
REDIRECTION OF FUNDING AND
RESOURCES WE'RE SEEING A HUGE
FIVE SPECIAL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BATES OF THIS. OF
THIS BEAST. OUR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAPPENS TO BE- ONE OF
THE FEW SITES THAT CAN PASS
SOME CAPACITY FOR TESTING OF
THE C. R. E. INTERBODY
RESISTANT ORGANISMS. HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF FINDING IT
BECAUSE OF THE DIRECTION OF
FINES AND STAFFING- WE HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD A DOWN ON OUR
TESTING TOOL ABOUT 10% WILL BE
USED TO TEST ONE A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AND I JUST THAT WE'VE HAD
TO CUT DOWN ON OUR STAFFING AS
WELL DOWN TO ONE PERSON AND
THEN THAT ONE PERSON WE CAN
ONLY UTILIZE FOR ABOUT HALF THE
TIME. THAT'S IT THAT'S ALL YEAH
AND I THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO
EXPECT AND THAT BECAUSE OF
THESE ACTIVITIES AND BECAUSE OF
REDIRECTS ARE AND ALSO BECAUSE
OF BY- LACK OF SUPPORTING THE
BE ALL AGES THESE THINGS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE GETTING. MORE
AND MORE DEVASTATING BUT THE
MARKET NEEDS. ANOTHER QUESTION
I WAS ASKED TO ASK WHERE'S
OCKENFELS. AND LOCAL RESOURCES
BE BETTER DIRECTED TO SUPPORT.
MY WORK OUR WORK. I THINK WE'VE
ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS AND
I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
RECORDING THANK YOU. THAT HAS
TO DO WITH STAFFING. WE NEED
MORE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE WORK. WE NEED EQUIPMENT TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS FOR. AND AT
THE GROUND LEVEL THE WAY THAT I
WAS WITH ACTION A BABY BASIS.
WITH MY COLLEAGUES. IT'S NOT
ENOUGH JUST HAVE STAFFING AND
SUBSEQUENTLY. WE NEED A CHEST
X. ROOMS STORAGE WILL NEED
REFRIGERATORS AND FREEZERS THAT
KIND OF STUFF. BUT I WAS SAYING
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND IN MY UNIT.
AND DOT WE HAD SOME CAPACITY AT
SOME POINT WE STILL HAVE
MINIMAL CAPACITY THAT'S- WHAT.
WITHIN A LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
SETTING. WE CAN ADOPT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE VERY EASILY
AND IF NOT WE CAN HAVE UR OWN
HOME GROWN TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE
CAN IMPLEMENT AND EVEN SHARE
WITHIN OUR- WITHIN WITH WITH
OUR PARTNER. THAT'S IT OR OTHER
LOCAL. ACCOUNT BUT. BUT THIS
REQUIRES OBVIOUSLY TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE REQUIRES SIGNED. IT
REQUIRES DOCTOR REQUIRES A
FUNDING FOR NEW EQUIPMENT FOR
NEW TESTING TECHNOLOGIES. ONE
OF THE MORE DEVASTATING THINGS
CURRENTLY THAT CAN POTENTIALLY
HARM AS WELL- DOWN THE LINE
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD TEST. AND I THINK
DOCTOR POUND REPORTING OF
COURSE HI FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TESTS PER DAY. RELATED TO COVER.
THAT'S GREAT. HOWEVER WE NEED
TO STAY ON TRACK AND ON TOP OF
WHAT'S ACTUALLY CIRCULATING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE ONLY WAY
TO DOTHAT ONE OF THE BEST WAYS
TO THAT WILL BE TO CONDUCT A
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCE IS NOT
THE STATE HAS A GREAT CAPACITY.
WILL. BUT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ALONE IN THIS EFFORT. AT THE
LOCAL PUBLIC OUT THE RECORD WE
HAVE SOME CAPABILITIES THAT
WILL COME AND GO. HOWEVER THE
WAY WE'RE DOING IT. WE'RE DOING
IT- HOW TO BEHIND THE SCENES
THAT TIME. WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING FOR THE- CONSOLE
UNFORTUNATELY THE PERSON WHO'S
CONDUCTING SOME OF THE ANALYSIS
OF THIS DATA S. NEW FROM HOME.
WITH THEIR HOME EQUIPMENT. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER PEOPLE
THAN THE NEW YORK FROM SOME OF
THE LAST ELSEWHERE. WELL THAT'S
THROUGH DEDICATION. BUT I DON'T
THINK IT'S ENOUGH TO HAVE A
PROPER RESPONSE TO THESE THINGS
AND NOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
WILL BE TO KEEP TRACK OF THE
PARENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE. IN
ALSO SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND. WHAT
IS CIRCULATING OUT THERE.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
LED ME THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
CASES FOUND. IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OF THE SOUTH
AFRICAN RAND THE PUBLIC. WHICH
CAN EVENTUALLY EVEN WITH A
SMALL TWEAK. RENDER THE ENTIRE
BAG SLUNG OVER THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF BACKS IT'LL
DISTRIBUTION USED. NOW THAT'S A
REALITY. SO BEST OF THE BEST
MONEY ASSOCIATED WITH- BOB.
WHAT THE SERVICE CAN BE PUT TO
PROPER STAFFING REQUIREMENTS
AND PROPER- RETENTION OF THE
STOCK. WARS WITH- JIM STEVENSON
REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF COMPUTING POWER WHICH FALLS
REQUIRES I TEASE. ANOTHER
QUESTION I WAS ASKED TO ANSWER
WAS THAT WHAT IS THE MOST
CRITICAL WHAT IS ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE
PANDEMIC PREPARE FOR FUTURE.
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES. I
HAVE TO JUST REITERATE STAFFING.
THE RIGHTS THAT. FOR MORE SO
BECAUSE WE HAVE SPAWNING BAD
WITHIN OUR PROGRAMS WE DO GET
SOME FEDERAL FUNDS AT TIMES AND
THEN PASSED AS A MATTER OF FACT
THE PROGRAM S MAINLY FUNDED
THROUGH FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
RIGIDITY. ASSOCIATED WITH. BUT
EVEN THOUGH WE MAY HAVE SOME
MONEY ASSOCIATED WITH SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS. WE CAN USE IT FOR
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THIS
SPECIFIC ORGANISM FOR THAT
SPECIFIC PROGRAM. SO WE CANNOT
REDIRECT ANY OF THAT MONEY TO
ANY OTHER EFFORTS WE CAN
RESPOND TO THAT THANKS BYE. ONE
OF THE CURRENT OUTBREAKS OF
STDS IN IN OUR COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING. WITHIN OUR-
POPULATION OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE
BEST WE CAN BETTER- JOHN TO
STV'S ACCORDING TO BODY
RESISTANT GONORRHEA CHLAMYDIA
HIV NEEDS SICKENING IN THE
CURRENT- ON OUTBREAKS OF TYPHUS
SKATES. I WANT THANK YOU GUYS
FOR YOUR TIME AND I WANT TO
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT. OUR STATE
CANNOT WAIT. UNTIL THE NEXT.
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IT'S-
INSTEAD WE ARE. WE HAVE THE
BEST CELL OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND OUR
WORKFORCE SO FOR THESE REASONS
AT THE VERY LEAST WE'RE ASKING
FORCED ONGOING STATE SUPPORT IN
FINDING OUR POOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AUGUST ALSO
EXPANDING OUR WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT DOES SO
CERTAINLY A CONSISTENT THEME-
THROUGHOUT ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS WAS THE NEED FOR
MORE FLEXIBILITY AND MORE
RESOURCES- AND I CERTAINLY HEAR
YOU AND I KNOW DOCTOR PANDITS
HE IS LOOKING HAS LONG BEEN. AN
ADVOCATE FOR MORE RESOURCES- IF
I CAN JUST ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
IN MIND I KNOW DR PANDA'S IS
READY TO GO. IT IN IN IN IN
DISTRIBUTING IT THROUGH THE
CLINICS ARE YOU FINDING VACCINE
HESITANCY IN THE END IN YOUR
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH. BUT DEFINITELY FINDING
VACCINE HESITANCY- THAT WAS THE
FOCUS THE BOLUS OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS FOCUS ON THAT IN
THE FALL- BUT I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. WITH THE
DEARTH OF VACCINES RIGHT NOW
IT'S ALL ABOUT TRYING TO GET
MORE OF THEM SO THERE'S A
HIGHER DEMAND AT THIS POINT BUT
WE WERE SEEING FOR HEALTH
CENTERS THAT FIRST STARTED TO
DO VACCINE EFFORTS. THAT THE-
THE NO SHOW RATE WAS AROUND A
THIRD SOME OF THE HEALTH
CENTERS ON WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS
PROBABLY RELATED TO THE VACCINE
HESITANCY- DEFINITELY- WE ALSO
VACCINE HESITANCY AMONG OUR
PROVIDERS. SO THAT WAS- THAT'S
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO COMBAT NOW WITH MORE
CONVERSATION MORE EDUCATION
BECAUSE OUR PROVIDERS ARE-
FEELING WARY AND THEN THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO THEN CONVINCE
THEIR OWN PATIENTS IF THEY WERE
WARY TO TAKE THE VACCINES OR
WORKING ON THAT- SO THAT WE-
ALL FEEL CONFIDENT IN DOING SO
IT'S DEFINITELY AN ISSUE- RIGHT
NOW IT'S NOT THE CENTRAL NEXUS
OF OUR CONVERSATION BUT WE KNOW
AS WE GET FURTHER AND WE GET
MORE AND MORE VACCINES. THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HARDER AND
HARDER TIME GETTING TO. THE
MOST VULNERABLE SO WE ARE
WORKING ON IT DAILY IN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES. AND ENTER
TO ALL OF YOU HOW ABOUT THE
VACCINE HESITANCY WITHIN YOUR
YOUR WORKFORCE. LET'S START
WITH THE HELP OFFICERS. JUST
JUST LIKE OUR PARTNERS AT THE
CLINIC SAID WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE IS A VACCINE HESITANCY
WITHIN VARIOUS WORK FORCES
WITHIN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES- BUT
AT THIS POINT WE ARE SO FOCUSED
ON ADMINISTRATION- WE DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE THOSE COMMUNITIES
BEHIND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE OF
THAT. OUR TRUSTED PROVIDERS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHICH
INCLUDES THE CLINICS INCLUDES
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS MAINTAIN THE WORK
THAT THE VALUABLE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING TO COMMUNICATE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE AND THE
SAFETY OF YOUTH. OKAY HOSPITALS.
WE SAW OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE
HOSPITALS WE SAW INITIAL WORK
FORCE HASN'T SEEN UNTIL THE
SECOND DOES HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED- I THINK WE WERE
SENT ABOUT 30% HASN'T SEEN I
THINK THAT'S DROPPED NOW QUITE
SIGNIFICANTLY AS WE GET TO THAT
SECOND DOSE- I DON'T KNOW HOW
DO WE HAVE UPDATED FIGURES BUT
IT'S STILL AN ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO WORK ON. OKAY AND THEN.
THE TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS. IT AND ALL OF YOU IT
SOUNDS LIKE THIS LIKE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT
EMERGENCY MONEY WITHOUT A LOT
OF STRINGS ATTACHED. YOU'RE
ASKING FOR MORE RESOURCES THAT
YOU CAN THAT YOU CAN
SPECIFICALLY TARGET. IN YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND OF THE
SON YOU GAVE US TWO HUNDRED
MILLION WAS THE ASK. YES AND
MICHELLE GIVENS GI I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT QUESTION SO THAT IS
TO NOT JUST HAVE KIND OF THE
RESPONSE- RESOURCES FOR
RESPONSE. I THINK EVERYBODY YOU
KNOW BARELY SELL ARE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE PANDEMIC AND
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO FOCUS ON WHAT LED
US TO THIS POINT. AND ALL OF
THE CONTINUE IS RAMPING UP IS
THAT BECAUSE WE LACK THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEEDED.
SO THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND THAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS REALLY TO HELP
REINVESTMENT OF THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PUBLIC TO GET IN
BAD STAFF THAT CAN WORK ACROSS
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS- THAT
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE STAFF. MET MET I THINK
ANOTHER REAL POSSIBILITY IS
THAT WE'VE EXPANDED OUR STAFF
TO BE MUCH LARGER THAN IT WAS
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS KIND OF
DOUBLING THE SIZE OF THEIR
DEPARTMENTS OR EVEN MORE. AND
IT WOULD BE A SHAME THAT AFTER
THOSE FUNDS THE FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE ARE GONE FOR US TO LOSE
THOSE FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH US FOR THAT PAST
YEAR. SO WOULD REALLY BE A WAY
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD
AND REBUILD OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WHILE ALSO
LEVERAGING- THE STAFF THAT HAVE
COME OUR WAY. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU THIRTY PM.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR A
FIRST OF ALL I DO WANT TO THANK
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS AND-
APPRECIATE PRESENTATION FROM-
SILVA FROM SEIU BUT ALSO OUR
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS WHO NOT
ONLY OF COURSE HAVE BEEN
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK TO TRY
TO STOP THIS PANDEMIC BUT
UNFORTUNATELY LOS HAVE BEEN
TARGETED BY SOME PEOPLE AND
WE'VE SEEN ATTACKS ON OUR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AND
WORKERS AND SO FORTH. AND DO
WANTED JUST RECOGNIZE THAT AND
WE SEEN FORTUNATELY SEVERAL OF
THEM AND UP RESIGNING OR
RETIRING OR LEAVING BECAUSE OF
THAT AND- AND- CERTAINLY THAT
HAS NOT HELPED- RESPONSE WINDOW
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO- ENGAGING
THREATS AND VIOLENCE AND- GOING
TO PEOPLE'S HOMES AND- SO
FORTH. AND SO I GOT IT BY
RECOGNIZE THE COURAGE AND- OF
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS TO
CONTINUE DO THE WORK- I KNOW
THAT SOME OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS WE TALKED I CONTACT
TRACY. SOMETIMES THE KIND
RESPONSES THEY GET WHEN THEY
TRY TO REACH OUT TO STOP THE
PANDEMIC ARE. THIS VOTE LESS
THAN KIND IS PROBABLY AN
UNDERSTATEMENT AND- AND I HOPE
THAT WE IS- THE STATE- WILL
WILL WILL READ WILL RECOGNIZE
AND- AND SUPPORTER PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS AND OF LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AS THEY
DO THEIR- WORK TO HELP PROTECT
ALL OF US- I GUESS. THE AND I
PRE APPRECIATE THAT YEP WE DO
NEED TO BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AS AS AS
PRESENTED- IT IN TERMS OF-
SERVE OUR ON GOING RESPONSE-
YOU KNOW I THINK THE- WHAT WHAT
DO YOU THINK I MEAN AND IN
TERMS OF- LIKE IT WE GET ASKED
BEFORE BUT PERHAPS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PANEL- YOU. YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY COVET IS THERE THE
BIG THING IN FRONT OF US BUT I
ALSO WOULD POINT OUT THAT AS
THEY DID IN THE PREVIOUS
HEARING THAT. THAT WE ALWAYS
HAVE AN OUTBREAK OF SOMETHING
GOING ON EVERY YEAR IS NOT MORE
THAN ONE THING. AND SO THIS
SHOULD IS- IT MAYBE NOT THE
SCALE OF CERTAINLY NOT THE
SKILL OF CODE WHICH IS FIVE ONE
DEL SERVE THEM ONCE IN A
CENTURY KIND OF THING WE HOPE
IT STAYS ONCE IN A CENTURY-
BUT- BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT EVEN
WE HAD SMALLER OUTBREAKS LIKE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAD A-
LOT OF MEASLES. IT SEEMS LIKE
FOREVER BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
STAFF GOT PULLED AWAY FROM
DOING ON GOING PUBLIC HEALTH
WORK TO CONFRONT MEASLES
OUTBREAKS WE HAD HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- SO
THIS SEEMS TO BE A REPETITIVE
CYCLE. HE RECENTLY GET UP
PERHAPS- LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
AND- AND ALSO PARTICULARLY- ARE
AT- REPRESENT FROM S. YEAH YOU
CAN SPEAK TO- YOU KNOW SIR
THAT.WHAT HAPPENS EVERY TIME
WE HAVE AN OUTBREAK NOT JUST
COVERT EVEN OTHER ONES AND IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THE ON GOING WORK THINGS LIKE
CHRONIC DISEASE ARE. NOW WE TRY
TO DEAL WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AND TOXINS AND SO FORTH
IT'S ERA. AND AND THE NEED TO
BE SURELY- SUSTAIN THOSE AND OF
COURSE ALSO FROM- HEALTH
DEPARTMENT FOLKS SELF. CAN YOU
CAN YOU PERHAPS SPEAK TO THAT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE. HI THIS
IS MICHELLE AGAIN I'M HAPPY TO
START YES IT'S REASONABLE THAT-
AND BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
THE LACK OF RESOURCES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAD THAT
MANY OF OUR STAFF WERE
REDIRECTED TO REALLY FOCUS ON
COLVIN AND I'VE HEARD THIS
REFERENCE MORE THAN ONCE FROM
OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ABOUT
HOW WE'VE REALLY FORMED CULVER
DEPARTMENTS OVER THIS PAST YEAR
AND THAT THERE ARE OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE
STRIVING TO CONTINUE TO DO BUT
OURS- POTENTIALLY SUFFERING A
LITTLE BIT DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND I'LL GIVE YOU EXAMPLES OF
WHY. IN SOME JURISDICTIONS THEY
ONLY HAD MAYBE ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE THAT MAYBE WORK ON
HOME VISITING ORDER ADD
INTEREST IN PROGRAMS AT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND THAT
ONE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES VITAL
TO THE BARE SPOTS IN THE
PANDEMIC AND SO THEY THEY'VE
HAD TO BE RE DIRECTED UP PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC I KNOW STD
RATES WAS CONTINUING TO BE A
CHALLENGE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND EVEN THEN OUT WE DID NOT
HAVE ENOUGH CAMILLE DISEASE
INVESTIGATORS AND CONTACT
TRACERS TO REALLY REACH
EVERYONE. AND SO WHAT THEY WERE
HAVING TO DO IS PRIORITIZE BY
DISEASE BURDEN AND THAT AND IN
TERMS OF INVESTIGATING AND
GOING FORWARD THE NOW THOSE
SAME INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON STDS ARE NOW
BEING RE DIRECTED TOWARDS THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL AND I THINK
THERE'S A HOST OF A NUMBER OF
OTHER EXAMPLES WHERE WE ARE
HAVING TO PULL OUR STAFF AND RE
DIRECT THEM TOWARDS THE FOCUS
OF THE PANDEMIC AND TO THE
EXTENT AND THE ONE THING I
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT. IN IN
OUR DEPARTMENTS THERE IS ALSO A
LEVEL OF CATEGORICAL FUNDING
WHICH I THINK YOU'VE HEARD THE
SPEAKER FROM S. YEAH YOU STATE
AND SO THERE ARE LIMITATIONS TO
HOW WE CAN MOVE OUR STAFF
AROUND AS WELL AND SO I THINK
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE HAD TO
MADE IT IS DO YOU DO YOU LOSE
THE FUNDING AND THE FEDERAL
SOURCE OF FUNDING BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO RE DIRECT THE PERSON OR
DO YOU TRY TO MAINTAIN THAT
PERSON AND THEN ARE YOU AND-
KIND OF LOSING. A RESOURCE THAT
CAN BE RE DIRECTED TOWARDS THE
PANDEMIC SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE TOUGH DECISIONS. THAT OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
HAD TO FACE. MISTER MAYOR. YES
HELLO SOME TRICKY THIS YEAR YES
WE CAN OKAY SO I WAS DOWN AT
THE LABORATORY AS A MATTER OF
FACT I WAS PART OF THE PART OF
A TEAM THAT WAS ASSOCIATED WITH
A TESTING FR MEASLES DURING
THE MARKET AS WELL AS THE- THAT
OUTBREAK WE HAD IN THAT THEME
PARK. IN THE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
ALSO DURING DURING DURING THAT
TIME. UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD TO
BE SENDING MOST OF OUR TESTING
ACTUALLY ALL OF OUR TESTING TO
THE STATE LABORATORY WHICH IS
GREAT BECAUSE WE'RE- PARTNERS.
HOWEVER WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
CAPACITIES AT A LOCAL LEVEL AS
WELL. SO AT THE TIME WE DIDN'T
HAVE THAT WOULD USE THAT
KNOWLEDGE IS THAT EXPECT EXISTS
IN OUR LABORATORY. EVENTUALLY
WITH TIME AND EFFORT WE WERE
ABLE TO BRING ON- IS YOUR TESTS
FOR THE DETECTION OF MIDDLE
SCHOOL NOW WE HAVE THAT RIGHT
TO GET REAL. BUT I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY ONE THAT I WANTED.
ILLUSTRATE IN TERMS OF STAFFING
IS THAT. PART OF OUR LAB IN THE
STATE IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
UCLA. SCHOOL OF MY OF. HEALTH
WHERE WE UTILIZED A STATISTICAL
MODEL TO. TO KINDA ILLUSTRATING
CHAU- HOW THIS. HOW THE RAPIDLY-
DOESN'T NEED. I WOULD BE.
PASSED WIDESPREAD AND SEEN. BIG
CLOSE THE WITH OBSERVABLE DATA
SO WE SAW THAT A LOT OF THE WE
ALSO SPOKE ACCOUNT WHAT THE
ACTUAL CALL OF WITH ANY TO BE
SPENT THEM. AND SO WE HAVE SOME
ROUGH- AND BY THE WAY THIS THIS
THIS. THIS STUDY- WE CAN STAY-
A COP OF THIS TO THE- YES-
REGIS BUT WE HAVE BEEN WE CAN
SAY THAT OVER TO YOU. SURE ARE
WE SAW THAT- AT THE END OF THE-
THE RESPONSE OF THE AND THEN I
OR TO THE TO THIS BRAND OF
MEASLES ARE WE ENDED UP
SPENDING AS- OUR FROM SOME FROM
TWO THREE TO THREE FOUR EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS THIS TO TWENTY
THIS WALL. THAT'S WHAT WE DO ON
A DAILY BASIS. BUT WOULD LIKE A
LACK OF FUNDING LACK OF
STAFFING ARE WE CHAT WILL BE DO
OUR JOBS WERE SCENES BACK IN A
FEW RESPECT A SENSE OF YOU
COMING TO WORK READY TO WORK WE
HAVE WELL AT LEAST FIND. ANTI
BEHIND OUR BACKS. UNFORTUNATELY
THE PERSON THAT WAS WITH STATE
IS LONGER. WORKING FOR THE- OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THEY MOVED ON TO-
OTHER THINGS ACTUALLY WORKING
ON THE A CAR. SO WE NEED TO
ABLE TO A MAKE TO TOLD THE SKY
OF EXPERTISE WITHIN OF HEALTH.
AND SO THIS IS ANOTHER REASON
WHY WE ARE. FOR THIS ONGOING
SUPPORT. WHAT IMPORTANCE. THAT
THAT SHOULD BE TO THE OUR RICH
NOT JUST TO JUST WALK IN THE
BUT EVERY ONE OF THESE THINGS
ARE WATCHING ON A REGULAR BASIS.
HOW HOW HAS THE HOW HAS THE
PANDEMIC. IMPACTED YOUR BUDGET.
AS IT RELATES TO STAFFING. I
KNOW I KNOW STAFF HAS BEEN A
LOT OF OVERTIME STRESSED OUT
NOT HAVING AND ANOTHER STAFF
WHICH IS WHAT I KEEP HEARING.
SO I'M ASSUMING YOU HAVE TO
BRING IN TRAVELERS AND I'M
ASSUMING YOU HAVE TO. PAY A LOT
OF OVERTIME HOW HAS THAT
IMPACTED YOUR BUDGETS AND YOUR
ABILITY TO DELIVER CARE. VERY
SOON AGAIN I THINK FROM THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
STANDPOINT- THEIR HUSBAND
INFUSION OF FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT HAVE COME THROUGH
DIFFERENT- WHAT THEY CALL
ENHANCE LABORATORY CAPACITY
FUNDING. AND SO THAT IS ALLOWED
US TO KIND OF RAMP UP SLOWLY-
ON DIFFERENT LEVELS. AND SO I
WILL SAY THOUGH THAT THOSE
FUNDS EXPIRE THEY'RE NOT YOU
KNOW A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS TYPICALLY
THERE IS. A DISEASE AND THEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STEPS IN
AND PROVIDES SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SO WE SAW THIS WITH
EBOLA WE SAW THIS WITH ZECA.
WE'RE SEEING THAT I THINK
THERE'S A TON OF OTHER EXAMPLES
THAT ARE COMING TO MIND BUT
THAT'S HOW WE'RE SEEING IT WITH
THE PANDEMIC TO. AND SO YES
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO ADD TO
THEIR STAFF AND I THINK IT
HELPS TO OFFSET SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT STAFF
BRING HER IN WITH OVERTIME AND-
THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT THERE IS
NO SOURCES TO CONTINUE THEM AND
SO- THE MOST RECENT FEDERAL
DOLLARS WE HAD JUST ASKED FOR
ONE POINT TWO BILLION FOR
CONTACT TRACING- DISEASE
INVESTIGATION VACCINES AND
TESTING. SOME OF THOSE BECAUSE-
FUNDS WOULD BE USED TOWARDS
STAFFING COSTS AND SOME WILL BE
USED FOR EQUIPMENT AND OTHER.
NEED SECURITY AT A VACCINE SITE
FOR EXAMPLE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THAT AND THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE APPROVED THOSE FUNDS
IN THE PLAN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD. TO PROVIDE
US WITH THAT ONE POINT TWO
BILLION BUT I JUST WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT THAT'S ONLY FOR
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS WORTH OF.
AND COST ESTIMATES ON THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT SIDE AND AS
WE CONTINUE TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE DURATION OF A PANDEMIC
ADDITIONAL AS YOU KNOW
RESOURCES MAY BE NEEDED. THAT'S
WHERE USING FEDERAL FUNDS TO
KIND TO HELP OFFSET THOSE THAT
INITIAL AND IMMEDIATE COST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HOSPITALS
THAT'S IN QUESTION. UNTIL
NURSING FACILITIES. SORRY COULD
YOU REPEAT THE QUESTION
QUESTION IS THIS JUST. STOPPING
I KNOW YOU TO MAIN ISSUE FOR
EVERYBODY HAS. A LACK OF YES A
DIFFERENT. STAFFING IMPACTED
YOUR BUDGETS. YES ABSOLUTELY
WELL AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
HOSPITALS WEREN'T BUDGETING FOR
COVERAGE OR MASSIVE- VITAMINS
LOCKS- SO AGAIN THAT RAMP UP
HAD TO COME IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS- AND I WANT TO. IT'S CDJ
SILVA AND M. ALL THE THAT
INTERNET WORKED AT THE BEEN
DOING RELATIVE TO GETTING US
PROBLEM AND AGENCY AND THE SORT
OF MARKET STYLE. US COSTS AND
PRICING FOR AGENCY AND
TRAVELERS AND THERE IN THE
BEGINNING OF COVERAGE THE BIG
SEARCHES THE WHOLE NATION WAS
USING A LOT OF REGISTRY SO WE
HAD NOTHING AND WE HAVE TO
DEPEND ON. WAIVERS TEAM
NURSING- X. CETERA- TO TRY TO
PUT THE PIECES TOGETHER TO DEAL
WITH THE VOLUME. RIGHT NOW IS
THAT NATIONAL CO RESEARCH HAS
DROPPED WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PULL
IN MORE NURSES FROM AGENCY ANTI
ANTI KRISTOFIC RATIO. SO AGAIN
A PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL.
AGENCIES AND HOSPITALS IT'S
BEEN ABLE TO SHARE AND DO
MULTIPLE TYPES OF TEAM WORK-
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET THOUGH
IT NONE OF THAT WAS BUDGET. AND
OF COURSE WE HAVE GOTTEN
FEDERAL FUNDING BUT NOT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE NEEDED IT- HOW.
HOW DO WE HAVE PROJECT FOR NEXT
SET OF HOGAN VARIANCE- SURGES
IS THAT IS SORT OF MOVING OUT
THERE FOR US HOW WE WILL
PROJECT. WHAT WE NEED BUT NONE
OF US WERE BUDGETING FOR JUST
KIND OF LONG. TERM VOLUME
CHANGE. THE NURSING FACILITIES.
ABSOLUTELY THE DION I'M REGARDS
TO SKILLED NURSE FOR THREE
STAFF BEING THEIR HEADS BEEN
AND THEN AMOUNT ACOSTA
OBVIOUSLY JUST LIKE A HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS I BUDGET- SINCE YOU THE
IMPACT WAS ON. A LOT OF. HE'D
ADDITIONAL YOUR TIME SO CALL
YOU KNOW THAT I'M YOU KNOW
YOU'RE OKAY WELL AS A LOT OF
OVERTIME AS A LOT OF FAMILY
MEMBERS YOU KNOW BEING STUCK
CALMER CHILDREN BEING HOME I
WERE ABLE TO REPORT AND TO WORK
AND SO A LOT OF OVERTIME AND
DOUBLE TIME LOSING KURDISH
ALLOWED OF TOWN INCREASED I'M
STOPPING BECAME MORE AND MORE
DIFFICULT. AND SO A LOT OF THIS
LADY DID TURN TO THE REGISTRY
SERVICES AND THEN IN THE LATEST
SURGE ON EVEN THE REGISTRY
SERVICES A HOSPITAL MENTIONED
THOSE RESOURCES- BECAME VERY
MINIMAL AND IT WAS REALLY HARD
STAFF COMING IN AND BEING
WILLING TO STEP UP TO THE PLATE
AND BASICALLY WORKED EXHAUSTION
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE RESIDENTS
OFF THE CARE THAT THEY NEEDED-
CURRENTLY AND WE ARE ALLOCATING
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES THOSE
RESOURCES ARE BEING HIRED FROM
ART ARE STILL WORKING THERE
PHILIPPINES IN ORDER TO. STAFF
THE NEW STATE OUR RESOURCES AND
SO WE HAVE FOUND THAT COST
OF THE REGISTRY IS YOU KNOW
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN SOME AREAS
HOW FROM WHAT PRIOR RATES USED
TO BE AND THEN ALSO LOSING MANY
STAFF TO REGISTRIES HAS CREATED
EVEN MORE BURDEN ON THE
FACILITY'S. AND SKILLED NURSING
WE DO TRY TO PROVIDE A MORE
HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENT AND STILL
HAVING THE STABILITY OF PEOPLE
THAT KNOW THE RESIDENTS IS MOST
IMPORTANT STILL HAVING HAVING
REGULAR PEOPLE THERE INSTEAD OF
TRAVELERS IS HUGE PART OF
PROVIDING PATIENT CARE. YOU
WOULDN'T ONE OPERATED SCHOOL
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS EVERY. A
NEW ONE ALL THE TIME- I THANK
THANK YOU MUCH AND I AND I. AND
I THINK IT'S JUST A TO KNOW
THAT WE SO INTER TO. IN
DELIVERING OUR HEALTH CARE.
THAT WE REALLY ALL NEED TO THE
STATE NEEDS TO. INVEST AND FUND
A WORKFORCE. BECAUSE WE WITH
PEOPLE OUT DELIVERING- ANOTHER
IT MATTERS ANYMORE. AT THE DR
PAN I JUST WANTED ALL OF YOU
FOR OF THE YOU HAVE DONE. AND
REALLY HAVE BEEN- THE BARRIERS
THAT THAT'S HOLDING HOLDING US
ALL TOGETHER DOT DEPENDED YOU
HAVE SOME MORE ON THIS. THANK
YOU AND US IDEA IS I THINK AS
YOU MAY NOTE THAT-
UNFORTUNATELY WE EAT AS MUCH AS
WE CAN EVEN PUT MONEY IN THAT
DIRECTION- YOU'LL PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS ARE HIGHLY TRAINED-
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE HIGHLY
TRAINED AND IT'S- NOT. AND SO
IT'S NOT AS IF WELL WE WILL
EVEN WHEN THE MONEY SHOWS UP
FOR SHORT TERM YOU CAN
DEFINITELY FIND- SKILLED PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES OTHER ONES JUST
SITTING AROUND WITH NOTHING TO
DO THAT ARE READY TO BE HIRED.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT'S WHY IT'S A LOT
OF OVERTIME AND OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS AS WELL BECAUSE- EVEN IF
YOU HAD THE MONEY TO TRY TO
HIRE PEOPLE. THEY MAY NOT BE
PRESENT- AT LEAST NOT SKILL
LEVEL THAT YOU NEED SO- WE NEED
TO THAT'S WHY IT HAS TO BE A
LONG TERM INVESTMENT INTO
RESTRUCTURING ADEQUATE ONGOING
STAFFING NOT. SAYING THAT WE
CAN JUST TRY TO HIRE PEOPLE AND
THE LAST MINUTE FOR A SURGE.
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY WHICH
AAIN JUST SPEAKS TO ME REALLY
INVESTING IN OUR AND OUR HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE. AS AS
WELL AS IT AND DATA. OKAY THING
ELSE AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE- WHICH IS THAT
DIRECT. THAT RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES COVERED. DIRECT
EXPRESS MANAGERS. YES GOOD NEW
SENATORS INTRACTABLE PERMANENT
FINANCE I'LL BE HANDLING- ISSUE
THREE- SERVICE PROPOSAL IS A-
BROAD RANGING ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE IT
SUPPORTS THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. OUR QUESTIONS
REHABILITATION. VETERANS
AFFAIRS SOCIAL SERVICES A
HOSPITALS AT THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS HELLO
SERVICES OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES- MEMORIZE IT PROPOSES
CERTAIN STATEWIDE FLEXIBILITIES
ARE ALL BEGIN WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE NON DPH ITEMS-
MY- POSITION OF THE FORMER
FINANCES OVERSEEING OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE FOR PORTFOLIO
SYSTEM OF THE- NINETY PH
PROPOSALS ALL OF THE MY BEST
ANSWER MEMBER QUESTIONS ONE-
BUT WE MAY NEED TO- TAKE THOSE
BACK IN AND RESPOND AT A LATER
TIME AFTER CONSULTING WITH
OTHER- ANALYSTS MANAGERS.
FINANCE WHO ARE MORE FAMILIAR-
SILVA CHANNEL SERVICES THAT THE
BUDGET IS PROPOSING A EIGHTY
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THE
PARMESAN SERVICES TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING LOGISTICS SUPPORT
PROVIDE WAREHOUSES USED FOR
INBOUND AND OUTBOUND MOVEMENT
OF PP- VARIOUS. MEDICAL
SUPPLIES EQUIPMENT. THE ALSO
SUPPORT DIGESTIVE ROLE. I DID
MISS OF THREE NON. SHELTER
PROGRAMS TO PUT YOU TO PROTECT
AT RISK- THERE OVER AND DEATHS
FROM CO IN NINETEEN ACTION- FOR
THE- DEPARTMENT OF. CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION THE BUDGET
PROPOSES TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
POINT THREE MILLION TO CONTINUE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES EFFORTS TO TREAT
OVER NINETEEN. AND MINIMIZE
EXPOSURE TO INMATES AND STAFF.
ARE YOU KNOW ONE HUNDRED EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION OF THIS TOTAL
WILL BE PRIMARILY USED FOR
TEMPLATE RENTAL CONTRACTS THUS
THE OVERTIME CLEANING AND
PURCHASING- PP AND THE
REMAINING ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION. I WILL
MAINLY BE USED REMAINS AT
TESTING MEDICAL STAFFING
REGISTRY AND OVERTIME A MEDICAL
TREATMENT AND PURCHASING AP-
I'M A VETERANS AFFAIRS THE
BUDGET IT'S PROPOSING FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION TO CONTINUE
AT THE DEPARTMENT'S DIRECTOR
SPOTS ACTIVITIES THESE
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE- IF RAISING
FOR PERSON ACOSTA. FOSTER
PARENTS HOMES I NECESSARY TO
REDUCE RISK OF INFECTION. AND
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE TO
PATIENTS. BERMAN SOCIAL SERVICE
WILL RECEIVING ME. FOR ITS
RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM SUPPORT
ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SERVICES TO
IMMIGRANTS DURING EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS- WHEN FEDERAL
FUNDING IS NOT AVAILABLE. THE
HOSPITALS I WILL BE RECEIVING
FIFTY TWO MILLION TO STICK IT
IN HIS WORK THAT THEIR RESPONSE
EFFORTS PROPOSED FUNDING I WILL
BE USED FOR THE MAIN THREE
AREAS OF RESPONSE PERSONNEL'S
PERSONAL SERVICES. AND YOUR-
OPERATING EXPENSES AND
EQUIPMENT AND OF COURSE TESTING.
THE BOARD OF THE STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS STATING
COMMUNICATIONS- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE BUDGET IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL INCLUDES
TWELVE POINT ONE MILLION I TO
SUPPORT COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS WITH THE AREA
INCREASED NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS RELEASED FROM STATE
PRISON NOT A POST RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION THE
REDUCE INSTITUTION POPULATIONS
IN RESPONSE THE PANDEMIC. ALL
MENTAL SERVICES WILL BE
RECEIVING A THIRTY SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE THEIR
DIRECT RESPONSE OPERATIONS
WHICH INCLUDE. SEARCH SITES. TO
SERVE FOLKS DIAGNOSED WITH
EXPOSED TO OR AT HIGH RISK FOR
KOBE- THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
BEDS AT- FAIRVIEW AT QUARTER
REAL DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS FOR
ABOUT SIX MONTHS- OPPOSITE
EMERGENCY SERVICES IS RECEIVING
A LETTER HUNDRED LET NINETEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION. FOR
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT FUNDING TO REIMBURSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR ELIGIBLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH EMERGENCY
ACTIVITIES UNDERTAKEN IN
RESPONSE THE STATE'S COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY BROCK.
PROCLAMATION THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH- I BELIEVE THIS
IS THE LARGEST ALLOCATION OF
THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE RECEIVING
A HUNDRED TWENTY POINT FIVE
MILLION. TO CONTINUE PROACTIVE
RESPONSE OPERATIONS ARE FOCUSED
ON MITIGATING THE ACTRESS READ
COMMITTEE TRANSMISSION AND
BUILDING ADDITIONAL HEALTH CARE
CAPACITY- THIS FUNDING WILL
PREDOMINANTLY BE USED FOR
STATEWIDE ESTING. AND ITS
AUXILIARY OR COMPONENTS-
INTERVIEW STATEWIDE CAN. WERE
TO NEW CONTROL SECTIONS-
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN POINT
NINE ONE ALLOWS FOR DECREASED
TO THE COVE IN NINETEEN
SPECIFIC ITEMS OF
APPROPRIATIONS. AND THE FUNDING
TRANSFER FUNDING BETWEEN THESE
ITEMS OF A PREPARATION SHOULD
COVER NINETEEN RESPONSE AND
ACTIVIT RECOVERY ACTIVITIES
NECESSITATE THE ADJUSTMENT- IN
ADDITION. THIS PATROL SECTION
WOULD ALLOWFINANCE TO INCREASE
ANY OF THE COPA NINETEEN
SPECIFIC ITEMS OR ANY FEDERAL
TRUST FUND ITEMS AND TO CREATE
ESTABLISH ANY NEW ITEMS OF
APPROPRIATION AMOUNTS EQUAL TO
ANY FEDERAL OR PRIVATE FUNDING
BECOMES AVAILABLE. HOW DOES THE
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN POINT
NINE TWO THAT WERE PROPOSING. I
WOULD PROVIDE FOR THE CONTINUED
USE OF THE DISASTER RESPONSE
AGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT OF
JURY- I FOLLOWING THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS FISCAL YEAR.
UP FRONT ANTICIPATED COSTS
RELATED TO THE GOVERNOR'S STATE
OF EMERGENCY ROP RECLAMATION
ON MARCH FOURTH OF LAST YEAR
WOULD HAVE NINETEEN. IN
ADDITION TO SOME OF THE VERY
SUS THE OF THE SPECIFIC LINE
ITEMS OF SUPPORT FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT DISCUSSED THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY FORTY MILLION.
RESTED MATED STATEWIDE HOSPITAL
IMMEASURABLE SURGE.
PREPARATION- EIGHT EIGHTY POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THAT CONTACT
TRACING. HUNDRED FORTY THREE
TWENTY MILLION FOR THAT AN
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS COSTS
ABOUT A- HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
ALLOCATIONS TO INDIVIDUAL
APARTMENTS. ONCE WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON NEED.
THIS FUNDING WOULD CONTINUE TO
BE ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE AT
THE DRILL OF FUNDING MECHANISM
AND CONSISTENT WITH THE
PROPOSED. CONTROL SECTIONAL
LEVIN POINT NINETY TWO MORE
THAN HAPPY TO TAKE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON THAT- ON THOSE
CONTROL SECTIONS AS WELL IN
ADDITION TO THAT. THE AND ITEMS
OF APPROPRIATIONS ACROSS THESE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS- TO THIS
THE SECOND QUESTION THAT THE
SENATE PROPOSED FUTURE OF THE
QUINCY BRANCH LABORATORY. I
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
SIGNALED A WILLINGNESS TO
CONTINUE OPERATION POST CODE. I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION
OR THE AND TO DESCRIBE. THE
EVENTUAL USE OF SAID FACILITY-
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON GETTING
IT RAMPED UP AND WORKING AT A
100% EFFICIENCY SO WE CAN MEET
THE NEEDS NOW- AND YOU KNOW THE
FUTURE OF THAT LABORATORY. WILL
BE DETERMINED- AS AS WE-
APPROACH THE- WHICH WAS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THIS
THIS COVERAGE SITUATION. AND OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
A VALUED PARTNER- IN THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS. SO WITHOUT ALL
CLOSE THIS INTRODUCTION AND-
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
IN LIGHT OF THE LAST PANEL THE
FIRST QUESTION WOULD BE IS IT
ENOUGH AND IS IT GOING TO THE
RIGHT PLACES. WELL I WOULD SAY
THAT- THE MAIN DRIVE BEHIND HIS
PROPOSALS TO GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE THE BEST POSSIBLE
LOOK AT ESTIMATED COSTS SO IF
YOUR QUESTION IS IT ENOUGH- WE
LOOK AT THE NEED ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS WE IDENTIFIED CLEAR
AREAS OF RESOURCES THAT NEEDED
TO. WE BOOKED THOSE SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO- REVIEW THOSE
PROPOSALS OF PINE AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON ON THAT IS
IT ENOUGH. WILK REMAINS TO BE
SEEN WERE IN A HIGHLY FLUID
SITUATION WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
PROPOSING THE STAEWIDE
FLEXIBILITIES VIA CONTROL
SECTION THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR AN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO BE
PROVIDED BUT OF COURSE- WE
WANTED TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE AND ENGAGE IN A IN A
TRADITIONAL BUDGET PROCESS
WHICH IS WHY WE- THERE ARE BASS
TO ESTIMATE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE WIDE RANGING- THAT-
ASKS AND RESPONSIBILITIES THE
STATE PASSED- SO I GUESS IT
INSURANCE. THE ANSWER TO
QUESTION IS IT ENOUGH- IN TERMS
OF NO KNOWN AS WE'VE DONE OUR
BEST TO ADD TO IDENTIFY THOSE
IN TERMS OF UNKNOWN UNKNOWNS WE
HAVE AOUT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
THAT'S A SORT OF AVAILABLE FOR
AB. ALLOCATION AND THEN ALSO TO
THE CONTINUED. USE OF THE THREE
L. AT- ACCOUNT. FORTY IN THE IN
CONCERT WITH THAT OVERALL. YOU
KNOW- BUDGET YOUR PREFERRED THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL SO WE'RE
PROPOSING THIS. AND WIDE
RANGING. HALONG COMPASS IN
PROPOSAL TO MEET THESE NEEDS
AND THEN ALSO- YOU IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE JURY- ACCOUNT
ALSO AND KEEPING THE DOOR OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING EMERGENT
SITUATIONS- ONE EXPECTED COSTS
THAT- WE CAN'T PREDICT AT THIS
TIME. SO- I'D SAY GENERALLY
SPEAKING WE'RE WE'RE- WE'RE
MEETING THE NEEDS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AND WE HAVE
CONTINGENCIES SHOULD ADDITIONAL
NEEDS ARISE. AND I THINK
THAT'S- THE INCIDENT THAT THAT
IS KEY AND I HOPE YOU ALREADY
WITH FOR THE DRILL SYSTEM WHEN.
NEW FUNDING COMES IN HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO PAY THAT
MAYBE SOME OF THE OTHER FUNDS
TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN THINGS.
THAT THE FEDERAL FUNDS ARE NOT
COVERING. AND I GUESS I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE FOR THE VALENCIA
LABORATORY- YOU KNOW EVERY
EVERY STEP BACKWARDS IS MONEY
LOST SO THERE'S BEEN SOME.
ISSUES THAT WOULD ALL COME TO
LIGHT WAS THE MISSILE BLOWERS
IN THE VALENCIA LABORATORY.
SOME IS IN SOME BAD DATA AND
ANYTIME WE GET BAD DATA OR BAD
TESTING IT DID AGAIN OUR ROADS
FEAR HAS TO BUILD BACK UP. CAN
YOU DEFEND A LITTLE BIT THE
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
MILLION TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THIS ESPECIALLY IF WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO THIS
FACILITY WILL BE USED FOR.
AFTER THE END OF THE PANDEMIC.
CERTAINLY WELL. FOR THE FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR- WE PROJECTED BASED
ON. EXISTING TRENDS AND
EXPECTED- COSTS AS WE CONTINUE
TO RAMP UP TOWARDS 1100%
OPERATION OF THE VALENCIA
LABORATORY. AND THAT AS WE KIND
OF REACH THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. AND ACTIVATIONS MORE
WIDESPREAD WE ANTICIPATED AS A
SORT OF DECLINE IN THE NUMBER
OF TASKS SO IN IN WHAT WELL WE
MAY NOT HAVE THE FUTURE OF THE
VALENCIA LABORATORY FULLY
SKETCHED OUT FOR THE ENTIRETY
OF THIS PER THE PERIOD OF TIME
THAT'S COVERED BY THIS PROPOSAL
WE KNOW WHAT THE LAB WILL BE
DOING WILL BE PROVIDING
TESTING- YOU MEETING THAT THAT.
THAT SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
TESTING THAT THE VALENCIA
BRANCH LABORATORY WAS BOTTOM
LINE TO ME- AND ANY SORT OF
FUTURE DISCUSSION ABOUT ITS
OPERABILITY AND OPERATIONS
PROBABLY. WOULD PROBABLY BE
HAPPENING AND IN THAT. EACH
ABOUT BUDGET. YEAH AT LEAST FOR
THE NEXT TERM NEXT YEAR-
PHYSICALLY SPEAKING WE WERE
VERY CLEAR ON WHAT THE
DEVELOPERS ARE WE DOING AND WE
OF COURSE TAKE AT THE
WHISTLEBLOWER ALLEGATIONS VERY
SERIOUSLY- WILL BE WORKING WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH TO- TO ENSURE
THAT THAT ONCE YOU BRANCH LIKE
TORIES BEING RANG CONSTANTLY
AND ACTIVELY. AND PROVIDING THE
SERVICES THAT WE ENVISIONED FOR
RIDE SO- IN TERMS OF- COULD YOU
THE FUNDING FOR VALENCIA BRANCH
LABORATORY IT IS AN ESTIMATE.
BUT IT'S AN ESTIMATE BASED ON
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES AND
PROJECTED- INCREASES IN
CAPACITY INSTEAD LABORATORY AND
OF COURSE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ENGAGE LEGISLATURE IN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT ITS- POSE
DRAVID- ROLE IN. THE STATEWIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
YEAH IT DIDN'T. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE VOTE. IS
HUGE IT'S FOR THE PA I THINK
IT'S LIKE. ASKING THE GET THE
EDT MY MONEY RIGHT NOW AS SOME
THAT'S BEEN VERY PUBLIC THAT
HAS HAD SOME ISSUES AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GIVE ANOTHER. FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE. MILLION
SO I ALWAYS JUST THINK WHAT MY
NEIGHBORS ON THE STREET ARE
GOING TO ASK ME. THANK YOU. DR
PEPPER. THANK YOU ACTUALLY- AT.
THE AT WITH THE ACTUALLY ASK IF
WE CAN HAVE ELLIE- COMMENT ON
THE CONTROL SECTIONS. I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GIVEN
THEY'RE- GIVING US THEIR BEST
GUESS BUT ALSO THE LOW OF
CERTAINTY. AND SO I WANTED
SHOULD. BE SURE THAT THE
CONSOLE CONTROL SECTIONS HAVE
SUFFICIENT LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT SO I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR. WHAT
FLEXIBILITY OF ONCE AS A MUCH
LESS ABILITY BUT WHAT'S LIKELY
HAVE TO COME ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I'LL BE SURE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT. MECHANISMS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. SO THAT AS THE
MONEY IS BEING SPENT THAT WE
HAVE- SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT- SO
L. A. O. CAN YOU COMMENT ON THE
CONTROL SECTIONS. THAT WERE FOR
TWO BY FINANCE. IN TERMS OF
YEAH. THANK YOU YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR- AS AS I
NOTED IN MY EARLIER COMMENTS
AND I THINK I MISTAKENLY
REFERRED TO IT AS A ELEVEN
POINT NINE FIVE. IT'S ACTUALLY
A PROPOSED CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE. THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY
NOTIFICATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE- IT WOULD ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE
DECREASE OR TRANSFER FUNDS
BETWEEN SOME SPECIFIED
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WELL AS SPEND FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES NO
INVOLVEMENT BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE SECOND CONTROL SECTIONAL
LEVIN POINT NINE TWO WOULD
EXTEND THE JURY- CELERITY-
THROUGH THE ENTIRE FISCAL YEAR
AND AS I'M SURE YOU'RE ALREADY
WELL AWARE- THE JURY- A PROCESS
ONLY REQUIRES NOTIFICATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN A TRANSFER
IS MADE FROM THE SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES TO
THE JURY- SUB ACCOUNT. BUT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY
NOT REQUIRED TO INFORM- THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HOW THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE FURTHER ALLOCATED
OR WHAT THE- WHICH WHICH-
DEPARTMENTS- NECESSARILY. SO
SIMPLE FOR BOTH PROPOSED
CONTROL SECTIONS- DO YOU CAN DO
NOT INVOLVE- THE LEGISLATURE-
EARLY TO ANY DEGREE ALL RIGHT
SO- LET'S GO BACK TO FINANCE
THAN- ELEVEN NINE ONE NO
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION HOW'S
THAT ACCEPTABLE- ELEVEN NINE
ONE. I'M NOT A PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL I WAS IN THE- PROCESS
OF DRAFTING OKAY BUT- YOU KNOW
ELEVEN NINE ONE NINE- IS A-
MORE INVOLVED CONTROL SECTION.
BOB WHAT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
ALLOW US TO DO IS MOVE THAT I
GUESS THE ALLOW YOU TO DO BUT
WHAT ABOUT TELLING US WHAT'S
GOING ON WHAT YOU'VE DONE OR
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO. WILL
THIS CASE BE I THINK THE BCG
OUTLINES THE FULL SCOPE OF
ACTIVITIES AND FUNDING FOR
DEPARTMENT THAT WERE WERE
LOOKING TO EXPAND- THE REAL
PURPOSE OF THIS IS THERE ARE
RESPONSIBILITIES OR- CHANGE
BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS RENTS
BETTER BETTER FIT FOR ANOTHER
PARTY TO DO SO- SO RIGHT I TELL
THEM RIGHT AWAY. I REALIZE THAT
YOU WERE YOURSELF WERE NOT
PERSONALLY INVOLVED- BUT I
GUESS YOU'RE SINCE YOU'RE TO.
REPRESENT. FROM FINANCE PERHAPS
YOU CAN TELL YOUR- RUN IT UP
THE CHAIN I THINK THE IDEA THAT
THERE'S NO LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION. OR IF THERE'S YOU
KNOW- SO I THINK WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT- AND WHETHER DEBTS
THE SUB COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. AND THEN AS I
MENTIONED THE G. OLA APPROACH-
REALLY WAS NOT DESIGNED FOR
THIS ON GOING SO I AGAIN YOU
KNOW RECOGNIZE WE HAVE A-
MERCHANT SEE WHERE WE Y. GIVES
FLEXIBILITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION BILL RESPOND I
GET THAT. BUT WE ALSO HAVE
ROUTE YOU KNOW OUR- WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERSIGHT
AND MONITORING AND OF COURSE
OUR FUNDAMENTAL- OUR TO
APPROPRIATE. SO I HOPE THAT WE
THERE'LL BE SOME REVISITING AT
THESE CONTROL SECTIONS IN A WAY
THAT RECOGNIZES. AS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT WE HAVE
THIS- THE OVERSIGHT WE WANT TO
GIVE YOU THE FLEXIBILITY THE
MINISTRATION OF LIES THAT YOU
THE MINISTRATION OF FLEXIBILITY
TO ADDRESS THIS PANDEMIC- BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO BE SURE WE HAVE
THE OVERSIGHT AND I THINK YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES WE HAVE LOW
HINTS OF THINGS DROPPING OUT SO
YOU MENTIONED THAT. WE HAVE THE
SINGLE USE CONTRACTS NOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT IN AGAIN IN A
CRISIS. PERHAPS NOT MUCH TIME
TO GO GET BIDS AND SO FORTH BUT
THEN WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT-
THAT THE- CONTRACTING PROCESS
IS BEING DONE AND A RESPONSIBLE
WAY SO THAT. WE DON'T YOU KNOW
SO THAT- WE THERE ARE ISSUES
THAT POP UP BECAUSE A SINGLE
SOURCE CONTRACTING IT CETERA
SO. THESE ARE ISSUES THAT I
HOPE WE CAN WORK OUT- PRIOR TO-
BEFORE PASSAGE OF THE BUDGET
WHERE. OF YEAH WILL. IT WE NEED
TO BE SHARP AT THE PUMP CAST.
RIGHT AND SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
AND THAT'S ALSO WHY WE HEARTHE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. INFORMATION AND
THERE'S NO LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION- THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM BECAUSE OF SOMETHING
DIDN'T GO TO GO RIGHT WELL IT'S
BEEN ENTIRELY AND THAT THE
ISSUE OF THE- I GUESS IT. THAT
BECOMES ENTIRELY RESPONSIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION AND- MAYBE YOU
WANT ACCEPT THAT RESPONSIBILITY
BUT- I THINK THAT PEOPLE TYPE-
THANK THAT WE SHOULD. THAT WE
SHOULD SHARE SOME OF THAT SO
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY MESSAGE
RECEIVED. I WILL COMMUNICATE
THAT CENTER THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU. BUT YEAH BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE L. THE
EFFORT AND THAT TOO TO HELP US-
YOU PROJECTIONS THAT THAT'S
ALWAYS A APPRECIATE I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE AYE I WOULD
JUST MAKE NOTE- IN TERMS OF THE
VALENCIA LABORATORY- ELISE HERE
TO WRITE UP- THIS VIRUS ISN'T
GOING AWAY IN THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR- AS MUCH JUSTAS HARD WE
TRY AND UP EVERYTHING SO. I
FEELING WE'RE STILL GOING TO BE
DOING QUITE A BIT OF TESTING
EVEN ONCE WE GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED JUST TO BE SURE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE L. BREAKS AND IN
PARTICULAR AREAS AND SO WHETHER
THAT CAN BE HANDLED BY THE
EXISTING SMELL TESTING SYSTEM
OR WE STILL NEED THE STUFF OF
YOU KNOW THE HELP OF- THE
DENTAL AFTER I ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT PART THE REASON FOR THE
LABORATORY. WAS ALSO BECAUSE-
IT IT HELPED DRIVE PUSH PRICES
DOWN ACROSS THE BOARD BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENED IS WE HAD A
CONTRACT TO GET A BETTER PRICE
AND- SO. THIS IMPACT IS LARGER
SO THE TEST IT DOES SO I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERNS
RAISED BUT- I JUST THINK WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT. THE
MULTIPLE FACTS THIS LABORATORY
THE POSITIVE X. AXIS
LABORATORIES HAD ON. TRYING TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO TESTING AND
ALSO. REDUCING EXPENDITURES ON
TESTING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY IF THERE'S
NOTHING ELSE FROM FINANCER OR
THE L. A. O. WILL GO ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ADJUSTMENT TO
SUPPORT INFECTIOUS DISEASE
MODELING- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S ADRIAN BERASA. I AM THE
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR. OF
WITH THE CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE AND I'LL BE COVERING
ISSUES FOR BY TODAY- ALL START
WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF RBC HE
SUPPORTED FACTIONS DISEASE
MODELING. AND I BELIEVE THERE'S
ALSO A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
REQUIRING I'M HOW THESE
MODELING RESOURCES AND EFFORTS
COULD YOU HELP ONE ADDRESSING
OTHER INFECTIOUS DISEASES- I
ALL ALL DRESSED AS PART OF MY
OVERVIEW BUT OF COURSE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AS WELL. OKAY TO GET
TO GET STARTED- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE A REQUEST
FOR A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AND A
COMPRESSOR EXPENDITURE OF THE
ORGANS WILL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE SUPPORT
F FACTIONS THIS GAME DISEASE
MODELING ACTIVITIES. AS PART OF
THE URGENT KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. TO REALLY
INFORM PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
DECISION MAKING. SO SPOKE ARE-
MAYBE WHERE AT THE START OF THE
FLAPPING ENDEMIC. H. VERY
QUICKLY ESTABLISH A CORONAVIRUS
MODELING I T. AND MODELING IS
PLAYED A VERY VERY CRITICAL
ROLE AND INFORMING NUMEROUS
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS AND
POLICIES. SINCE THEN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL OFFICE AND
LAUNCHED A CALIFORNIA KOPEN
NINETEEN MODELING AND ANALYTICS
ANALYTICS CONSORTIUM. IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY WITH INPUT FROM
C. P. H. THIS CONSORTIUM WAS
REALLY DEVELOPED TO CONSOLIDATE
MODELING AND ANALYTIC
ACTIVITIES ACROSS THE UC
SYSTEM- WHICH WILL BE USED TO
INFORM STATE POLICY DECISIONS
AND REALLY TAKE. ADVANTAGE OF
THE REACH OF THE UC SYSTEM.
WHICH SPANS ACROSS NINE
ACADEMIC AND HEALTH CAMPUSES
AND BRINGS TOGETHER OVER A
WITH DIVERSE ACADEMIC AND
HIGHLY TECHNICAL EXPERTISE.
THIS PROPOSAL INTENDS TO
LEVERAGE THE COLLABORATIVE
NATURE OF THE CONSORTIUM. AND
MEET THE URGENT NEEDS OF THE
COVERED NINETEEN RESPONSE BY
ADDING MUCH NEEDED INTERNAL
CAPACITY- TO THE DEPARTMENT BY
HIRING A DEDICATED STAFF MEMBER
AN EXISTING SAFFING CONTRACT.
THIS INDIVIDUAL WAS ACTUALLY
SERVICES CDPH CONSORTIUM LEAD.
AND ENSURE WORD BACK THAT WE
ARE LEVERAGING THIS
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
YOU SEE PARKER'S. AND WE DO
INTEND TO FULLY LEVERAGE. THIS
COLLABORATIVE MODEL AND
EVALUATE LESSONS LEARNED TO
POTENTIALLY EXPAND MODELING
ACTIVITIES TO OTHER INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. AND HELP INFORM
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE EFFORTS
AROUND US. I'M SO WHAT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT- THE PANELING
OUT. I CAN HEAR FROM ELLIOTT.
YES MATT I'M SURE THIS IS SORT
OF HEADACHE FROM THE L. A. AND
WE JUST MAKE ONE NOTE ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL AND THAT IS THAT
THERE IS A COMPANION PROPOSAL
IN THE UC BUDGET FOR ONE POINT
TWO FIVE MILLION TO ADDRESS.
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CONSORTIUM ON ON THE UC SIDE OF
THINGS THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
DALLAS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
PRESENTATION AND- APPRECIATE
ELIO GLASS MAKING NOTED THAT
I'VE IT THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR A FUTURE PANDEMIC
AN OUTBREAK RESPONSE SO WELL I
GUESS WE'RE PUTTING IT TOGETHER
FOR CODES IF WE HAD ONLY HAD OF
BEFORE BEEN VERY HELPFUL SO
CERTAINLY HAVE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF US HAVING THIS CAPACITY
THANK YOU. MISSY MEASURE TWICE
CUT ONCE- WE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. OKAY SO- FOR
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE I'LL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
OUR EIGHT OUT ON NOVEMBER REST
AMERICANS AND AGAIN HAPPY NOT-
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AFTER. THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED EIGHT OUT LOCAL
SYSTEMS FUNDING OF FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION WITH NO STATE GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION. THE REVISED
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET IS FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION. WHICH IS AN INCREASE
OF TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
OR SIX POINT 6% WHEN COMPARED
TO THE TWENTY. TWENTY BUDGET
ACT. THIS IS REALLY PRIMARILY
DUE TO AN INCREASE OF
PROJECTED- ON MEDICATION
EXPENDITURES. PREDOMINATELY FOR
CLIENTS WHO ARE ENROLLED IN OUR
PROGRAM AND I WAS- IT APPLE
LEAD MEANING THEY HAVE NO THIRD
PARTY PAYER COVERAGE. AND THEN
PROPOSED EIGHT OUT LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. S. FIVE HUNDRED
AND THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
WITH NO STATE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION THIS REPRESENTS
AN INCREASE OF SIXTY FIVE POINT
ONE MILLION OR FOURTEEN POINT
NINE PERCENT. COMPARED TO
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. BY
THE NECK CREASE YOU EXCUSE ME
THE INCREASE HERE IS DUE TO THE
SAME REASON BUT ALSO- THERE IS
A PROJECTED INCREASE AND-
INSURANCE PREMIUM EXPENDITURES
THAT ARE DRIVING THE COST
INCREASE. INTERAC INCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW OF THE NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO. IT DOES.
OIL ON THIS. REALLY AGAIN
NOTHING IN ANOTHER JUST EXAMPLE
OF A REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM
THAT WE CAN'T TAKE OUR EYES OFF
OF AS AS WE'RE DEALING WITH
THE- WITH THE PANDEMIC. OKAY
ANYTHING FROM THE PART OF THE
PART OF FINANCIAL THE. OKAY
THEN LET'S GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY ESTIMATE. A DOCTOR DID
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON- SENATORS MY
NAME IS COMMON LINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY AND THE LICENSING
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. THE M.
C. PROGRAM IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF
LICENSED HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
AND HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
TO ASSESS THE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF HEALTHCARE
QUALITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CCQ FOR FILLS THIS ROLE BY
CONDUCTING PERIODIC INSPECTIONS
AND COMPLAINT RESOLUTION SO
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES. TO
RETURN COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
STATE LAWS AND REGULATIONS. C.
SECURE LICENSES AND CERTIFIES
OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES AND AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA IN. THIRTY DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. HE'S ALSO RISK FOR
FUNDS FROM THE SENATE FROM
MEDICAID SERVICES. FOR THOSE
ARE ACCEPTING MEDICARE MEDICAID
PAYMENTS C. SIX ZERO VIRUS
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE. AND
FEDERAL LAWS REGULATIONS AND
CONTRACTS FOR THE LAWSUIT IS
KIND CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
CERTIFY THOSE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES. LOCATED WITHIN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. IT IS SEIZE
OVERSEAS THE SUFFOCATION OF
NURSE. OWN HEALTHCARE IS ALSO
TECHNICIANS IN THE LICENSING OF
NURSING HOME ADMINISTRATORS.
WITH REGARD TO OUR NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE THE CURRENT YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO SEE A
SIX YEAR. CDPH PROJECTS REVISED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EXPENDITURES
TORTILLA OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY POINT SIX MILLION. WHICH
IS A TEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DECREASE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT. THIS CHANGES TO THE
SECTION THREE POINT LINE- PLAY
COMES ISSUE REDUCTIONS. FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. HELP US MAYES
EXPENDITURES TOTALING THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE MILLION
WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF THIRTY
SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
COMPARED TO A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
START. THIS INCREASE INCLUDES.
NINETEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE- YEAR THREE OF
THE CONTRACT LOS WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THAT WAS
MENTIONED THE TOP OF THE-
BUDGET HEARING- FROM READINESS.
IT ALSO INCLUDES A SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
FOR THIS INVOICE COMPLICATION
BRANCH EXPANSION FOR THE
ANALYZE COST INCLUDING LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STATEWIDE
WORKLOAD AS WELL AS FOR PC PS
WHICH I'LL PRESENT SHORTLY TO
THE COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE ASKED
FOR AN UPDATE FOR THE
EVALUATION THE BIGGEST THREAT
FOR OUR HEALTH FLEW BY WITH A
NURSES AS OF NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. VACANCY RATE IS TEN
POINT 3% FOR OUR NURSERY OR
CLASSIFICATION WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF FOUR POINT 6% FROM
OUR- OFFICE HERE IN NINETEEN
TWENTY. THE TWENTY ALSO ASKED
FOR AN UPDATE FOR THE
COMPLETION RATE FOR A LONG TERM
CARE COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS.
THE TO SIX FROM OUR QUARTER
THREE FOR STATE FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY SURE THAT WE
CLOSED APPROXIMATELY 65% OF ALL
LONG TERM CARE COMPLAINTS
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS. AFTER THE
SAME TIME WE CLOSED ABOUT 63%
FOR OFFICIALLY REPORTED
INCIDENTS- WITHIN SIXTY DAYS.
AND WITH THAT. I WILL COST TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY ACTUALLY- HELLO CAN YOU
JUST GIVE ME YOUR YOUR TAKE ON
THIS AND THEN I DO HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AFTER THAT.
AND SENATOR AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SO- BUT TALK ABOUT HIS HISTORY
SO OF IS THIS PAST YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE I KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
FOR AWHILE- THE SO. FIRST OF
ALL OF THIS LIKE THE VACANCY
RATE AGAIN I REALIZE WE'RE TOLD
IT NOW HAS BEEN THOSE LIKE IT'S
CREEPING UP AGAIN- AT TEN POINT
THREE PERCENT- CAN USE. TO- THE
SPEAKER THAT AND WHAT MIGHT BE
DONE TO KEEP IT FROM CONTINUING
TO RISE BECAUSE THAT I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN AN ISSUE. AND THEN
THE EIGHTH AND THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER PART IS THAT IS YOU
MENTIONED THE- TIMELINESS US
YOU KNOW 65% OF THAT'S ONLY TWO
THIRDS ARE DONE IN TWO MONTHS
SO. WHAT'S THAT TALE THE
REMAINING WELL- ONE THIRD
TAILING OFF HOW HOW LONG OR
THINGS TAKING- BUT STILL A LOT
OF COMPLAINTS THAT'S A THIRD OF
THE COMPLAINTS IT'S GONNA TAKE
MORE THAN SIXTY DAYS FOR
EVALUATION SO. WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THOSE CASES AND HOW ARE
THESE GETTING DRAGGED OUT FOR
THESE COMPLAINTS HE ALSO MAKES
A COMPLAINT. SIXTY DAYS TWO
THIRDS OF THEM GET RESOLVED BUT
NOW WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
REMAINING THIRD ACCESS TO A LOT
OF CASES LEFT SO CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THAT TOO. SO ZERO SO CANCER
RESEARCH THANK YOU- SO. ON YOUR
FIRST POINT- LET YEAR THE-
DEPARTMENT FOR AN INCREASE OF
AND STAFF POSITIONS. AND WE
WERE GRANTED SIXTY SIX CAREER
POSITIONS IN A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN POSITIONS
OVERALL. OKAY THOSE POSITIONS
ARE BEING PHASED IN OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD. ARE THE
VACANCY RATE THAT YOU SEE HERE
IS A REFLECTION OF THE FACT
REMAINED LOST SOME MEMBERS OF
STAFF MEMBERS WHO HAVE CHOSEN
TO RETIRE EARLY OR RETIRED MORE
MORE. HIGHER RATES AND PRESS IN
PREVIOUS YEARS BUT ALSO
RECOGNITION THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
COMING ON BOARD AND WE'RE
TRYING TO RECRUIT AND TO OFFER
ENOUGH SO THAT KIND OF- WORK
WHERE WE NEED TO TEASE OUT A
LITTLE BIT BUT THAT'S KIND OF.
WHY WE'RE HAVING A PARTICULAR
VACANCY RATE OKAY SO NOT HAVING
A LOT OF TURNED AND REYES IS
THAT LIKE PEOPLE COMING IN AND
OUT ITS THAT OKAY WELL WE HAVE
A BASELINE OF COURSE SOME
PEOPLE RETIRE COBIT MIGHT TRY A
FEW MORE PEOPLE RETIRE BUT THEN
WE ALSO GET YOU MORE POSITIONS
SO WE JUST HAVEN'T BURKE.
READING RATHER SELL THOSE YES
TAKING LONGER TO FILL THEM
CORRECT CORRECTSURPRISINGLY WE
HAVEN'T SEEN AS MUCH OF A
TREASURY THOUGHT TO BE.
POSSIBLY COULD SEE AN
ABANDONMENT OKAY AS YOU CAN
WELL IMAGINE- STAFFER ON THE
FRONT LINES EVERY DAY MORE IN
THE BUILDINGS MUCH LIKE
HEALTHCARE. WORKERS THEMSELVES
AND SO. WE WERE. ABOUT THAT WE
MIGHT SEE A- GREATER UPTAKE. WE
HAVE REALLY SEEN A GREATER
UPTAKE AND- SO THIS. UPON OKAY-
FOR THE COMPLAINTS HE YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT WE ARE TRENDING DOWN
FROM WHAT WE HAVE REPORTED IN
PRIOR YEARS. THE PRIOR YEAR WE
ARE HIRING MORE ON THE 75%
COMPLETION WITH THEM SIXTY DAYS
SO WE ARE TRENDING DOWN OF THIS
LAST YEAR. PART OF THAT IS A
RECOGNITION THAT FOR THE FIRST
SEVERAL MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC.
THE DEPARTMENT REALLY STOOD
DOWN A LOT OF THIS
INVESTIGATION SB JANET OUR OUR
FEET. DECIDE HOW WE CAN GET P.
P. TO OUR STAFF FOR THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS- ANSWER THAT HAS
HAPPENED EFFECTIVE KIND OF
TEMPERING WHERE WE ARE AT WITH
WITH COMPLETING. ONGOING
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS.
INSTEAD WE HAVE GATHERED THE
NECESSARY PPD WE HAVE GOT OUR
STAFF BACK INTO THE WORK FORCE
INTO THESE BUILDINGS. WE ARE
DOING WE CAN- TO ADDRESS BOTH
THE CURRENT COMPLAINTS AS WELL
AS TRYING TO ADDRESS OUR
BACKLOG COMPLAINTS THAT THAT WE
HAVE. AND WE'RE DOING THAT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS-
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE TRYING TO
BATCH AS MANY COMPLAINTS AS
POSSIBLE. AT ONE TIME SO THAT
WHEN WE DO GO OUT TO
INVESTIGATE WE'RE NOT JUST
DOING ONE COMPLAINT WE'RE DOING
A COUPLE AT A TIME. COME AGAIN
THE PURPOSE IS TO MINIMIZE
BOTH- STATES THAT PRESENCE IN
THE BUILDING. BUT ALSO TO
MINIMIZE THE TIME THAT
OBVIOUSLY STAFF AFTER YOU STOP
WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO ANSWER
OUR QUESTIONS ARE COURT RECORDS
AND SO. WE ARE MINDFUL OF THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE ALL. THE
MEASURE OF WORK TO DO. WE ARE
BEGINNING TO FALL THOSE WHOSE
WORK WAS INTO MORE MORE
FREQUENT DISTANCE. AS WE
CONTINUE TO A KIND OF MODEL AND
BUNDLE AND YOUR STAFFERS BACK
INTO THESE BUILDINGS TO
COMPLETE THOSE INVESTIGATIONS
OKAY SO I APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION TO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE ON ONE HAND OF
COURSE WITH CODED IN. FACT THAT
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE AT RISK
AND NURSING HOMES- OBVIOUSLY
DESIRE FOR TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE FOLLOWING UP WITH
COMPLAINTS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. BUT I ALSO DO RECALL.
THAT WE HAD APPEARED A TIME
WHERE YOU KNOW WE HEARD FROM
THE THEN INSPECTOR THE NURSES
WHO- SAID THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE BP AND SO FORTH AND I
CERTAINLY CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU TOOK A POSSIBLY SURE THEY
HAD THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO
INCREASE OUR TURNOVER RATE
BECAUSE THEY DECIDED TO LEAVE
THE JOB BECAUSE THEN HE'LL BE
SAFE DOING IT SO. I THINK. I'D
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW AS WE GO
FORWARD THE FOLLOW UP SIR
LOOKING AT THESE THINGS IN
SAYING THAT OKAY THEREFORE WE
ARE NOW THAT WE HAVE THE P AND
SO FORTH YOU'RE DOING THE
BATCHING THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT WE'RE NOW STARTING TO
CATCH UP. SO THIS PERHAPS
REFLECTS MORE OF A- TEMPORARY
IT'S A TEMPORARY SITUATION
GIVEN THE SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR OF THAT
BE A CORRECT- WE LOOK AT IT.
ABSOLUTELY WE KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT IS HIS KIND OF
PILING UP- WE ARE TRYING TO
BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND- AS-
CONDITIONS. CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA WE HOPE TO BEGIN
RESUMING NORMAL RECIPROCATION
STORIES OF OUR BUILDING RIGHT
NOW THOSE THOSE ARE ON BECAUSE-
WE'RE DOING MORE EFFICIENT
ENABLE SERVICE ARE DOING MORE
MEDICATION STORIES IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE THE SUGGESTIONS. SO
WE'RE ANXIOUS AS AS WELL AS THE
STATE IN THE NATION TO GET BACK
TO BUSINESS AS USUAL. AND. SO
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD BACK THAT
CAN PASS ASK ME AND YOUR STUFF
AND BUILDINGS. WE RECOGNIZE
THOSE IN CRITICALLY. THAT FROM
A COMPLIANCE STAND. THAT THE
MESSAGES ARE DONE. THAT WE HOLD
STATE ACCOUNTABLE AND- AS- IN
THIS PART OF WHAT WE ARE. TO
REBUILD BACK INTO PASSED. THANK
YOU MUCH APPRECIATE IT. FURTHER
FROM L. A. O. OKAY. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE ON. SO
IF YOU WANT TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM I WILL GO AHEAD AND
DO SO THANK YOU. SO- THIS B. C.
PAY FOR HEALTH CARE- AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS- IN RESPONSE
TO SOME BUILT TWO THREE FIVE
THIS B. C. P. REQUEST ONE
POSITION AND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
FILLED HELLO I'M SORRY SIX
FIGURE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THEREAFTER. TO DELIBERATE
DELICIOUS FOR PPG STOCKPILES.
C. PH CON NEED TO WORK WITH A
PARTNER INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS.
THE TYPE AND AMOUNT OF PPH
MAINTAINED. THREE BILLION TO BE
MAINTAINED BY THE PROVIDER AS
THE TYPE AND SIZE OF EACH
PROVIDER AS WELL AS THE
COMPOSITION OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IN THIS WORKFORCE.
MISTER SAMPRAS BECAUSE-
RESEARCH ADVISED DIR AS IT
DEVELOPS REGULATIONS FOR THE PP
STOCKPILES. AND WITHOUT-
BECAUSE THERE ARE QUESTIONS.
HELLO PLEASE. OKAY DR PAN HELLO
NEXT INTO THAT LANE HAD NOTHING
OKAY ALL RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
FOR APPRECIATED AT THE MINUTES
MY BILL AND SO- APPRECIATE
WE'RE GETTING READY THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES STAFF
REQUIREMENTS. RIGHT NOW BEEN
NOTES- THIS PIECE OF PAPER
REQUEST SIX POSITIONS TO
INCLUDE EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE AND
ALSO REQUEST NINE OR THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN THE RAFTERS-
BRIDGES OF AB ANYONE WHICH
AFFECTS THE QUALITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA. AB AB
ONE EXTERNAL THE RIGHT SYSTEM
SUBMIT A REQUEST FOR AN APPEAL
TO A SKILLED NURSING FLAYED
WHO'S THE TERMINATION OF
NONCOMPLIANCE THE STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS DID NOT RESULT IN
A MONETARY PENALTY. THIS CHANGE
WILL RESULT IN AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF APPEALS FROM
SKILLED NURSING STAYS OFF FOR
ONE DAY NON COMPLIANCE- IS THIS
BASICALLY REQUIRES POSITIONS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO PREPARE
FOR THOSE MR OF HEARINGS AS
WELL AS REQUEST POSITIONS FOR
OUR OFFICE AND WE WILL SERVICES
WHICH WILL ALSO HELP TO FILL IN
THOSE- THOSE APPEALS WHEN THEY
GET TO. THE MYSTERY OF HEARING.
HELLO THE PART OF FINANCIAL. I
HAVE REVISED APRIL. THE ISSUE
NUMBER NINE TIMELY
INVESTIGATION OF CARE GIVERS
BUT YOU'RE- THIS B. C. P.
REQUEST SEVEN POSITIONS AND ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM I CAN
THROUGHOUT THE SCRIPTURES I'M
SORRY STATE FOR THREE YEARS
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IN THE
RAFTER TO ADDRESS AN ONGOING
INCREASE IN COMPLAINTS AGAINST
A LICENSE HEALTH CARE GIVERS
INCLUDING INCREASE OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS THAT WE CAN WE CAN
PRIORITY ONE FOR INVESTIGATION.
CCQ CONTINUES TO SEE A YEAR
OVER YEAR INCREASING
COMPLAINTS- EVEN THOUGH WE HAD
A DROP IN THOSE COMPLAINTS NOW
DO THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE THERE
ARE FEWER COMPLAINTS COMING AND
WE ARE SEEING A BACKLOG AND IN
THESE CASES AMOUNTING AND SO
THIS B. C. P. REQUEST OF
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY TO
ADDRESS A BACKLOG AND TO BECOME
CURRENT. OF IN HOLDING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE THAT-
MAY HAVE ABRIDGED ON PATIENT
RIGHTS OR VIOLATIONS. I THINK
THE YEAH HELLO. FINANCE. I
THINK THIS IS JUST. THIS IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT WILL BE
MONITORING THIS TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ENOUGH BECAUSE I THINK
JUST WITH THE EVERYONE AND IN
ISOLATION WE PROBABLY DON'T
KNOW THE LEVEL OF THINGS THAT
ARE OCCURRING OUT THERE AND
WILL PUBLIC INCLUDING.
EXPERIENCE A BACKLOG OF THINGS
COMING IN WHEN THINGS BEGIN TO
OPEN BACK UP AGAIN FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO GO VISIT
PEOPLE AND WE AND WE BEGIN TO
HEAR MORE DIRECTLY FROM
INDIVIDUALS. THAT. IN THE LAST
TIME THAT I WILL PRESENT.
MEDICAL BRIDGE FORCES. SB SIX
REQUEST SOME TEAMS ON TO PRESS
EXPERIENCE TO STAY AS WE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THEREAFTER TO
EXPAND THE OPERATION EDUCATION
SECTION TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING
REGULATIONS AND LAWS- COURSE
UNIFICATION VESTED IN A
NECESSARY MISTER PENALTIES
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS. AND OR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
CURRENTLY THE SECTION- HAS
ASSUME THE RESPONSE FOR THESE
INVESTIGATION FOR OR NINETEEN-
FIELD OFFICES THIS PCP WILL
COMPLETE THE CENTRALIZATION OF
ALL THESE INVESTIGATIONS INTO
ONE SECTION- BY EXPANDING THE
SECTION. AS WELL AS IN THE
INVESTIGATION WORKLOAD. EACH
THE HUMOR FREE UP THOSE NURSES
IN THOSE OFFICES ARE CURRENTLY
DOING THESE INVESTIGATIONS TO
ALLOW THEM TO GO BACK TO DOING
OTHER TYPES OF A WORKLOAD THAT
IS MORE- COMMISERATED KELSON'S.
WORKING SMARTER NOT HARDER-
ANYTHING FROM LA OF. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THE DEPEND OKAY THEN
LET'S MOVE ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MONICA MORALES I'M A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OVER THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES I'LL BE REVIEWING
ISSUE ELEVEN. STARKEL WOULD
REPLACE PUBLIC REPORTING SO
THIS IS A REFLECTION OF AN
ONGOING INCREASE OF SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND TO
MANAGE THE COPE WITH NINETEEN
WORKERS OUTBREAK REPORTING.
UPPER EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
THIS MANDATES EMPLOYERS TO
REPORT PUBLIC OUTBREAKS THAT-
DEPARTMENT THE LOCAL DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN RETURN THE
LOCAL DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH HERE AT THE
STATE. THIS MONEY WOULD SUPPORT
THREE F. T. E.'S TO DO DATA
COLLECTION CLEANING ANALYZING
AND REPORTING AS WELL AS
SUPPORT- THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR- CAL READY- DATA SYSTEM TO
ACTUALLY ACCEPT THE DATA. IN
ADDITION IT'S SUPPORTS CREATING
AND PUBLISHING EDUCATION OR
TRAINING MATERIALS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND THE POSTING OF
THE COLERIDGE OUTBREAK AND.
WORKPLACE DATA ON OUR WEBSITE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE OF FINANCE.
LU THE DEPEND. THANK YOU FOR
THAT PRESENTATION I'D- I WOULD
MAKE NOTE OF THESE THERE'S BEEN
SOME NEWS REPORTS THAT- AND I
REALIZED AS- WELL. THAT THE-
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFF
TO NOW THIS IS THE CAL
OCEANSIDE- THAT TO DO ENOUGH
INVESTIGATION SO APPRECIATE
WE'RE INCREASING SOME STAFF
HERE DO THAT AND I AM NOT SURE
WHAT THE PROPOSALS ON THE CAL
OCEANSIDE TERMS INSPECTORS FOR-
WORKED AT FOR REPORTING
OUTBREAKS AND WORKPLACES BUT-
IS THIS PROPOSAL IN
COORDINATION WITH- A SO IT
HURTS I'M HOPING THAT ON THE
CALLUSES SIDE AND SEEN IT YET-
IT. IS THAT THERE'S AN INCREASE
IN INSPECTORS THAT WE GET
BETTER REPORTING AND WORKPLACE
OUTBREAKS COBIT IS. THIS
PROPOSAL VENCORE WITH THAT SO
THAT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
MORE WORK PLACE BREAKS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE NEED FOR CD
PHD HELP OVERSEE TO THAT SO I
GUESS CAN YOU HE'S TO THAT
HOUSE AND IF WITH- CAL. ESCAPE.
YEAH DEFINITELY WERE WITH
KELLER VERY. BOTH ON YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT THAT WE CAN CAN TO
RUN WITH- EMPLOYER TO ENCOURAGE
AND GET EVERY. BUT ALSO SHE THE
DAY. INTO WITH THAT IN MIND WE
DEFINITELY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
OTHER PLANS THAT THEY'RE
WORKING ON IN TERMS OF- IT YET
DIET REALIZE YOU GUYS ARE
WORKING TOGETHER BUT I'M
TALKING TO CAPACITY SO IS THIS
SO BASICALLY. I GUESS- GIVEN
THE STAFFING A PROPOSING IT HOW-
HOW MUCH INCREASING CAPACITY
LIKE HERMES AND I REALIZE EACH
WORKPLACE OUTBREAK IS DIFFERENT
RIGHT NOW SOME ARE LARGER
SUMMER SMALLER BUT HOW MANY
MORE WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS DO YOU
THINK YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
MANAGE IN TERMS OF ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE OF THINGS-
WITH THIS INCREASED CAPACITY ON
HOW MUCH INCREASE CAPACITY WE
BUILDING IN WITH THIS PROPOSAL
IS THAT AND- I GUESS THE
FUNCTIONS ENOUGH BUT WHEN YOU
FIRST TELL ME HOW MUCH CAPACITY
I MIGHT HAVE ON WHAT
I THINK THAT'S ENOUGH OR NOT.
THANK GOD. THIS HELP SO RIGHT
NOW WE'REAVERAGING ABOUT A
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED REPORTS
OUTBREAK REPORTS MONTHLY AND
SO. FOR NOW WHAT WE ARE WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS THAT. THESE KEY
POSITIONS WILL BE ABLE TO. GO
THROUGH THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED CLEAN ANALYZE IT. AND
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE'RE
STRIVING FOR. I BET YOU KNOW
WE'RE WORKING OBVIOUSLY YOU
VERY CLOSELY WITH- THE REST OF
THE RESPONSE. TEAM JUST TO
ENSURING IN A CAR READY- CAL
READY COLLEAGUES AS WELL. TO
ENSURE THAT THIS IS- YOU KNOW
FOR WHAT WE BELIEVE. WE'VE DONE
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT WHAT WE NEED
FOR NOW TO KIND OF A CELL LINE
TO SELL WITH. AN INTERN
REFLECTIVE SO FOR GIVEN THIS
PROPOSAL. AND WE BRING THE
STAFF ON BOARD AND I KNOW YOU
HAVE TO CREATE SO FORTH. IS
THAT TO BE- HANDLE IS SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS OR
IS THAT SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS. ARE HOW
MANY WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS PER
MONTH GIVEN THIS LEVEL STAFFING
SHOULD. THESE STAFF AT OUR
DEATH- THIS ARE THE O. H. P.
BRANCH IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE. IN TERMS OF- NOW I
REALIZE THAT AGAIN IF YOU
AVERAGE IT ALL OUT AMONGST
THEM- TO BE ABLE TO DO ALL THE
FUNCTIONS THAT WE SHOULD BE
NEEDS TO DO- IN RESPONSE. TO
TWO OUTBREAKS. YEAH WE WORKED
WITH AGAIN WE WORK WITH A
SCIENCES FRANK KIND OF MAKE AN
SS. SO AT THE RATE THAT WE'RE
GOING BASS ON THE DATA. WE
THINK THAT FOR NOW THIS IS WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS MANAGEABLE FOR US
AND IF ANYTHING CHANGES
OBVIOUSLY IN TERMS OF THE
OUTBREAKS. AND WHAT WE'RE
NOTICING WE WILL HANDLE AND
THEN YOU KNOW. MY QUESTION WAS
THE CEMETERY HERE YOU SAID IT'S
A SUFFICIENT AND I A FIGURE
THAT'S WHAT YOU TRY TO PLAN FOR
BUT- SO HOW MANY OUTBREAKS PER
MONTH. IS THIS TEAM GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HANDLE IF. YOU. KNOW WE
APPROVE THIS AS YOU RECOMMENDED.
CAN YOU CAN GIVE ME A ROUGH
SCALE AS STATUS AS OF NOW HE
SAID RIGHT NOW IT'S SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED PER MONTH IS THIS.
DESIGNED FOR SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
PER MONTH IS THE SIGN FOR
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PER MONTH.
ROUGHLY REQUESTED YEAH YEAH I
THINK FOR NOW WE'RE DOING KIND
OF BEST ESTIMATE SCENARIO AND
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO KIND OF MANAGE. THE
CURRENT OUTBREAK I NUMBERS THAT
YEAH. AVERAGED SO WHAT YOU'RE-
WHAT I'M HEARING IS YOU KNOW
QUITE SAY IF IT'S AROUND THE
AROUND SEVENTEEN HUNDRED PER
MONTH RANGE. YES YES THEY CAN
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE- THE KEY
THING RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PUT THE SYSTEMS IN
PLACE THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE DATA SYSTEM TO COLLECTED.
THAT EDUCATION FOR THE
EMPLOYERS JUST REALLY TRYING TO
DO ALL OF THAT. ON YOU KNOW
RIGHT NOW AND THEN HOPEFULLY
ALL THOSE KEY PIECES ARE IN
PLACE. WE REALLY GET TO FOCUS
ON THE DATA CLEANING THE DATA
COLLECTION WORKING YOU KNOW
WHAT THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO CONTINUE. THAT
EDUCATION ON ENTERING THE
INFORMATION INTO THE SYSTEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO ALWAYS A
LIFT AT THE BEGINNING. THAT
ONCE THOSE. YOU KNOW- FUNCTIONS
ARE IN PLACE RIGHT THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO FOCUS OKAY. RIGHT I
GET THAT I APPRECIATE THAT I-
ALSO JUST MAKE AN OBSERVATION
IS AT LEAST- THERE ARE NEWS
REPORTS THAT. WE'RE NOT PICKING
UP AS MANY OUTBREAKS. ROGER OUT
THERE NOW OF COURSE IS WHAT IF
WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
PEOPLE BACK NAMELY DR NUMBER
CASES DOWN MAYBE THAT WILL THEN
HEAD DOWNWARDS. SO I JUST WANNA
BE SURE THAT- SO ANYWAY BECAUSE
WE APPROACH MAY WE'LL SEE WHERE
WE ARE THERE AND SEE- THE OTHER
THIS IS A SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
THE THINGS THAT YOU. WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH I THINK WE BOTH
WANT- THIS THE COMPLEX THANK
YOU. AND THEN ALL OF THE OTHERS
MAKE THE- THE STATEMENT ON THE
OBSERVATION. AS WELL AS WE AS
WE STAFF THIS UP AS WE AS WE
PREPARE FOR THIS. FIGHT UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT I JUST HOPE-
WORKING IN CONJUNCTION. WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE. AS FAR AS
TESTING- GOES AHEAD. JUST AN
EXAMPLE I WAS OUT OF THE FARMS.
CHICKEN TURKEY PLANT- BUKAN AND
WE KNOW THEY'VE HAD SOME SOME
ISSUES WITHOUT BREAKS BUT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE TESTING IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST AT
ALL. WITH TESTING FOR THEM. IT
WOULD HAVE TAKEN IT WAS TAKEN
TWO WEEKS THAT AT THAT TIME IN
MERCED COUNTY- AND PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN CROWDED SITUATIONS
AND PEOPLE ARE CARPOOLING IN
WAYS THAT- ARE ARE. ARE
DIFFICULT TO START WITH-
INDEPENDENT OUTBREAK OF TWELVE
IN A IN A FACILITY THAT THAT
EMPLOYEES. TWO THOUSAND- AND
INTEND TO POST AND THEN TO TRY
TO TEST AND ISOLATE AND
CONTRACTOR USE- IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO ON ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND AS WE WERE
GOING INTO- PACKING SHOULD
SEASON. PICKING SEASON I THINK
WE'RE JUST HAVE TO BE VERY
AWARE THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
MORE OF THIS AND WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED. IF AN OUTBREAK OCCURS
TO BE ABLE TO GO IN A FULLY
SUPPORT AROUND TESTING AROUND
ISOLATING ABOUT CONTRACT
RACING. IT'S ALL GOING TO WORK
AS A SYSTEM AS IT WAS INTENDED
TO DO. BUT SOMETIMES WE HAVE
GAPS IN IN OUR BEST LAID PLANS.
OKAY. TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE. I GET A LITTLE
TO DO NOT A NOTED THAT- I JUST
SAY IS THAT THIS IS CERTAINLY
NOT AN EXPRESSION OF LACK OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS NO NO I THINK
THIS IS JUST ME SHOWING SCALE
TO THE RIGHT SKILLED DOING
SKILL TO THE RIDICULOUS CARE
ACT AND IF WE DON'T FORGET.
THERE'S OTHER PARTS. THAT ARE
INVOLVED WITH THIS. THIS ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE SUPPORT ALL
TIMERS SO I'LL CONTINUE WITH
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS
SUPPORT FOR ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
AWARENESS REGION TRAINING THIS
REFLECTS A SEVENTEEN MILLION
MILLION GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION
FOR ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE PROGRAM
YOU'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON FIVE
KEY AREAS STARTING WITH- OUR
RESEARCH PROGRAMS GRANTS
FOCUSING ON WOMEN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR- IN OTHER
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
POPULATIONS. THE SECOND-
STRATEGIES A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN FOCUSING ON REALLY
KINDA EDUCATING OUR PUBLIC ON
THE SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS OF
ALZHEIMER'S THIRD IS OUR CARE
GIVER TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM OF REALLY
FOCUSING TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE BASED DEMENTIA RELATED
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
STRATEGIES FOR. I IN CAREGIVERS.
NUMBER FOUR WE LOOKING AT NO
CHALLENGE BLUES DOWN CHALLENGE
GRANTS FOR COMMUNITIES ARE
REALLY LOOKING AT HELPING THOSE
THAT ARE MOST PREPARED AND
WILLING TO ADDRESS ELSE TIMERS-
IN RELATED TO- RISK FACTORS
PERTAINING TO ALZHEIMER'S. AND
THEN FINALLY THE FIFTH ONE IS A
STATEWIDE STANDARD OF CARE FOR
DEMENTIA REALLY LOOKING AT THE
SPECTRUM OF NO DETECTION
DIAGNOSIS TREATMENT AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW CARE DECISIONS
THROUGHOUT REGRESSION AND-
OUTSIDERS. I'LL STOP THERE AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE HELLO.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I DON'T
HAVE A THIRD PATH. ACTUALLY HE
JUST GOT IT CAN YOU JUST
QUESTION NUMBER TWO THE MEASURE
IS A PLAN TO DRESS THE OTHER
FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS THE TASK
FORCE. PLEASE STAND AGAIN JOBS
WILL FINANCE- READ ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL BASED ON AVAILABLE
RESOURCES. ABOUT TEN.
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THIS
PARTICULAR TASK FORCE. THIS
ISN'T THE END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ENGAGEMENT ON
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA I KNOW
THIS IS A VERY HIGH PRIORITY
FOR THE GOVERNOR- RIGHT I CAN'T
SHERRY SPECIFIC PROPOSALS NOW
BUT WE- WE IDENTIFIED SOME KEY
AREAS WITHOUT WE CAN MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ON FUNDED
THOSE- AS THE BUSINESSES STANDS
TODAY BUT CLEARLY- THERE'S A
LOT MORE WORK TO BE DONE. DON'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC PROPOSAL FOR
THE OTHER FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THAT TASK FORCE AT THIS
TIME- BUT- WOULD HAVE TO TALK
THROUGH WHAT WITH US NOW OKAY
BUT SHE THAT- THAT PRECEDE THE
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE OTHER ONES CERTAINLY
THIS BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE AND I
KNOW I MYSELF HAVE BEEN ALSO
WORKING TO BE SURE TO FIND OUT-
ALTAR. WAYS TO FINANCE LONG
TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES-
WHICH OF COURSE IS KEY TO THE
ALZHEIMER'S POPULATION AS WELL
AND SO LOOKING FOR TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I KNOW THERE'S A
BIG CONVERSATIONS- BUT THAT'S
HOW WE'RE GOING AS WE TRY TO
DRESS AGING ISSUES SO- JUST
WANT TO PUT A PEN ON THE FOLLOW.
UP ON THE REMAINING
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN AND
PARKINSON'S. HI AGAIN THIS IS
MONICA MORALIS- DISCUSSING
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS
OUR PARKING STASYS REGISTRY SO
THIS REFLECTS A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS. FROM
GENERAL FUND TO CONTINUE OUR
OUTREACH AND SURVEILLANCE
EFFORTS PERTAINING TO
PARKINSON'S SO- AS PER AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE THE
CHECK STANDARD AUTHORITY TO
CONTINUE AT THE DATA COLLECTION
AND THIS FINDING WITH SUPPORT
TO FTP IS TO CONTINUE THE DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND
REPORTING. AS WELL AS OUTREACH
TO HEALTH SYSTEMS TO CONTINUE-
OUR PARTNERSHIP PREVENTIVE
VIEW. REPORTING INTO THE SYSTEM
ITSELF SO WITHOUT. PAUSE AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
HELLO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPEND OKAY QUESTIONS ARE NOT
FOUR HOURS THAT NUMBER FOURTEEN
WHAT PROGRAM ESTIMATES. THAT
AFTERNOON I'M CHRISTINE NELSON
FROM THE DEPARTMENT. PUBLIC
HEALTH WEIGHT DIVISION. THE
WAIT PROGRAMS ACROSS THE NATION
HAVE BEEN JUST HAVE BEEN SEEING
DECLINES IN PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IN CALIFORNIA
WE EXPERIENCED INCREASES IN
MARCH AND APRIL OF LAST YEAR
AND THEN MINOR INCREASES EACH
MONTH AFTER THAT. OUR CURRENT
YEAR ESTIMATE IS NOW NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS PER MONTH. WHICH
MATCHES OUR ACTUAL NUMBER FOR
LAST MONTH NEARLY EXACTLY OUR
BUDGET YEAR ESTIMATE IS NOW
NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS FOR MY-
IN. JANUARY OF TWO THE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO LAST
WINTER WE SERVE NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
COMPARISON TO FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY WE WERE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND NINE THOUSAND SO WE'VE
EXPERIENCED AN 18% INCREASE.
SINCE A COUPLE OF HOPE IT
PANDEMIC BEGAN AND MOST OF THAT
INCREASE WAS IN MARCH AND APRIL
OF LAST YEAR. THIS
PARTICIPATION CHANGE RESULTS IN
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN FOOD
EXPENDITURES. OUR CURRENT YEAR
ESTIMATE IS NOW SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOOD WHICH IS A ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OR 17% INCREASE FROM
THE BUDGET ACT. OUR BUDGET YEAR
ESTIMATE IS EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FOOD. AND THERE'S NO CHANGE TO
OTHER LOCAL SYSTEMS FOR STATE
OPERATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
MONITORING MONTHLY
PARTICIPATION CHANGES WE ALSO
LOOK AT ACTUAL PARTICIPATION AS
A PERCENTAGE OF ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS. ARE UNDER US
DEPARTMENT AGRICULTURE PRODUCES
THE ESTIMATE OF ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS USING THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY AND THAT'S
ALWAYS A COUPLE OF YEARS
BEHIND. THE LATEST USDA PROGRAM
REACHED RECORD WAS ISSUED IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
AND INCLUDED TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DATA. IN THAT REPORT CALIFORNIA
WHICH SERVED 61% OR ONE POINT
ONE MILLION PEOPLE OF OUR
ELIGIBLE POPULATION. WHILE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE WAS FIFTY ONE
PERCENT. THE ONLY STATE WITH A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE THAN
CALIFORNIA WAS MARYLAND WHO
SERVED ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE OR 64% OF
THEIR POPULATION. WE'RE
EXPECTING A NEW REPORT WITH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DATA ANY TIME
NOW AND CAN SHARE THAT WITH
STAFF WE RECEIVE THAT. USTA'S
GRANTED STATES MANY WAIVERS TO
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT WORKS SERVICES CAN BE
PROVIDED SAFELY. THESE WAIVERS
ARE IN PLACE UNTIL THIRTY DAYS
AFTER THE END OF THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY IS DECLARED. EXAMPLES
OF WAIVERS INCLUDE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ALL INDIVIDUALS SEEKING TO
ENROLL OR RE ENROLL AND WHAT DO
SO IN PERSON. REQUIREMENTS THAT
TRANSACTIONS HAPPEN IN THE
PRESENCE OF THE CASHIER WOULD
DISAPPEAR YOUR TOP ONLINE
SHOPPING. ALLOWING FOR REMOTE
INSURANCE OF BENEFITS AND
ALLOWING OTHER FOOD OPTIONS ONE
WEEK FOODS ARE NOT AVAILABLE IN
LOCAL STORES. REMOTE SERVICES
FOR ENROLLMENT IN NUTRITION
EDUCATION CERTAINLY TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO
PARTICIPATE AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALSO HAVE GOOD ENGAGEMENT
WITH THESE FAMILIES. IDEALIST
FAMILIES HAVE WILL HAVE A
CHOICE FOR WHAT BEST MEETS
THEIR NEEDS. REGARDING ONLINE
SHOPPING WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR EASY T. SERVICE
PROVIDER. INTERESTED STORES FOR
SHORT TERM SOLUTION AND THERE'S
ALSO WORK HAPPENING AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL TO PURSUE
VARIOUS OPTIONS FOR LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS. SINCE THE WAIVER FOR
IN PERSON TRANSACTIONS I
TEMPORARY IT MAY NOT BE
APPEALING TO STORES TO INVEST
IN CHANGES TO THEIR ONLINE
SHOPPING WEB PAGES AND SYSTEMS.
KNOWING THAT IT MAY JUST BE A
TEMPORARY FIX. THIS WEEK THE
NATIONAL WITH A SOLICITATION
RELEASED THEIR INAUGURAL STATE
OF WORK REPORT THAT HAS A LOT
OF GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT
DIFFERENT WAIVERS THAT HAVE
BEEN. ENACTED AND THEIR
POSITION ON SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. OKAY THE HELLO.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. IT IS
INTERESTING AT THE YOUR PROGRAM
HAS GROWN WELL WE HEARD FROM
CALFRESH THAT THERE'S HAS
ACTUALLY DECREASED SO- YOUR YOU
ARE YOU ARE SOMEHOW MEETING THE
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE AND WHAT
PART OF THAT DO YOU THINK
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE.
POST PANDEMIC. THAT IS THAT IS
EFFECTIVELY ALLOWED YOU TO WORK
WITH MY CLIENTS. WELL I THINK
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHANGES HAS
BEEN A BY NOT REQUIRING PEOPLE
TO PHYSICALLY COME INTO THE
WEBSITE BEING ABLE TO TíNH
PHONE. AND VIDEO APPOINTMENTS
THAT IS ONE OF THE TEMPORARY
WAIVERS FROM USDA AND THERE
SPEND A LOT OF REQUESTS FROM
LOCAL AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION IS ALSO
WORKING AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
TO PURSUE THAT IS NOT A
PERMANENT CHANGE. MORE
PERMANENT GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU THIRTY DIFFERENT. THANK YOU
FOR A PRESENT. I THINK WHAT I'M
TRYING TO CORRELATE THINK IS A
CHAIR IS THE DATA WE HAVE FROM
OTHER PROGRAMS RIGHT SELF
SAMPLE WE'VE ACTUALLY CAL
WORKS- WE- SEE INCREASED RITA
CALFRESH IS AND- AND SO. DEARLY
IT BE INTERESTED WHEN WE
APPROACH MAY REVISE WHETHER FOR
EXAMPLE. THERE MAY BE A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE LET'S SAY ON
UNEMPLOYMENT AND THEN FILE DOWN
A PLANE IT IS ENDING OR ON THE
P. AWAY OR WHATEVER AND THEN
SUDDENLY NOW WE'RE GONNA SEE A-
CASE INCREASE. I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE A MENTIONED YET HE'S
INCREASE OF 18% LAST SPRING THE
WEATHER TO BE ANOTHER BUMP IN
CASES. AS UNFORTUNATELY MADE A
GROUP OF PEOPLE. AND
UNEMPLOYMENT AND I'M UNABLE TO
FIND WORK- WE KNOW THAT A LOT
OF WOMEN UNFORTUNATELY ARE NOT
ABLE TO RETURN TO THE WORKFORCE
BECAUSE OF- CHILD CARE SAID NO
SCHOOLS ARE STILL CLOSED AT
CETERA. AND WHETHER THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT IN THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR OR NOT THAT
WE- WELL I WOULD SAY NOT
ANTICIPATING BUT THAT WE. WE
MAY NOT BE AND WORK. PLANNING
FOR AT AT THE NUMBERS YET AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY.
OBSERVER WHETHER YOU THAT'S A-
THAT THAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBERS YOU'RE LOOKING
AT WORK. SO OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
FLAT. SEEN LESS THAN I.
PROBABLY HALF A PERCENTAGE
INCREASE EACH MONTH- SO WE'RE
JUST CONTINUE TO WAIT AND SEE
THERE'S BEEN CHANGES HAPPENING
IN NYC CALIFORNIA AGREEMENT YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL TEMPORARY
BENEFITS. SO WE- HAVE BEEN.
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED AT THAT
SOMETIMES THAT PEOPLE ARE
CONTINUING. TO COME IN EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE GETTING INITIAL
POSITIONAL BENEFIT WE THINK
THAT A LOT OF THE SERVICES THAT
WE PROVIDE. OUR I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN A WAY THAT IT'S
NOT JUST THE FOOD PROGRAM BUT
AS THE ADDITIONAL NUTRITION
EDUCATION BREASTFEEDING SUPPORT
THAT WE OFFER TO FAMILIES.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO. HAVE DO
THAT VIRTUALLY NO AND
TELEFONICA. YES YES WE CONTINUE
TO DO THAT. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN BUCKS
FOR LOW INCOME CHILDREN. HELLO
MY NAME IS KATHERINE LOPEZ AND
I AM THE ASSISTANT DIVISION
CHIEF THAT WAY. AND WE'RE
REQUESTING A ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY FOR
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR IN
STATE OPERATIONS TO ALLOW THE
TRANSFER OF FUNDS TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FOR AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD LITERACY PROGRAM PER
WEEK PARTICIPANTS. THE BOOK FOR
KIDS PROPOSAL IS TO MAKE BOOKS
AVAILABLE FOR INSTANCE YEAR
OLD'S YOUR EIGHTY THREE LOCAL
AGENCIES MIXERS OVER. SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
THIS AGE GROW. PARENT OR
CARETAKER ENGAGE WITH THEIR
WICKLUND TWICE A YEAR AND- AS
CHRIS STATED THAT HAS BEEN-
REMEMBER PART ONLINE THE LAST
ON MONTHS- BUT NORMALLY THEY
COME INTO THE OFFICE AND THIS
IS A STRATEGIC TIME FOR HIS
PARENTS YES. BEGIN EARLY
READING ANTIBIOTICS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. WITH ANTICIPATED SO
WE COULD PURCHASE ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION BOOKS WITH
THESE FUNDS AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THE PLAN
IS A REQUIREMENT FOR WHAT LOCAL
AGENCIES TO WORK WITH THEIR
LOCAL FIRST FIVE COMMISSIONS.
TO AVOID THE DUPLICATION OF
EFFORTS FANTASY GUIDANCE ON ON
BOOK SELECTION. IN WITHOUT A
THIRTY QUESTION. GO TO THE
FINANCE MOST L. W. OKAY BUT THE
I'VE SERVED ON THE BOARD OF A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM AND I JUST VITALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET BOOKS AND
PARENTS AND KIDS ALL TOGETHER
AND ENGAGING IN A HEALTHY
PROPERS. A DEFENSE. YES I
ACTUALLY AGREE AND SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IN PROGRAMS
LIKE REACH OUT AND READ- WHICH
AUTHORS. THAT PHYSICIANSOFFICES CERTAINLY WAKE OFFICES
ARE GREAT SOURCES WELL BUT I
KNOW THIS IS A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE SO IS THIS FIVE
MILLION FOR JUST ONE YEAR OR IS
THIS FIVE MILLION OVER A FEW
YEARS ARE. IS SO JUST TO
CLARIFY WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
RIGHT WE ANTICIPATE IT IS A ONE
TIME BUT WE ANTICIPATE THEY'LL
BE CARE UP- TIME THAT WILL NEED
TO ACTUALLY. GET THE BOOKS-
SELECT AND GET THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES IDENTIFY. AND PROVIDE.
THE LOCAL AGENCIES WITH THE
SMALL PRIMER ON HOW TO
INTEGRATE. INTO THEIR- INTO A
REGULAR APPOINTMENT WITH THEIR
LOCAL AGENCIES. AND SO IT WILL
GO THROUGH WILL IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN- AND- OKAY WILL BE ONE
TIME OKAY SELL IT SO I GET THAT
SO OBVIOUSLY TAKE SOME TIME TO
GEAR UP BUT I MEAN ALL RIGHT
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT YOUR UPS
WE TAKE Y. REMAINING MONEY WE
HAVE BY A WHOLE BUNCH OF BOOKS
AND THEN SEND THEM OUT AND
THAT'S IT. OR. IS THERE SOME. I
NEED TO ASK YOU REALLY HOT
QUESTION. THAT THAT'S OF THE
REASONS WHY ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WERE INCLUDING DIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FIRST
FIVE COMMISSION. BECAUSE
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE FIRST FIVE COMMISSION AND
WILL ADD ADDITIONAL- I SUPPOSE
POINTS ARE NOT- PROPOSAL
PROCESS. THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
SORT OF SUSTAINABILITY- POSTED.
ON THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OKAY WELL AGAIN EVERY GREAT
IDEA- I'M JUST ITSELF LET
CERTAINLY WILL HAVE SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY AND TIMELINES-
BY ME REVISED THANK YOU. AND
I'M SERVICES I'M ASSUMING
THERE'S ALSO AN EVALUATION
COMPONENT OF THIS SO WE CAN WE
CAN WE CAN SEE THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY MAKING A DIFFERENCE I
KNOW ABOUT THE PEDIATRICIAN
PROGRAM SO WE'RE SWITCHING TO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT HOW DO WE
KNOW ESPECIALLY IN A MORE
VIRTUAL WORLD. THE PROCESS OF
ACTUALLY GETTING THE BOOKS OUT
AND IF IT'S GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND IF THE SAME.
TEACHING THAT OCCURRED AT THE%
PEDIATRICIAN'S OFFICE WILL.
ALSO OCCUR. THROUGH THE WITH.
COME CORRECT SIR THE WHIMS
CONSIDERED AT PROBABLY ONE OR
PROCESS OF VALUE BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
TIME- BUILT INTO RUSSIA SAID
THE FUNDS BUILT INTO THE
PROPOSAL BUT WE WILL DEFINITELY
BE CONDUCTING A- PROCESS
EVALUATION FOLLOWING BEST
PRACTICES. USING EVIDENCE
INFORMS OUR EVIDENCE BASED-
READING PROCESSES SO THAT. YEAH
THAT PROCESS EVALUATION WE- CAN
MAKE SOME ASSUMPTIONS BASED ON
THE OUTCOME. OKAY ANOTHER
NUMBER NINETY DEPARTMENT HUH
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR WOMAN IF
YOU BOUGHT BY COULD BE
ACKNOWLEDGED ON THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FAMILY HEALTH PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I JUST WANTED TO ADD TO WHAT-
HAS BEEN PROVIDED IN THE KIND
OF RESPONSE TO- WHAT DOCTOR
POUND HOUSE- HAS RAISED UP. IS
THAT THIS OPPORTUNITY ALL. GIVE
US KIND OF- A SUPPORT AND
ENERGY AND PART OF OUR GRANTING
PROCESS WILL ASK THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. DEMONSTRATES OUR
ABILITY TO COLLABORATE BUT ONE
OF THE MAJOR COLLABORATORS WILL
ALSO BE LIBRARIES- WE THINK
THAT YOU KNOW BRINGING
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE
FOSTERING THAT. BEING ABLE TO
GET THE BOOKS OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BUT THEN- CONSISTS
BURKE ON. AND SUPPORT PARENTS A
LOCAL AGENCIES TO UNDERSTAND
HOW VALUABLE THE LOCAL
LIBRARIES OURSELVES WE
UNDERSTAND HIS SUSTAINABILITY
QUESTION. AND WE HOPE. TO
INCORPORATE THAT INTO THE
GROUND TO COST. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS OKAY BUT ISSUE
SIXTEEN GENETIC DISEASE
SCREENING PROGRAM THREE IT WAS
FINANCE BUT TO SAY SOMETHING
THOUGH I'M SURE I DIDN'T JACK
JACK WE GO TO TALK SPEAK. NO I
DON'T THINK I HAVE. ANYTHING AT
THIS TIME CHRISTIANSEN OKAY ALL
RIGHT I THOUGHT I BETTER NOT
TRYING TO SAY SOMETHING THE
DIRECTOR. OKAY THEN WE'LL GO
BACK TO ISSUE SIXTEEN. JERICK
DISEASE SCREENING PROGRAM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- CENTER
PAM THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HI MY NAME'S
RICHARD ALL ME AND I AM A
DIVISION CHIEF FOR THE CITY PH
OF GENERIC SCREENING PROGRAMMER
GST. EMAIL JUDY OF BUDGET
SUPPORT ACTIVITY GO THROUGH PRO.
THE MANDATORY CALIFORNIA
NEWBORN SCREENING PROGRAMS THAT
ARE STATEWIDE VOLUNTARY
CALIFORNIA PRENATAL SCREENING
PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS THE PNS
PROGRAM. SO COMPARED TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT WITH
EXPENDITURES OF ALMOST A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE MILLION-
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
EXPENDITURE ELEVEN YOU IMMATURE
RELATIVELY FLAT WITH ONLY A
SLIGHT. DECREASE IS DUE TO A
DECREASE IN PROJECTED NUMBER OF
LIVE BIRTHS. WHICH AFFECTS BOTH
ONES REMAINING PNS PROGRAM.
HOWEVER. FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR PROJECT YOU
MORE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES- 2%
INCREASE IN EXPENDITURE-
MERRILY DUE TO OUR B. C. P. FOR
APPROVING THE PIANOS PROGRAM
WHICH WILL DRAW SHORTLY. THE B.
C. D. INCLUDES A NET INCREASE
OF TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS MANAGERS TO IMPROVE THE
PNS PROGRAM. BY ADDING FIRST
LINE CELL FREE DNA SCREENING-
ST OF. JULY WITH CURRENT
STANDARDS OF CARE FOR PRENATAL
GENETIC SCREENING. THIS
INCREASES FOR BOTH STATE
OPERATIONS STAFF WORKING AND
IMPROVE MONTHLY POSITION A ONE
TIME INCREASE AND LOCAL SYSTEM
COST. OF A GRADE FOR
INFORMATION SYSTEM THE
CONFIGURATION FROM OTHER
READERS DOT. WE ARE PROJECTING
A VERY SMALL THAT INCREASING
REVENUE FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- WITH THE INCREASED
EXPENDITURES THE SPECIAL FUND
BALANCE IS EXPECTING THROUGH
DECREASED 3% STORKE FUTURE
FISCAL ISSUE BEYOND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AM COULD THE LEFTY
INCREASE THAT WOULD ADDRESS ON
BELL. SO THAT'S IT FOR THIS
ISSUE BEFORE MOVING ON TO THE
B. C. B. R. RUNNING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE- HELLO THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THIRTY PM OKAY IT'S
GOING TO SEVENTEEN. OKAY SO
ISSUE SEVENTEEN OF THEIR B.
THREE P. WHICH IS A REQUEST FOR
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR A
REDESIGN OF OUR PIANIST PROGRAM.
THE RESOURCES WILL BE NECESSARY
TO MODERNIZE THE PROGRAM BY
REPLACING THE CURRENT
BIOCHEMICAL SCREENING FOR
CHROMOSOMAL ABNORMALITIES SUCH
AS DOWN SYNDROME. WITH AN
INNOVATIVE SCREENING
METHODOLOGY NORMAL CELL FREE
DNA WHICH ANALYZED THE FETAL
DNA CIRCULATING IN THE TALIBAN.
REQUIRE A SPECIAL BEING
LABORATORY METHODS SUCH AS DNA
SEQUENCING. OUR PRINCE ALFRED
JANET NOW CONSIDER THE STANDARD
OF CARE OF PRENATAL SCREENING
BY NATIONAL MEDICAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
WOMAN FOR GENETIC AND GENOMIC.
THE CHRIS WELCOME SAFETY CODE
MANDATES THAT WE EXPAND
PRENATAL SCREENING FOR ME AND
THE BOOK CARE. WE HAVE THE DATA
INDICATE IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE CURRENTLY IN EQUITY WHEN WE
USE OF COURSE FIND IT AT THE
END OF THE SCREEN. OKAY LOOK
AREA THE MORE SELECT.
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS AND GOAL OF
PIANOS PROGRAM IS ALWAYS GOING
TO PROMOTE WITH THE SERVER. IN
ADDITION TO HAVE IT'S GOING
WORKS FOR BECAUSE CHEN I IN THE-
WITH THEM MORE ACCURATELY. AND
EXTENSIVELY LOMBARDO CHEMICAL
SCREENING. AND ALSO RESULT IN A
LOWER FALSE POSITIVE RATE. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE EXPECT
ANNUAL SAVINGS OF APPROXIMATELY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
DECREASES IN THE WHOLE WORLD
FOR FOLLOW UP. IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE ONE WEEK
ONCE YOU HAVE BEEN IN SCREEN.
DURING TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO WE WILL USE THE REQUESTED
STAFF ONE TIME FUNDING GROUP
PRELAUNCH ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
REDESIGNING PLUS MAILERS. M.
AFFIRMATIVE WAS SCREEN PROBLEM
AND CHANGING OUR SCREENING
INFORMATION TO THEM TO MORE
COMEDY NEW UNIT SCREENING OF
ALL TRANSMITTED. FROM A
CONTRACTED LAB LABORATORY. SO I
DRESS IN THE QUESTION ON THE
AGENDA ABOUT THE USE OF-
CONTRACT. OUR CURRENT PIANOS
MODEL USES CONTRACTED REGIONAL
LABORATORY BUT- CONTRACTOR NOT
INCLUDE IN THE TECHNOLOGY SO WE
ARE CURRENTLY PLANNING TO
CONTRACT WITH THE DNA LAB OR
LABORATORY. WILL PREVENT
EXPERIENCE ONE SECOND PIPELINE
FROM INTERPRETATION. TO PROVIDE
RELIABLE AND ACCURATE TESTING.
HIGH THROUGHPUT ENVIRONMENT.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO W.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON BOTH THESE
ISSUES AND APPRECIATE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS- GOING TO
REMAINING ON THE FOREFRONT OF-
OF BOTH PRENATAL AND- NEWBORN
SCREENING SO THAT- WE CAN KEEP
THE- PEOPLE SAFE HERE. I DID
HAVE A QUESTION YOU MENTIONED
THAT- IN TERMS OF THE
CONTRACTING FOR THE WITH THE
LABORATORY THAT PREVIOUSLY YOU
AS YOU CHANGING TECHNOLOGY
CHANGING THE CONTRACT- IS HE
JUST MAYBE SPEAK TO- THE NEED
TO CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE
LABORATORY VERSES BE ABLE TO DO
IT IN HOUSE IS IT. THAT HE JUST
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE I GUESS YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU READY
CONTRACT WITH REGIONAL
LABORATORY SO YOU DIDN'T DO
THAT IN HOUSE EITHER- FOR THE
PRENATAL SCREENING. SO HE JUST
SPEAK TO ONE WHY CONTRACTING
OUT THAT THIS OUT MAKES MORE
SENSE THAN BRING A HOUSE OR IS
THERE PLANNED EVENTUALLY BRING
IT IN HOUSE. RIGHT WELL THE-
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE US EMBASSY
CONCERNING. QUIT BIOINFORMATICS
AND SO FORTH ARE. REALLY BEYOND
THE CAPACITY OF A LOT OF US TO
DO IT IN HOUSE OKAY- RIGHT NOW.
OR EVEN IN OUR REGIONAL
LABORATORIES WHICH IS WORKING
ON A SCREEN CURRENTLY CURVES-
YEAH I REMAIN OPEN QUESTION
WHETHER COULD BE BROADENED
HEALTH PROVINCIAL IT BUT-
DEFINITELY NOT POOR START UP
ACTIVITY. OKAY SO I THINK WOULD
BE IN IN YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
THIS IS. DEPENDING ON PRICE
COMPETITIVENESS OTHER THINGS
WHETHER THAT'S SOMETHING IT'S
PAST YOU WANT TO BRING IN HOUSE
OR NOT IN THE FUTURE RECENTLY
RECOGNIZING THAT IN THE
BEGINNING- YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THAT COMES THE END OF OUR
AGENDA ANYTHING FURTHER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
FIRST THING FURTHER FROM.
ANYTHING FURTHER CONTENT ALL
RIGHT AS A SINCERELY APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S HARD WORK AND
PRESENTATION AND GETTING READY
FOR THIS- AND OUR CONTINUED
WORK GOING FORWARD- BUT IT IS
NOW THE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE. SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN
SIX ZERO NINE AGAIN I WOULD ASK
THAT EVERYONE- TURN OFF YOUR
DEVICES WHEN YOU'RE SPEAKING I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU TRY TO
MAINTAIN YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE- BY THE END I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE ANYBODY IN THE IN
THE WITNESS FROM CORRECT WE'RE
ALL REMOTE. OKAY MODERATOR YOU
THERE. WELL I'M HERE I'M HERE
OKAY- FIRST CALLER PLEASE. OKAY
AS REMINDERS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT. CAN YOU TELL
ME THE AMOUNT OF ONE AND THEN
ZERO CAN YOU TELL ME THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE IN THE WAITING ROOM.
CERTAINLY. WE HAVE NINE IN Q.
RIGHT NOW OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU'RE WELCOME AND AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE THIRTEEN
ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MANAGER AND VENDORS
THIS IS M. J. D. AS ON BEHALF
OF S. B. R. U. CALIFORNIA.
UNDER ISSUE TWELVE WE SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION FUNDING
TOWARD COMBATING ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE. FIFTY FIFTY FOUR CARE
GIVER CAREGIVER TRAINING BUT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THE TRAINING
CENTER SHOULD BE UTILISING
EXISTING ENTITY. I SECONDLY ON
THE CALL THAT LADY I AM UNDER
ISSUE ONE AND TWO WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR CONTINUED
INVESTMENT INTO PDF PATTERSON
AT EIGHT STOCKPILE BACKWARDS
ALL HEALTH CARE AND FINANCIAL
WORKERS. AND ALSO LEVERAGING
FEDERAL INVESTMENT TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE- BUT AS YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR WE SPONSORED SB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE- AND THAT BILL
STILL LACKS A FUNDING SOURCE.
THEREFORE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND THE STATE
PP STOCKPILE TO ENSURE WE ARE
READY FOR THE NEXT PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTBREAK. AND LASTLY
YEAH YOU ALONGSIDE OUR
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT
COALITION. ARE WE ALL STRONGLY
SUPPORT OUR BUDGET REQUEST FOR
STATE ONGOING INVESTMENT OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR TO
REBUILD OUR CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THIS
SPECIFIC BUDGET ACT ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTY. THE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ELEVEN ONE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS- THIS IS DAN OPEN
BECAUSE PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
AND I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE TOO HIGH ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE TO THAT COULD
MAKE A PANDEMIC- WE'RE JUST
HERE TO COMMUNICATE OUR
FRUSTRATION WITH THE CURRENT
PRIORITIZATION AND DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS OF THE- COLOR NINETEEN
VEXING. I REQUEST SUPPORT
VACCINE OLDER ADULTS ARE AT
HIGHER RISK OF BOTH THE CENTRAL
WORKERS. WILL BE ABLE TO HAVING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT THE ONCE YOU LEVEL. WHICH
IS THE SAME LEVEL OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION. AND SEE IF
I'LL SEE- WE RECOMMEND THAT
PEOPLE DISABILITY MOVED UP FROM
ONE C. TO ONE B. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
AT NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. OUR
NEXT SPEAKER IS LINE SEVENTEEN
ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND ASKING HIM TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF AND
ASSEMBLY PARTNERSHIP. WE ARE
PLEASED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
LEFT FULL THE COMPANY PANDEMIC
DIMINISH OUR ABILITY TO SERVE
FAMILIES DUE TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE. FOLKS I'M
LOOKING IF WE HEIGHTENING THE
NEED FOR HOME VISITING SERVICES
TO VULNERABLE PREGNANT WOMEN IN
THERE AND THEN THE MOST AT RISK
OF THE ILLNESS AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND IF YOU PROVIDE SERVICES TO
FIRST TIME PREGNANT WOMEN OR
NEWBORN. WE HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN DELIVERED TO COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT MANY OF OUR
NURSES WILL BE FIND A COMMON
RESPONSE BACK IN DELIVERY
NEVERTHELESS AN APPEARED THE-
FIRST FAMILIES THROUGH
TELEHEALTH VISITS. COVERED
STOPPING ROTATIONS ALLOW IN
THIS REPORT IS CRITICALLY
NEEDED TO MAINTAIN NORMAL LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS.
CLEARLY COUNTIES NEED
ADDITIONAL STAFFING RESOURCES
PARTICULARLY INTERESTING TO
MEET THESE DEMANDS AS SUCH WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTION PROPOSAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUILD OUT
HUNDRED PPH. I WISHING HAPPY
THING ABOUT. OF THE CAL KIND OF
FAMILY. WE URGE YOU TO COME THE
NEED OF SMALL PRIMARY CARE FOR.
IN UNDER SERVING UNDER
COMMUNITIES LIKE WHICH THESE.
IMPACT ROLLOUT PLANNING AND- SO
THAT WE CAN EFFECTIVELY TARGET
THE ETHNIC DISPARITIES THAT
WERE TRYING TO AVOID. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE'RE GONNA LINE
NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M FARE ON
THE DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES I
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE-
COMMITTEE AND SAID JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR APPROVING. THE MORE THAN
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO COME TO
COUNTY BY MARCH FIRST WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT WE'RE ALSO
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT IN THAT
HUNDRED DOLLARS. ONGOING
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I WOULD YOU WANT TO
STAY ON THE BACKSEAT ALLOCATION
ISSUE THAT- WE ARE AT COUNTIES
ARE AGE PARTNERS NOT JUST
ANOTHER PROVIDER IN THIS ISSUE
AND THAT WERE VERY CONCERNED
THAT BACKED US ACCEDE READ MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. I THINK
BACK NEEDS TO BE FIRED BUT IT'S
FOR THAT REASON LASTLY WE
CONTINUE IN OUR QUEST FOR
ACCURATE DATA ONE OF THE STATE
IS WORKING HARD ON THAT AS
WELL- AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
A CLEARER PICTURE. OF THE ISSUE
THANK YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS BIGGER PLACE. HELLO
TWENTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DIANA DOUGLAS ON BEHALF
OF HEALTH AT THAT CALIFORNIA
AFFECTED SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ABOUT
FUNDING FOR BACK. AND IT
IMPLEMENTED WITH EFFICIENCY
ACCORDING IN THE FOREFRONT IT
WILL RESULT IN A MAKE YOUR
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN LIFE
STATE AND A QUICKER RECOVERY
INCREASE FUNDING WILL ALSO
REDUCE BARRIERS AND USED IN THE
LOGISTICAL LAST MILE OF ACTING
DISTRIBUTION WITH THAT WORK
AND- LIVE- ALSO IN FAVOR. OF
PUBLIC. FUNDING BOTH NOW AND
THE FUTURE CONTINUE. SUPPORT OF
A STRONG PUBLIC INTEREST THAT
HAS THE RESPECT THAT. RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY ESPECIALLY IN OUR
MOST VULNERABLE TO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. OUR NEXT
SPEAKERS LINE SIXTEEN ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHARACTERS SO-
REPRESENTING THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WELL I WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ISSUED BY
ALL THE SUPPORT FOR ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AWARENESS RESEARCH AND
TRAINING THE BILL THE PROPOSED
SEVENTY MILLION OF THE GREAT
START IMPLEMENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S PASSPORTS
RECOMMENDATION AND ALZHEIMER'S
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE BIG MASTER PLAN. WORK BURKE
CITED THIS THE THAT YEAR'S
FOCUS ON PUBLIC HEALTH AS OUR
ASSOCIATION LOOK AT ALZHEIMER'S
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR WERE EXCITED TO SEE
MORE SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION WHICH IS FUNDED IN
THE PROPOSAL SUPPORT FOR CARE
GIVER TO DEFENDANT IN THE
PROPOSAL AND SUPPORT FOR A
STATEWIDE STANDARD OF THE MAGIC
CARE IN ADDITION TO THE ITEMS
REGARDING RESEARCH AND WE'VE
DONE. WE HOPE THAT THIS THAT
THROUGH THIS BUDGET- PROCESS WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THESE PROPOSALS
BUILD UPON THE GOOD WORK ON IT
BECAUSE LEGISLATIVE SESSION AS
WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION
PASSWORD MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
PROPERTIES. AND ARE TARGETED
THROUGH AN EQUITY LINES AND
THAT REMAINS THE PRIORITY FOR
ASSOCIATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THESE ITEMS MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTH. ONE
FOR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT
AFTERNOON MY CHAIR AND BY
CANNELLA. REPRESENTING ALL
LEVINE ALL CONVERGE ONCE AND
ALZHEIMER'S ECHO AND WE WANT
TESTIFY FOR OF AN INCH WELL.
WEEKLY THAT IT COULD INITIAL-
ONE TIME WE UNDERSTAND ONE TIME.
BUT WE GET THE ONGOING COVERAGE
LOOKING FOR TO HAVE A THOSE AND
LOOKING PART OF WITH YOU STAFF
AND GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION BY ON. SENATE
AND WITH CHIEF WITHOUT THE THAT
THE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER. OUR NEXT IS MY EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBER I'M FROM THE CASTEEL AN
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH AND WE
ALSO ASK ABOUT COMMENTS ABOUT
THE NEED TO STRENGTHEN OUR
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ADDRESS
CALIFORNIANS OTHER PRESSING
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS TO HAVE
BEEN DEFERRED AND CONTINUE TO
GET WORSE AND ARE COMPOUNDED
BY. HOPE AND- ALEXANDER FOUNDER
OF THE PUBLIC- PUBLIC HEALTH IN
BEST ILLUSTRATED BY THE RAPID
RISE OF SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
DISEASES THAT WERE ALREADY BY
ROCKETING. TO CRISIS LEVEL
BEFORE HOLDEN IT. NEARLY A
QUARTER OF A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WERE INFECTED WITH
SYPHILIS CHLAMYDIA OR GONORRHEA
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THEN
CURRENT NUMBERS ARE ESTIMATED
TO BE MUCH HIGHER. FIND THAT
THIS EPIDEMIC OF THE NEGLECTED
FOR FAR TOO LONG HAVE ALREADY
MANIFESTED IN ALARMING WAYS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE CDC CONFIRMED-
IN SEPTEMBER THAT THERE IS A
NEW ANTIBIOTIC RESISTANT STRAIN
OF GONORRHEA THAT IS WRITING
ACROSS ENTRY THE NEW MEXICO
THAT CRISIS. AND OUR OWN
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUED AN ALERT IN DECEMBER
ABOUT THE RISING NUMBERSOF
DISSEMINATED GONOCOCCAL
INFECTIONS WHICH IS A SEVERE
COMPLICATION OF UNTREATED
UNTREATED GONORRHEA THAT THE
BRAND BUT PROP BODY THROUGH THE
BLOODSTREAM. IS UNLIKELY TO
RESULT THE PEOPLE NOT KEEPING
AN STD TESTING AND TREATMENT.
DURING THE- AND THEN L. A.
COUNTY. MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
B. WERE WITH CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS IN TWO. AND THE COST
OF OUR INACTION IS ARGUED TO
CONTINUE IGNORING BECAUSE
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IS SPENT ANNUALLY IN
OUR STATE ON HEALTH. HEALTH
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT HE-
AND FELLOW ALTHOUGH OUR
REPUBLIC OF CRISIS IS AFFECTING
ALL COMMUNITIES IT IT USED.
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND GAVE BISEXUAL AND
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
THIS IS NOW A SOCIAL JUSTICE
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE THAT MUST
BE ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY AND SO
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP
THIS IN MIND WHILE ASSESSING
THE STATE BUDGET AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK- FOR
TODAY AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE. WORKING WITH YOU ON
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
SO TWO SIX LINE IS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE SELLING OF OUR OWN
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT I DIDN'T
WANT TO FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN.
WE AGREE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD INVEST IN A
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE TO THE
CRISIS RESULTING FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN THAT CRITICAL
REPERCUSSIONS OF CALIFORNIA TO
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN FAMILIES.
PARTICULARLY THOSE FROM LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
LINE ITEM ONE WE SUPPORT A
COORDINATED PLANNING AND
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FOR VACCINE
EDUCATION AND DISTRIBUTION TO
ENSURE ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE
KNOWLEDGE AS AN ACT OF ACTING.
KILLER TO THE PRIORITY
POPULATION. FOR VACCINE SAFETY
AND AFFECT. I TOOK A PICTURE
ITEM. I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND MEDIC HELP CHILDREN
ARE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE BUT NOT
IN HOLDING WEAK AND WE
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT FOR OUR
STATE PROGRAMS TO COORDINATE
AMONG THEMSELVES JUST
STREAMLINED ENROLLMENT FOR
THOSE. THE STATE KNOWS ARE
ELIGIBLE. REGARDING ITEM
FIFTEEN PCT SHARE THE VALUE OF
INCREASED INVESTMENT IN BOOKS
FOR CHILDREN AS A KEY RESOURCE
FOR THEIR COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT. HILL AND
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE EFFORT WE
ALSO FIND AN URGENT AND GROWING
NEED TO SUPPORT YOUNG
CHILDREN'S SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AS A WAY TO PROMOTE
POSITIVE MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
LATER IN LIFE. AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO IDENTIFY AND
SUPPORT INVESTMENTS THAT
PROMOTE EARLY CHILDHOOD SOCIO
EMOTIONAL LEARNING ALONGSIDE
SIMILAR BATHROOM BURKE EIGHT
EIGHT. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WEEK REPLACE. WE WERE
GO TO LINE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF MANY MCCARTY MOMENT
HERE AND I'M CALLING FROM A
DIFFERENT THE CREATE FOUNDATION
ON BEHALF OFTHE AND THE
EPIDEMIC COALITION- AND ONE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE FOCUS WE STATE HEARING
ON THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH.
SYSTEM AND SPECIFICALLY THE
CALLED IN RESPONSE. AND SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT ALSO
ALLOW THE OF COURSE RECOGNIZE
THAT BECAUSE THAT IS AND THE
HIGHEST STATE PRIORITY RIGHT%
NOW FIFTY PH AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- WE DID NOT WANT AT
LEAST THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHER ON GOING PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM AND THEY- ARE.
LIKELY THAT I'M GOING TO SEND
AMERICAN HIV VIRAL HEPATITIS I
GUESS EITHER UP OR DOWN. IT
DOESN'T HIGHER ATTENTION TO A
COUPLE OF LINKS BETWEEN SIX THE
STATE. OF THE FIRST ROUND. THE
STATE STD EPIDEMIC. I NEW CASE
ARE AT PLUS THE TWENTY THIRD.
AND CASES OF CONSENT CENTRAL
ARE A NEARLY 100% SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. EVERYTHING THAT
THEY CAN INCREASE OVER. WERE
RATED UP. 100% AND AFTER TO
FENTANYL UP 8100% THE FUNNY.
AND OF COURSE THESE CRAZY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AT THE
VERY SAME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
NOW. BEARING THE BRUNT. OF THE-
THREE- THE COMMITTEE OUT OF
YOUR ON THE STATE COLLECTS.
MAKE OUT WITH MY- FIGHT IF I
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES AT THE- AT.
WORLD. WITHOUT MY A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL TO THE THESE THAT WE
ARE MET THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY. NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER LINE TWENTY
THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANASTASIA
CALL JOKE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
VISORS ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES. PERSONAL
WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE ARE
COMMON WITH THE SPEAKERS FROM
THE H. E. B. HEALTH OFFICERS
AND OUR OTHER LOCAL HEALTH
PARTNERS REGARDING THE NEED FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN ADDITION I
WOULD LIKE TO READ A BRIEF
STATEMENT FROM OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DR HERALD GOLDSTINE.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS CENTRAL TO
ADDRESSING MANY OF THE PRESSING
EQUITY AETIUS SPEAKING
CALIFORNIA BOB AND BEYOND THE
CALL THAT YOU CAN MAKE.
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA HOMELESSNESS
CHRONIC DISEASE PUT SAFETY
MENTAL HEALTH AND WATER QUALITY
AND PUBLIC SAFETY THE
LEGISLATURE CAN'T WAIT. TO
INVEST IN CRITICAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN RESPOND TO
THESE ISSUES NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE OUR LIFE AND LIFE OF OUR
CHILDREN. LITERALLY DEPEND ON
IT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
OUR LAST SPEAKER IN Q. DEADLINE
TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. YOU MAY
JOIN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION INSTRUCTING THE
NEED FOR EQUITY ON OUR VACCINE
ROLLOUT THE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM THAT
FOCUSES EXCLUSIVELY ON AGE
WOULD REINFORCE THE DISPARITIES
THAT ARE BEING LAID BARE BY
CORBETT NINETEEN. CNA
RECOMMENDS THAT VACCINE
ALLOCATIONS CONSIDER MORBIDITY
AND TRANSMISSION RATES AND
COMMUNITY WITH ALLOCATIONS
WEIGHTED TOWARD THOSE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
RATE TRANSMISSION ENACTING THE
MINISTRY- AND HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES. THE
BE PAIRED CONCERTED OUTREACH TO
POPULATIONS WITH IN THE THOSE
COMMUNITIES AT HIGHEST RISK ONE
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF REACHING
COMMUNITIES IS MOBILIZING THE
EXISTING HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADMINISTER
THE- ASSET PLAN CREATORS.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD B ABLE TO
GET BACK YOU NEED TO DO THEIR
OWN DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR CLINIC.
BASED ON A RECENT CMA SURVEY OF
COMMUNITY PHYSICIAN PRACTICES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA POSITION HAVE
BOTH THE CAPACITY AND INTEREST
IN ADMINISTERING THE- RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO UTILIZE THESE
PRACTICES. TO ADMINISTER THEM
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME AND I'M SURE THERE
ARE NO. ALL RIGHT WELL IF THAT
IS THE END OF OUR CALLERS THAT
DRAWS ARE ADHERING TO A
CONCLUSION- YOUR OPINION IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO US IF YOU
DIDN'T OR WEREN'T ABLE TO GET
ON YOU YOU CAN STILL EMAIL- ARE
BUDGET SAFF WITH ANY INPUT
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE. AND WITH
THAT I WILL ADJOURN BUDGET SUB.